[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
for chess continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40s oh no
we were worried that he overthought the
advantage oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
oh no the choreographers
that means that's actually gotta be
super intimidating if you're playing a
car when he puts on the code
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
miss amigos we say adios to daddy wrench
but we say hello to the venue here in
madrid the palacio de santonio it's
round 10 of the 2022 feed it candidates
we see it is bright it is sunny and we
also see the spanish commentary getting
set up people trickling into the live
audience they will be there ready to
listen to all the great commentary a
view from the playing hall it is a
lovely scene every single time the
artwork is there the players are getting
set and
well i'm
happy to be rejoined by international
master el miros kripchenko we have grand
master daniel naradiski i'm grand master
robert hess and almira welcome back
thank you so much i'm so happy to be
back and robert i have a question you
know who let the dogs out you know if i
summarize this well you know i went out
of town for the weekend you know those
guys three party almost every day and i
come back and i find like a few dead
bodies in the living room
well round nine was definitely a
decisive day you guys see some bottles
on the ah it's this water bottle
i was wondering what you were doing
there you scared me for a second well
done welcome back how was your rest day
here albert rest day was amazing it's
been years since i've been to europe so
i just took a long aimless walk around
madrid i was at the center
i mean i just remembered how beautiful
europe is and it occurred to me that
it's so fitting that a tournament of
this importance and of this magnitude is
taking place in a city that's beautiful
for sure the city is beautiful and the
chest has been beautiful so let's remind
everybody what happened before the rest
day we saw alireza ferrugia win with the
white pieces as did team over java and
dingle run they scored their first
victories with white but amirah all eyes
were on that game that was ending in the
draw between five minute carwana and
yonder palmicide
oh yes that was such a crucial game for
yon nipumneshi
he defunded very well first of all he
used the petrov opening against someone
who is a patrol specialist fabiano
caruana he played this opening against
magnus carlsen from the world
championship match so
it was so important not to lose this
game
and well but we have another three
decisive results in this round yeah
donna what did you make of those three
victories i mean all of them were
fascinating
in particular rajaba victory over
nakamura that was a big deal that was
timor's first victory not only in this
tournament but in the last couple of
years it was an excellent game
and uh ding
he missed several chances throughout the
tournament and finally uh the day before
yesterday he was firing on all cylinders
an excellent end game and of course
perugia report well that game kind of
speaks for itself doesn't it yeah
there's a lot of flair there not just
because the fashion that rich report
shows every round well we want to show
you remind you what happened in round 9
between alireza frugia and richard
report
ali reza ferrugia gained a big advantage
in the opening against richard rapport
as he set up the pawn break f4 then he
ripped things open with his first
brilliant move of the game knight takes
e5 a pawn sacrifice that gained a
powerful unopposed dark squared bishop
[Music]
after an inaccurate follow-up by ali
reza rapport got back in the game and
may even have been better in some crazy
lines he could have even castled on the
queen side
then the fatal bishop to c4 allowed ali
reza to play the winning rook to f5 he
followed up with consecutive brilliant
moves sacrificing the exchange both
times and placing a monster of a bishop
on d6 apparently you had three brilliant
moves according to our game review and
julia don't get banned again
beautiful checkmates loomed i mean i was
going to say this if you take on e5 in
that game oh
yeah if we can show this pawn takes e5
queen f8 is a little bit of a check and
then rook takes back and then
a little bit of a mate yeah can't take
it oh why not why not oh
report evaded being checkmated and made
the time control but ali reza's heroic
dark squared bishop delivered the final
blow picking off the under-defended
knight on e5 and forcing resignation
alireza received his first conceding
handshake of the tournament
[Music]
well that was a fantastic game by
alireza frugia and also a fantastic
interview we had him here in the studio
almer what did you make of his mindset
and his thoughts well first of all i
liked the interview so much
while it was very insightful and
interesting but there was one thing that
betrayed him alvarez was very calm
as always but he said that you know this
was a very important victory against
richard report who is the player in form
so this victory counts and actually we
were speculating a lot about the
pressure if he feels like well is he
going to win the tournament or not but i
think that what he's worried about is
that
he needs to prove that he belong here
you know so that was very important to
him to win to score his first first
victory yes as we look at the standings
we see he certainly does belong this
tournament he jumped from the bottom
where yanchez of duda currently resides
back towards the middle tied for fifth
place so dania as you look from top to
bottom standings what's sticking out to
you well i can't take my eyes off of
first place there's a small difference
jan there's a six in front of his
uh point total for fabi there's a five
and for hicaru there is a four so we
keep talking about is it a three horse
race is it a two horse race and if yon
wins today it just might be a one horse
race so really all eyes are in yan he's
got the white pieces hit a huge game but
of course those in the peloton fabi
ikaru ding all of them are going to have
to come through again and again if they
want to seriously challenge young for
first place and of course we focus on
the top half of the standings but maybe
too much amir as we look at the bottom
half of the standings these four players
can still make a major impact in the
tournament yes but there is one player
who is all alone at the bottom of the
standings and it's young shisht of duda
you know
there were so many interesting articles
uh uh well published on chess.com and
like were given
trying to prognose like who is going to
win the tournament but it seems that
mathematics confirmed that the only
player who will not win this tournament
is young she should do that because he
was before the tournament he was given
like the lowest chances to win it and
also uh as i remember correctly i think
he has also the lowest score against the
field so uh this prediction seemed to be
correct you know it's a good thing that
these people are not mathematicians
they're chess players and they will
settle the score over the chess board
and one player who says that he's hungry
is ali reza faruja he came to the studio
saying i'm happy with that first victory
but one might not be enough and almira
as we look forward in his schedule
what do you see there
well first of all he is facing hikaru
nakamura today with black they play
their first over the board game game
here actually and that was one of the
most intense games that i've witnessed
especially as a professional chess
player
so he will try to keep the momentum like
he won
his first game hikaru lost
with well with black against timur jabez
so he certainly is
will be aggressive today and will try to
to win this game that's a good point
hikaru might be upset obviously already
is the highest form of the tournament
but donya as we look forward for ali
reza he is going to play a major role in
the outcome this term he may not win it
himself but if we highlight round 11
with the white piece against john not
very important not really why you're
pointing that out nor is round 14 with
blacken's five-minute carona yeah last
john against fabby who just might want
to turn yeah i don't know what there is
really to talk about but in all
seriousness round 11 my eyes are on that
matchup he will have the white pieces
and the important question i think in
terms of determining the chances for
round 11 is how ali reza will do today
because if he carries forward his
momentum
if he manages to win with the black
pieces today jan is going to be
shivering in his bed tonight because ali
reza on a roll is a force to be reckoned
with so jan is rooting for nakamura ali
reza is obviously rooting for himself
but round 11 and round 14 against baby
those are going to be ones to watch so
cancel your meetings cancel your dinners
and your flights for those days it's
hard to shiver here the other days in
madrid because it is so hot but speaking
of players who are on a hospital room's
cold
that's a you problem but yandapamishi
he's on a hot streak he's been
performing extremely well preparation is
there and he caught up with dina
bellancaya after his round 9 draw
congratulations on such an important uh
opening preparation storm safe
when did you realize you were
calming things down
i think after 93
okay actually after he took on five
because i thought it's like bishop f1 on
bishop c2 but both was very promising
for it and
i mean at first i just didn't see this
idea like that the bishop can just
retreat from d3 i thought okay bishop f5
and then okay all this line if 93 and
it's a joe
but once we came to this position i
realized that okay
he is not obliged to take on f5 and this
appears to be very suspicious so i mean
okay but
uh what i did was
as it seemed to me more or less only
moves after after i played this 96
because i ran into queen a4 which is
extremely unpleasant and i believe if
not queen a4 it's like maybe slightly
worse for black but i can just stabilize
like knight c7 i don't know bishop f6 g6
something like this he has a very solid
position
but yes and i also couldn't recall any
of my prep because surely i have some
but yeah i just decided to play you know
on my own
which
i think was not the optimal way
now having played fabi
will your sleep be better approaching
the five next rounds
uh i hope so but uh
i mean in general attention is uh
you know it never goes away until the
last round so it's
it's still extremely tense
right yeah and once again
congratulations and uh good luck
thank you
and as you heard from jan napomshi he
may not be shivering but he is tense
almira he is a target on his back he's
been the lead for many rounds now do you
think that he can handle this tension
well he certainly has a target on his
back but what strikes me the most uh
from this interview is that he doesn't
show any sign of weakness i mean
physically he looks
very in shape you know we were
discussing like the point of if he will
be able to keep
to keep up with the steady performance
and seems that he's doing very well he
certainly is and well he's been
performing well thus far but he needs to
keep it up in round 10 there are some
juicy matchups in store for us i'll
mirror why don't we start with you
richard report with the white pieces
against dingley wren that should be a
fun one well this is actually the game
that i was looking uh
forward for
during this round because i went through
richard openings and he is certainly
very creative player we we have said
this well numerous times but
he's one of the uh last romantic players
who still uses the king's gambit you
know in his games and not on the rapid
games and classical games and i hope we
will be able to show you one of his
games in this opening and ding plays e5
so probably well
we should understand what state of mind
richard is in now he lost his two games
so he's probably on tilt so he might
as well go for it it's very possible we
never know what to expect from richard
report and donna um john chase of duda
he's been struggling he's lost a couple
games in row now five under carwana in
second place needs a win but has the
black pieces what do you see happening
in that second game well speaking of
tilt both dude and carolina they're
pretty frustrated right now in the case
of jkd we've seen it in his body
language we've seen it in this play he's
disappointed the tournament hasn't been
going well he hasn't caught a single
break even against dingley ren two days
ago he
had a very workable position in the
equal end game but he screwed that one
up fabi did the same against
janupomnishi he managed to make a draw
but that was a very winnable game so i
think there's going to be a
psychological battle that takes place
off the board as well who will be able
to push their previous results out of
their mind both of them are going to be
angry and hungry for a victory i'm
excited for a very combative game and
i'll mirror the next matchup between yon
napomishi and timur
neither of those players want to forget
their most recent results because
they've just had a win for a java of a
nice draw with black for napashi what do
you think's gonna happen there well
i think that daniel just mentioned you
know the beginning of the psychological
warfare but i think that um jan is going
to be very aggressive with white once
again because
in the first leg of these candidates
they drew their game but it seemed that
temu just
made a very insipid draw so is it going
to be punished for this attitude
and let's see but the score also speaks
for itself uh jan never won against him
or a job of suki
it's
an extra incentive for him okay and
danya
how about hakkar versus alareza well i
think this is the matchup that makes any
chess lovers mouth water
including mine they've only played once
it was in this tournament
and that is honestly what elevates this
matchup to the level of fascinating
because it's so rare these days at the
top level to have two players who
essentially have never faced each other
add to that the fact that
hikaru is a lot of fans perugia has a
ton of fans we both love these players
for their combative confident nature for
their playing styles it's an unstoppable
force against an immovable object we are
going to see who's going to get the
upper hand well it's a good thing now
that you have to vote because these
matchups are difficult to predict now
that burden is squarely on my shoulders
while danny's on his flight back home so
let's do it go to chess.com events i'm
going to get a danny wrench position oh
get off
snuggle into the chair okay first
matchup between richard report and
dingley wren over here like a blanket
i'm gonna go with a win
for dingley ren with the black pieces
not every day we pick a win with black
at the highest level but dingley wren he
won a game report is up and down and i
think it's going to be another down so
we're going to dig dingley rent in our
next match up yan chistop duda five
minute carwana i think i'm gonna
surprise people i'm gonna go with five
beyond a car one with the black pieces
once more he's showing great preparation
yanchez of duda clearly devastated in
the last couple games at the chessboard
so five minute karwan with the black
pieces yonder palm shield timor java
that is essential for our standings i'm
going with jan he seems to be an
unstoppable force and i do not think
that rajab is going to be the immovable
object that he'll need to to hold off
the leader of this 20 22 feet of
candidates and last but certainly not
least we have hikaru nakamura against
ali raza fruga i think it's going to be
combative but i think it's going to be a
draw just like the first game between
these two so if you're at home you don't
have to slouch like i was but you should
get involved with the voting go to
chess.com events pick your choices as to
the results of today's games you could
win a thousand dollars for first and
just like alireza fruger was asked hey
can you get a dime membership you can if
you get between six and ten but look at
dean lee wren he is as focused as i've
ever seen he's thinking about that
diamond membership you get if he comes
sixth
and i i was mentioning david bernstein
you know at some of uh well in our
previous rounds you know he was coming
at the board 10 minutes before the game
and in order to get this
uh state of absolute concentration so
dings looks exactly like david bernstein
well richard report i don't know who he
looks like he looks like a fashion model
often in this event but he is seated at
the board he gets the first move
advantage and that
that's the view that everybody wants
these two players hikaru nakamura ali
raza farouja hey alexander christina the
chess cleanser there we go
i was just gonna say on on the topic of
vikar he took off his uh his blazer
which means he doesn't expect to win
this game in under 10 minutes
oh and richard report playing e4 mirrors
you guys can't see this but she's uh you
know it's the second move
we gotta be watching she's clasping her
hands excited for potential kings gambit
and i mean richard he doesn't look that
happy and probably because he lost the
previous round
he's got that conspiratorial smile so i
think the king's gambit might be on the
cards let's not forget that against jkd
he did play the gleck system four nights
followed by kingside fianchetto i think
you'll settle for that omira that's
offbeat enough right okay the first
moves are played maybe let's uh well
allele blue first of all you know
oh i wanted to say this oh ali raza
faruja he brings his c pawn forward
against the carnage more playing the
sicilian that often leads us to sharp
variations and he is probably looking to
play for more than just equality with
black
no
i'm sorry i'm so sorry i know you won
the king's gambit but the knight is in
the pawns way in the upper left-hand
side of the screen between richard
report and dingley wren and as we stay
here in our bird's eye view we see an
italian game from beyonce dude in the
top right against fabiano caruana we see
caruana once again wearing blue he wore
a lot of white dress shirts throughout
the event now he's uh in blue and
well in the bottom left we see yonda
pomshy instead of playing e4
he goes to a catalan
yeah
and
that's not a particularly surprising
choice i think there's no question that
jan wants to preserve solidity he's not
going to play you know king's gambit or
any kind of gambit for that matter he
wants to play something that affords him
winning chances yet something that is
solid we were talking about that after
his game against ding maybe something a
little bit more spicy and i think he's
responded the catalan is by no means an
opening that you play if you want to
guarantee a draw amir am i accurate of
course i agree with you and it is such
an interesting and reach opening because
it has this um range of the positions
which are very different you know you
can have a very positional game and but
on the other hand it could go
it could be very tactical well at some
point it could get very tactical at some
point well it might start that way
because it looks like rajab has just
captured that opponent on c4 weren't
familiar with territory and one sort of
philosophical question i had about this
opening choice by yom napomishi he beat
yanches of duda playing knight f3
instead of his typical e4 he also beat
lexenko at the previous candidates with
a catalan so do you think it just brings
him happy memories and that's his new
comfort zone despite it being a rare
choice by him over the last few years
well it's of course uh
well it's a rare choice on his behalf
but i think that he has analyzed the
catalan uh for a while and especially i
remember the games against magnus you
know where he had uh well the with the
opposite colors so i think he would he
tried to analyze this opening with both
colors and to understand the nuances so
you're saying if magnus does it we
should probably do it too of course
just making sure i understood you
correctly um so which game should we
start on they all look interesting i
feel like we can go to this game between
yonda pomshi and timor rijaba just
because that is the player in first
place in yondu pomshi looking to use
that first move advantage for java
looking to build upon his draw in
his win in the previous round his first
win in classical chess in three years so
let's head back to the beginning just to
go over how we got here
it was d4 played by yon so not the
king's pawn which we've grown accustomed
to seeing from him and
as we get through the early stages here
this is all standard favorite bishop g2
black castles white does the same and
after d takes e4 i guess this is maybe
our first interesting moment dania where
you have choice between queen c2 or
queen to a4 yeah i've played this a lot
from the black side so i feel
i feel like i'm pretty much at home in
this position there's a third move which
is 95
which at various points has been very
popular
but has kind of waned in popularity
recently as black has found pretty much
foolproof ways toward equality now
there's a very interesting difference
between queen c2 and quinn a4
after queen c2
the traditional move here has always
been a6 and in a moment i'll get to why
that has changed recently and after a6
uh the move queen c2 affords white the
extra option of delaying the capture on
c4 and first playing a4 this is actually
the line which most gm's uh have been
relying on
to fight for the advantage in the last
couple of years but about a year ago
hikaru nakamura started religiously
playing the move which timur jabba has
just made and even before hikaru the
young american phenom christopher yu i
think he might have been the first to
introduce this move to the top level b5
but it's not this move itself this new
robert just to conclude my thought after
b5
a4
the traditional way to play this is to
play b4 and say hey i'm going to give up
that c4 pawn you can take it but in
christopher use innovation black plays
the crazy looking move bishop b7 which
timur's just played and meets a takes b5
with a6 a gambit from the black side
and elmira i guess i have to ask you are
you surprised at all that jan
at this moment here he could play queen
a4 play very solidly because there's no
b5 with the queen's staring at that
square so are you surprised that yon
allows b5 which is more complicated well
i'm not surprised at all because unless
there is a very forced line which leads
to to an equal position
jan wants to take risks in this game
like
rationally because this victory can
secure him the victory in the tournament
if he wins this game he's so much closer
to win the candidates and i think most
viewers you know saying risk-free
position looking for a possible edge
they look at this position say uh
there's a pawn on c7 a pawn on c4 those
aren't going to be good and yan develops
with knight to c3 so i always felt that
white shouldn't have any risk whatsoever
so i agree with you on that front
almirah and i guess i asked elmira what
you talked about jan's choice dania what
do you think of rajab of choice to enter
this line which we know he's played
before yeah i mean rajab is taking the
risk that jan took in the previous round
he's playing something that he knows jan
probably expects what does that tell us
well that basically tells us that he
believes in the line
so much that he believes he knows all of
the nuances and he believes that even if
jan throws a curveball at him he's going
to be able to improvise successfully
over the board
time will tell if that's the right
choice or if he should have chosen
something that would have surprised down
a little bit more right now they're
heading down one of the main lines of
this new b5 variation white's going to
take on a8 black's going to recapture
white's going to take on b5 and as far
as i can remember the move is bishop a8
to d5 very clever move you're hiding the
contact between the queen and the d4
pawn if the white knight returns from b5
to c3 all of a sudden bishop takes f3
and queen takes c4 black grabs that pawn
position remains very complicated but i
think black has been pretty successful
in this position i'm absolutely
mesmerized by those
well amira if we were to get to this
position that we're analyzing it still
feels like yonder palm she has no risk
he's down to pawn but the pawns are
doubled here on the c file so
i think what you're saying and i'm
agreeing with is that jan picks a very
good choice to play the catalan and a
line where it seems like his losing
chances are diminished and
have a look at those powerful bishops
certain well he lost central pound of
course but
he has a pair of bishops which
guarantees him a sufficient compensation
for the sacrifice bond and in a long
like run i think he will be able to win
the c4 pawn
so
uh i think that timur ajab needs to be
very sure of the line that he is playing
right now yes and well they're both away
from the board so
we've talked about the outlines of this
position black is trying to stabilize
white seems to have a pretty decent
position without major risk so as we
bring us
us back to all four games i mean i'm
looking at the top right and we've seen
this opening before
it was in the game between ali raza
faruja and timor java where they played
over 90 moves in seven half hours but it
started with a bishop that was on b3
taking this bishop on e6 and that means
that black has this double pawn
structure to
stay for the rest of the game pretty
much and knight h5 as you can see
played by fabi and that is a very very
typical move two more job have also
played this move it sets up a bunch of
threats on the king side i'm gonna say
right now what i said as i was
commentating that game i would be really
scared to play this position from the
white side open f-file bishop on a7
skewering the diagonal knight coming to
f4 but
the the white players they usually
believe in the queen side pressure and
they believe
uh that they've got enough pieces on the
king side they've got enough firepower
to tamp down
any attacking chances that black can
generate by putting that knight on f4
almero when you see this position do you
think that fabiano should be happy with
how the opening is going
well i play this uh opening uh from
white side and well i know that it's
very solid so you need to exchange the
bishops then to bring your knight
g2 to f1 or sometimes to keep it there
and to play g3 then there's another
thematical move which comes to my mind
this to play rook a2 it's very strange
but this rook will protect the f2 pawn
when you will need to move your f3
knight so a
computer gives a small edge when he
assesses this position so but once again
psychologically i feel that it's much
more difficult to play those with white
yeah i would agree with that i think
what you're highlighting rook a2 was
played in that game between alireza and
rajabov and i think there's some static
weaknesses for black these double
isolated pawns aren't great and that
actually became a problem for a job late
in that game but the pressure that black
is building and if we look at duda's
face i mean i've seen his round after
round yeah but he's had the same face
for like the last three rounds yeah he
just doesn't seem very happy at the
chessboard and i mean i don't know what
he feels has gone wrong to this point
but he seems to be really unhappy at
least visually here as we look at him on
screen i feel that he is disillusioned
you know like after these two losses
it's very difficult uh
to get poised you know and to come back
into play like nothing happened so uh
knight h5 and well probably he's
thinking right now once again i'm under
pressure
yeah
yeah
what did i just do what did i just play
was this my plan under pressure is a
great song but not a good feeling and
that's what
yanchez of duda is facing and actually
fabinho carwana he played the white side
of this position and lost against
alexander grishok so it's interesting to
note that
fabinho has experienced from the white
side but he also lost the game and then
he's like hmm well i lost alexander
grisham one of the best players ever
let's use that opening well i i would
say that i think almost every player in
this field maybe save dingley ren but
probably also him has had this position
from both sides the ingredient is
definitely from the black side it says
that he might be the only player in the
field who doesn't play e4 that often
so
this position is all the rage these
types of positions because as i said uh
the last time we encountered this input
or drop up what's important to
understand about these italian positions
is just that there's eight thousand
different move orders you could have
this position with a queen on the e8
instead of the nh5 you could have this
position if white is uncastled and the
pawn is on p2 instead of on b4 so it's
actually really really hard to analyze
these positions concretely which is why
we're putting such an emphasis and i
think the players when they analyze
these positions put more of an emphasis
than usual on typical ideas rather than
on specific moves amira i really like
what don just said there that it's not
about the theory so much as the feel and
understanding of the position and from
that perspective five minute caruana has
been up to 2844 as his highest rating
that's it and that's it and young
is just reaching his peak so
from that perspective you'd have to give
i would imagine the slight nods of
fabiano in a position in neutral
territory well of course he
well first of all he knows these
positions very well you were talking
about the feel and we were discussing it
um previously that sometimes even if the
computer gives a slight edge
well you
might not go for it because well you're
it's not your comfort zone you don't
well the plans and i remember the game
that he played against uh ding you know
he simply said in the interview like
after the game that well he didn't know
what was the plan you know how difficult
are those positions
yeah that's not a good place to be when
you feel out of sorts and your opponent
is feeling sharp it's uh not good and i
mean
dingley wren
before the rest day right now yanchez
still in the clock spending five minutes
that must feel good for fabiana caruana
and i do want to take a step back for a
moment here and look at all four games
because in the early stages when we see
players think we often feel that's not a
great sign and in the game between
hikaru nakamura and ali raza faruja of
course that's
such a mouth-watering matchup everyone
is excited about that one alireza has
spent eight more minutes in a car and
that's not the biggest deal at least in
theory but almira alireza's time
management throughout the tournament
hasn't been ideal it hasn't been what
we've seen from him in other events so
when you look at the clock there in the
bottom right do you get a little bit
concerned considering how early in the
game we are
well on the other hand uh i think that
it's very important sometimes to take
those moments and to just to calm
yourself because he's playing the
neither maybe hikaru will use the
variation you know which he didn't
expect although they i've i went through
those their games you know they were the
i think uh loretta was using so many
openings uh it's not only the neither
it's e5 it's even the karakan so hikaru
had to prepare all of them so maybe he
went for the line which is also very
solid against the neither
yeah and we can bring this game up here
we are only on move seven alireza spent
quite a deal of time right if we just we
can scroll through the moves it's a
sicilian a very popular opening at the
highest level yonder palmishing himself
an absolute wizard on the black side of
night orbs and after knight c3 a6 bishop
e3 e5 this has been played
so many times and then the knight
retreated to f3 and that's where ali
raza began to think so amira what is it
about the move knight f3 that
had alireza pause well i think the
the sharpest line which can occur uh
occurs after knight b3 and that that's
what we've seen in the game between yami
palmishi and there is a furious so
knight of three is uh well it's a more
solid move some sometimes it can
lead
to
a very positional play in the neither
so maybe he will he was unexpected
for sure
you're a sicilian player you love these
sharp positions so why don't you tell us
a little bit about this knight of three
yeah i don't love facing knight f3
before i delve into it i will say that
you know there was a time many moons ago
and alireza was not 2800
and when he did have a narrow opening
repertoire
that was around the time that uh you
know uh general general lee surrendered
appomattox but um
essentially alireza i think at his heart
is a sicilian night of player and for
this important game i think he decided
to resort to the opening that he knows
truly knows best
now
knight f3 is an interesting choice by
hikaru hikaru has played absolutely
everything against the night or i am
positive that he's played this as well
and
i agree completely with omira knight f3
is generally an indication that you are
in for
uh a long positional battle the reason
why i'm so sure of this is because white
always castles king side in these
positions whereas after knight b3 yeah
you can still castle king's side but if
you want to go for the principal lines
you have opposite side castling and as a
consequence you have opposite side
attacks um the sort of the english
attack variation after knight f3 the
battle generally takes place on two
fronts there is a battle that takes
place
uh over who will have full control over
the d5 square and you might say well
obviously the answer is white because
it's a weak square but that's not
necessarily the case black will position
the light squared bishop quite often on
e6
and he will have a lot of eyes on the d5
square the second battle takes place on
the queen side black will try to develop
quick play on the queen side often by
pushing the b pawn to b5 sometimes by
positioning the rook on c8 and you have
exchange sacrifices on c3 so the big
question is going to be is white's
control over d5 going to be fully
counter balanced by black's queen side
counter play i'm not saying that's the
only way that the game goes in these
positions and finally on that note the
positioning of the knight on c6 is
something that raised my eyebrows
generally in this line you don't play
knight c6 this early this is a rare move
it's a move that i'm sure alireza has
analyzed before
it's much much more rare than bishop e7
which is the main move as far as i
remember
and no surprise that hikaru is taking
his time upon seeing this relatively
rare knight development but almira i
mean this knight c6 move while it may be
much rarer than bishop e7 it seems like
over-the-board inspiration rather than
some kind of preparation
well oh so that's an interesting
question because i i also wanted to
point out the idea especially in this
line that when you're playing bishop
seven knight bd7 sometimes you have this
rook c8 and rook c3 you know it's a very
important moment uh well
like when you play b5 there should be
some somewhere like uh and so you're
trying to sacrifice an exchange then to
well
to create a complete chaos on the board
but here you know after knight six six
your choices are rather limited that's
uh that's why i think that dinah doesn't
like this move
yeah i mean you keep talking with this
rook c8 rook takes c3 such a common
motif in the sicilian whether it's a
knight or for a dragon it's always
available with the c5 being open but the
knight in c6 actually blocks that path
so hikaru is now on the clock right
is this the first time you think he's
really seeing knight c6 do you think he
feels like already made a mistake but
the position is so close it's not a
tactical position where you're like that
was a blunder i should be able to take
advantage of it wasn't on my top list of
candidate moves so do you think that
these players are completely on their
own at move seven
well there's a very typical plan here
for example after knight six you you
will probably develop your bishop on e6
with black so you
white
usually plays knight d2 bishop c4 and
tries to exchange this bishop
maybe hikari is uh thinking about how to
wait for this move bishop b6 you know he
needs to find because if he plays bishop
b2 here and
tries to finish his development and
castle then you know he it feels like he
lost the tempo
so maybe this he's looking for a more
most precise move order in this position
tanya yeah so to me the most natural
move for white is bishop c4 to increase
your control over d5 but
one thing i will say
i've seen this among certain night of
experts in the last couple of months and
years
uh black has started to sometimes put
the light squared bishop on g4 which is
a very like un-nadorf-like way of
playing but then again when a new
invention comes along there's always
those people who say the television
isn't going to catch on and i want to
make sure that my comments don't age
that poorly so it might be that alireza
is actually
not going to put the bishop on e6 at all
and he's going to play bishop g4
and try to use that pin to make white
uncomfortable to prevent uh the move
that almira mentioned knight f3 to d2 so
i'm going to be very interested to see
where alireza puts his bishops in
particular his light squared bishop
and whether he pushes the b pawn and
goes for normal queen side play or does
he have in mind some sort of new
unconventional idea but i don't think he
just invented this move on the spar
robert i think
maybe he was trying to remember analysis
maybe he was trying to
you know he was remembering some sort of
old file from many years ago but i can
almost guarantee you
either of you are welcome to disagree
with me that he didn't just you know
you know this wasn't just a fit of
inspiration a spur of the moment kind of
decision yeah i mean as we're talking
knight f3 not the most common move and
hikara has shown a tendency to play into
preparation they've seen that opponent
play earlier in the tournament so that
was knight to b3 of course by jan the
palmashi and here it's all about the d5
square so one more thing to point out
before we take a step back is that
sometimes black gets a quick bishop e6
and tries to strike with d5 but even
that doesn't necessarily solve all
black's problems so it's going to be a
real tense battle in the center but
let's take a step back this is the third
of the four games that we have looked at
thus far and in the top left we see that
man right there on screen he is hunched
over the board and i have a hunch that
maybe he's not so happy with the opening
because he is down a bit of time dingley
wren playing quickly so in the top left
as we bring that game up to speed here
richard report has the white pieces
supposed to be the first move advantage
but let me ask you something elmira i
see an h6 and the black king's not
castled dingley wren scored his first
victory could we see a g5 and dingle
rent fighting for
some really crazy activity well actually
i've been having nightmares where black
like was pushing h6 g5 so
i think hicarius
games you know inspired those nightmares
but uh
this is an idea we've seen almost in
every game like well mostly against the
joko pianist or the italian
but here i think uh first of all richard
why did the berlin defense is that
because let's go back and show how we
got here because i wanted to have a look
at the opening
so sorry there was no f4 no kings gambit
in this game can we show the game that
richard played all quite uh well a while
ago but nevertheless it was a classical
game and well i wanted our audience to
to have a look at how complicated it
might be and i think danny also analyzed
this yeah i think we can bring this up
potentially later on the touch screen so
we'll get yeah i do have to go to do it
later touch screen but is that going to
use the touchpad we have some fun stuff
we looked into almira did with uh f4 and
the kings gambit but not today richard
reports says let's be solid let's play
knight f3 uh but maybe he'll regret it
and he wishes he played the exciting
kings game but amira the opening was a
berlin excuse and
spanish with a6 not playing berlin
i think he was potentially worried that
maybe richard would take the draw or at
least ding i agree with you i think he
wants to win this game yeah so he avoids
any force drawing sequences what you're
saying and stop me wherever you'd like
after knight f6
d3
we see black push on the queen side to
kick that bishop back and bishop c5 so
all right black uh you know
already kicked the bishop back has the
e5 pawn defended and brings the bishop
to a more active square often in the
spanish we see the bishop gets stuck on
e7 but i think dingley ren's moves kind
of show us that he's playing not just
for equality but really to give himself
chances
yeah i mean i will just point out one
thing and i'll throw it to you olamir i
mean you're probably more experienced
than me in general but maybe in these
positions as well when i was growing up
and was being topped the right lopez
this d3 line is of course not the main
line the main line is move five castles
uh
if you want to play the d3 line
uh i was taught that you should castle
you should wait for bishop e7 and then
you should play d3
because the immediate d3 allows the
exact line that dingley run played which
is b5 and bishop c5 which is supposed to
be totally fine for black
but the one thing that report may have
been dissuaded by is the possibility of
an open road we sell caruana
unsuccessfully tried the open road
against hikaru nakamura but this is a
different game these are different
players and the open road has been a
force to be reckoned with
in the last couple of years so it might
be the case that he wanted a sideline he
didn't want any mainline theoretical
battle
and he got what he wished for i mean
report quickly reached a very
non-theoretical position as far as i can
tell the only problem robert is that he
might not be totally happy with this
non-theoretical position well i like the
point you made there right with the
bishop allowed to come to c5 when the
other variation bishop on e7 and those
subtleties elmira they play such a
tremendous role at this high level of
course and i agree with daniel
that richard wanted to
to get just a playable position that was
somewhat also an approach
that magnus introduced to chess you know
he started to play uh very uh different
lines at some point of his career that
he didn't want to go into
lines which were analyzed by the
computers till the move 30 or 40 as this
the case in the open race so he simply
wanted to get a playable position and to
go for complications and this move
bishop g5 confirms it here because i
would go for something
more classical like c3 in this position
or even knight c3 it's also possible but
bishop g5 is
very aggressive it certainly is and it
allows h6 to be played you don't really
want to take this knight in f6 and hand
black the bishop pair but you want to
say the threat is strong in the
execution let's keep that pin alive and
we're waiting for g5 dingley red didn't
play it this early because dragging the
bishop back at that moment would have
left e5 hanging so waiting for the right
moment right d6
c3 bishop a7 that way the move d4 never
comes with the tempo against the bishop
here and white always needs to be
careful while playing d4 because the e4
pawn is loose as soon as you do so so
castles knight a5 and as we get to the
game position after c5
richard's in a deep think here he's
already spent seven and a half minutes
he's not sure what to do and i wasn't
joking when i asked the question are we
gonna see a hyper aggressive dingly run
because we know this g5 move is often
available even when black castles but
the fact that black hasn't castled could
actually help launch some kind of attack
a pawn storm perhaps g5 h5 and bring
those pawns up the board
yeah this is a fascinating position
there are a lot of moving parts and i
think one thing a lot of people might
notice is they might say well wait a
second knight a5 and c5 i've seen that
before but doesn't that block the bishop
on a7 isn't that just a really dumb
bishop and i think the way that you can
think about it is to view the a7 bishop
as an extension of the c5 pawn the pawn
and the bishop are one unit what is this
unit doing this unit is discouraging
white from playing d4 so if white plays
d4 here which i still think is one of
white's main candidate moves in fact i
think if report doesn't like the
possibility of ding playing g5 the best
way to fight flank play is to
preemptively open the center so i can
guarantee you he's thinking about it but
after cdcd bishop on a7 opens up and
bishop g4 exerts further pressure on the
d4 pawn richard or also knight a5 to c6
either way richard might not like the
pressure that's being exerted on the d4
pawn and so he might choose not to play
d3 d4 but in that case ding will have
his arms untied and he will be able to
strike at the king's side with g7 g5 so
it's a bit of a
tough decision for richard d4 might be
premature then the bishop on a7 strikes
and if he doesn't play on d4
then knight a5 and c5 has been
successful and ding can play on the king
side it's a difficult situation in my
opinion for richard
well i love this explanation and there
is one thing that i wanted to add of
course is that
uh richard has to use this moment to
play d4 because if black
simply consolidates or coordinates his
bishop and plays knight c6
then richard will be deprived of any
counter play and then the move g5 is
going to be even more powerful
uh yeah i'm so tempted to play g5 here
if i'm dingly wren because as dania so
nicely
explained
the way you contend with a potential
king side attack is by striking the
center but you don't necessarily want to
strike in the center because it opens up
that bishop that looks
not well placed because the pawns in his
path so it's like is the cure worse than
the disease you like to use that
expression dania it's a tough decision
right here and this bishop on h4 bishop
g5 was enterprising play but perhaps
you know you wish your bishop could come
back around to the scene yeah it's your
e3 diagonal so uh this is off on the
side but let's take a step back you know
where this game is going to be very
interesting if we look at the game
between nepalmishi and rujaba and the
palm shield continues to move quickly
and as we bring that game up for you
that
they can possibly get into a position
where
you know they might want to repeat the
move so
um
we see that the
queen on a5 right in the
bottom left-hand side of the screen is
here so
you know i mean this bishop on d5
probably should move
where the queen should move and one of
the two
well if you play queen c5 back
yes right you can go queen c5 uh if we
just look at what's happened here right
queen takes c5
bishop e3
queen a5
bishop d2 so you could play queen c5
back
but we shouldn't just assume that jan is
necessarily going to bring his bishop to
e3 because if we just take a step back
the bishops start on f4 so maybe for
some reason the bishop is better on d2
if you want to do something else but it
does look like after bishop d2 if you
play queen c5
we could get a repetition of yan saying
i am just going to draw by draw keep my
tournament lead hmm
i don't think he's going to repeat
i i really don't i think after queen c5
he wants to make a general improvement i
think jan claims that the bishop on d2
is simply well placed i mean guess what
you can take on d5
and you can enjoy your life you have the
two bishops the pawn on c4 is a
liability
95 rook c1 white's not losing this game
and i think
there is no point for yon i mean yon can
essentially make a draw in this game
whenever he wants to
now
do blunders happen do crazy things
happen of course but considering his
great form
i i you know i aggressively believe that
yon should
at least make a couple more moves
and well i i tend to agree with you
daniel on this you mean that after
bishop d2 he young didn't sign the
letter of the intent you know like he is
just
i said he is uh well he is playing with
his opponents so
maybe we can have a look at the pos well
black's options let's have a look so
uh
we have queen c5 just if we want to
repeat the moves but maybe there is a
threat after queen c5 let's have a look
at this position
well
at the very least you've left the open
file so i would feel pretty happy to
bring my rook to a1 maybe after taking
on d5 maybe before doing so but i guess
white can claim at least that minor
advantage ah so then after bishop d2
maybe you you have to retreat to a
bishop if you want to keep your bishops
on the board so
is this possible can you pick a square
because i don't know where to go oh
there are so many slaves it's like a
restaurant in madrid it's very hard yeah
which where are we going let's say
bishop c6 and if i don't have like a
very dangerous move they jump with my
knight
uh does it seem so yeah it does not seem
sorry because if you go in knight e4 i
could even just take you
forward with the bishop attacking your
queen so that would not be a good move
yeah i mean knight d1 is interesting
here trying to get the knight around to
e3 because
i feel like if black preserves the light
squid bishop which is what
i think what what he should do white's
biggest chance lies in just a frontal
assault
on this c4 pawn so where's the queen
going to go like queen a6 i guess
and then the knight transfers over to e3
and as far as i understand in this line
black's best strategy lies
in giving strategically giving up the
pawn on c4 you don't want to cling to it
because if you play move like bishop b5
knight d4 happens and you can see how
awkward that becomes so black needs to
find a way to either defend it
indirectly with a move like c8 or to
give it up for some sort of compensation
but that can be a little bit tough but
you know then if your queen goes to a6
and that's why i thought it was very
important to keep the queen on the fifth
rank at the last 95 as well
so maybe
you should keep an
eye on this square so if rooks 895 i was
trying to calculate are you losing the
pound or not oh
and he's about to make a move and i
think he did move the bishop but he
moved all the way back to eight so he
doesn't want tamira's point i mean uh
the bishop can be tucked safely home on
a8 and maybe the knight can come out to
c6 and an additional point is that in
the live position we see that the rook
can come to see it and at once defend
the pawn on c4 so it doesn't require the
bishop you know tactically uh to move
out the way to defend the pawn on c4
instead the rook comes directly and this
knight can either go up to c6 which
could be very useful depending on what
happens um but
i don't know it's a kind of an odd place
to be in the corner there's so many
useful moves for white here i agree with
that so i have knight d193 then roxy one
knight e5
these moves
are very easy to make
all about going for the c4
very very direct approach
yeah i would start with rook c1
yeah and and
black has to figure out how to position
i mean java would probably play rook c8
i would imagine
and the battle over the c4 pawn
it rages on but
you know it's like boxing but you're
in like a bulletproof vest only one side
can deliver the punches black is clearly
on the defensive here and if white
quote-unquote fails
then basically you make a draw if black
defends the c4s pawn successfully
white's never really going to be worse
here yeah amira had a great variation
knight d1 let's say we go queen is queen
b5 just feels awkward to me especially
with the bishop one eight because knight
d4 comes with the tempo and maybe quincy
seven in order like
he wants to uh avoid knight t5 but i'm
not sure if this this is the best move
yeah actually exactly what i was going
to say so i was first going to show why
queen a6 i didn't like as much and why
queen c7 is good almira's suggestions
because almira keeps talking about this
e5 square that's very very important
because white is trying to pile up
pressure on the c4 point so if you go
queen a6 and white goes knight e5 we
already see three of white's pieces
staring right at this pawn and black
doesn't have enough to defend that pawn
so elmira i agree with you that queen
back to c7 seems to at the very least
keep the knight out of e5 for the time
being and i mean this knight's coming to
e3 anyway so it i just feel like
whitespan is so direct so jan has to be
happy about the position he's obtained
yes it's a very concrete approach and uh
i had one remark about uh this type of
structure normally you would want to
have not your rook on b8 so when
everything you know every piece captures
on c4 you force a lot of exchanges you
want to take pawn on b2
so
i i feel that jan uh has won the opening
battle
yeah
i would say he's
he's achieved exactly the type of
position he wants he's wanted to achieve
he's gotten what he did against ding
which is a risk-free position except
it's not a dead draw he's got a
risk-free position where he can play for
an edge and he can essentially
you know take the freeway exit anytime
he wishes and while that is true for yom
nepam she if we think about from timor
rijaba's perspective he showed an
amazing set of defensive skills against
alareza fruga he defended that game for
seven hours he almost turned it towards
the end by bringing his king up so if
there's a player in the field who can
kind of sit and have a passive position
and defend for maybe seven hours maybe a
hundred moves team over jabba i a lot
has been said about his non-win you know
not win
since 2019 in classical chess but he is
very solid and very good at defense
well i agree with you but um this kind
of of approach has also its drawbacks
because
these tournaments are very long and so
you are getting very tired and i i
believe that timur has spent uh
more time than anyone you know over the
board in this tournament so uh he could
be physically exhausted that's very true
but on the flip side dania remember he
played some sicilians against five
minute caruana he ended up losing that
game not necessarily because the opening
but it was a risky choice that got him
in a worse position and it seemed to be
kind of out of his specific elements so
i guess there's two sides to this yeah
and by the way we can see john quickly
carrying out uh the maneuver
that is central to white's strategy of
attacking c4 he plays knight d1 and that
knight is going to e3
i just wanted to add that it's important
i think not to overstate the case here i
think black is well within
the range of equality i think if for
java plays five or six accurate moves he
should be able to hold hold his own
queen a6 rook c8 black's play is not
that difficult here
but um
yeah i i think the truth is somewhere in
the middle yes this strategy of
essentially being on the defensive from
the very start with the black pieces
it's it's very taxing it's grueling
but at the same time you want to get
positions you're comfortable with and i
think rajab at this stage in his career
he likes clearly defined solid positions
and as all of these players have
remarked more than once in the
interviews
especially nowadays when there's
basically no advantage anywhere in any
opening the most important thing
priority number one is to get a position
that you are comfortable with and that
is really what defines success in the
opening for the most part and you use
the word define and i think definition
to a position could be very useful for
players because then they could find
their plans more easily and as we see
all four games going on here the top
left there is nothing very clearly
defined okay we know black has just
expanded with g5 and h5
all dingley rent fans are going to be
very happy to see them we know
throughout this 20 22 feet of candidates
uh there's a huge audience coming from
china rooting for dingley ren game after
game so his time advantage his position
looks good in the upper left and i'm
looking at the upper right and we see
that fabiano caruana has a bishop and
knight against two knights and in
particular that bishop on a7 eyeing all
the way towards the white king slicing
across the board that should for fabiano
give him chances
so he didn't go for this typical
exchange bishop is three young sister
duda decided to
to exchange his bishop against the
knight because he felt that
this knight was uh well way too active
first of all on f4 he um
well maybe this is also a very concrete
variation he well he took on the f4 he
went for uh queen b3
attacks the e6 bound
so he trades with the bishop for the
knight and it goes queen b3
very interesting and what he wants to
say that there is no maybe easy way of
protecting this one because well you
want to protect it with the queen
normally in
this position so
because maybe rook ae8 which seems
natural is met with b5 i don't know like
is it possible it looks very possible
right because you're taking advantage of
the fact that black is bringing a rook
away from the queen side so b5 a very
logical follow but amir i think you're
reading this position correctly and it's
just a position where if you take you
immediately lose a piece right because
after pawn takes pawn takes your
knight's under attack once the knight
moves down goes this bishop here on a7
that will obviously not be played but if
floppy does go rook 88 and b5 is played
you have to move your knight and then
this queen is in a perfect situation
aiming down the b file and knights in
the rim we often talk about how dim they
are that knight is not getting back into
the game anytime soon never on the queen
can just depart for c2 or d1 and you can
just show and i think it's important in
general not to fall for the illusion
that black is somehow close to
delivering checkmate you know you could
look and you could say look at that
bishop look at that queen storm clouds
are gathering around white's king well
they're also kind of dissipating because
you've got the knight on f3 which is
blocking the f file the knight from f1
can move toward e3 neutralizing the
bishop
o'meara talked about the idea of rook a1
to a2 lending further support to the f2
pawn black is nowhere near delivering
checkmate or even developing an attack
we can't even talk about that yet white
on the other hand is very very close to
developing serious queen side pressure
with b5 from an objective perspective i
think duda has actually done a good job
i'm starting to change my mind about
this position when i first looked at it
i thought black is totally fine now i
feel like fabi needs to be very careful
the next couple of moves and he has to
do something
uh such that b5 is not going to be you
know a killer
i think this is what the position
revolves around completely as b5 and you
explained it well that it looks like
white's king is in grave danger but
almira she suggested rook a2 since the
beginning it's such a good idea on mira
because the rook on a2 it also can allow
you to double on the queen side right
you can get your rooks in a line and
protecting the king with just one move
on the other flank that's very useful so
one question i have for you all mirror
is what do you see the future of the
white knights because then f3 kind of
has to stay put but what about this
non-f1 even if it gets to e3 sort of
what's
next on the agenda
well first of all it looks like it's a
new philosophical concept young sister
do the things that in this position his
two knights are much better like or at
least a little bit better than uh
fibers bishop and a7 and the knight on
c6 which usually causes a lot of
problems uh for black and they're trying
to play 97 knight g6 so to bring another
knight to the f4 square but here he
simply doesn't have time for it and i
was actually looking uh for a way to
coordinate this uh
white knight but maybe he will keep them
on h2
protect on f3 push g3 play king g2
this is a
very standard plan in this position and
also it gives you an opportunity to play
knight g4 at some point and
but if you stabilize the position then
you might as well go for d4
it's a really good path forward for
white and this thread of b5 that's
always looming because amir once again
is a great point this knight on c6 i
talk about this all the time it's
dominated by the pawn three squares away
and not only is that the case it can be
kicked by b5 which helps open up the
position this is a hook on a6 to open
the queen side but this knight it
belongs in f4 right that queen could go
back to any square f7 h6 f6 doesn't
really matter and you can bring this
knight to f4 but it takes time but why
don't we actually look through something
so let's say this queen goes to a square
like h6 right
i do want to bring my knight around and
if you just played b5 thinking that
that's going to work out well there's
already tactics watch out for sacrifices
in f3 that's another thing and that's
why i purposely chose queen h6 was i'm
opening up we were talking about in the
farouzia game against nakamura rook
takes c3 and many sicilians in these
types of positions you always have to
look out for your king side with the
rook on the open floor so you see
intuitively i felt that the knight has
to be on the second night has to be on
h2
i uh well i haven't seen this uh
variation because i was uh looking at
queen f6 and or queen f7 but queen h6 is
uh is a poisonous move
it has a lot of venom in it so
um
and let's let's have a look yes
97 but now there's a downside which is
that you can't easily play knight g6
because of this darn
e6 pawn which is constantly going to
hang
so you have to play rook 88
and white's gonna play rook a2 and white
can strike with d4 because you took your
knight away from the center this is what
always happens in these positions black
bogs down with trying to create king
side play and in the meantime white
you know white sets up all of the
defensive pieces on ideal squares and
strikes in the center and starts
queenside play it's really cumbersome
for black to do anything on the king
side
i wanted to ask robert what do you think
about queen f6 so you keep your
pawns mobile but even g5 h5
well
doesn't do much in this position that's
how you realize that uh
black's play is not so easy because what
i wanted to play after knight h2
uh knight t7
and then play maybe g5 or h5 and knight
knight g6
yeah now at some point you should
definitely be considering those pawn
pushes it not only restricts this knight
from getting to g4 but you can just keep
thrusting those pawns forward it's kind
of has a king's indian defense feel in
some ways where if you can get these
pawns four and your queen behind it
let's say to g7 just or g6 you throw
those pawns forward and continue your
attack so if this knight ever has to
leave f3 that's really really bad news
in fact the gate would probably just
collapse for white but for the time
being it does seem like white is in
control because the king side not in too
much danger and as we keep talking d4 or
b5 all sorts of moves for white to start
expanding and creating problems for
black more look at this position
the plan was g5 and h5 looks completely
suicidal to me
to me actually i feel like
that might be black's best bet but i
would start i i would try to start with
age five
so as to be as uncommittal as possible
right
uh dude if to start from a pushing point
this way which keeps your king a little
bit safe especially if there's a knight
on h2 you could argue that h5 is
actually a positional move it restricts
the knight from coming to g4 you're
pretending that you're doing one thing
and then all of a sudden you play g5 but
i can see almira's point of course
i have one i think important conceptual
question like let's say this queen goes
to f6 and that goes day two what were we
talking about can black decide to
protect the queen side by actually
pushing the queen side pawn with a5 and
the reason why i like this is white
certainly cannot allow black to take on
a b4 because once you take back you
allow black to carve out this d4 square
and a knight coming to d4 is not going
to be very pleasant so if you push b5
now black has the benefit of closing the
queen side b5 was so powerful in many
positions when you could take on a6 but
with the pawn up here on a5 and i'll
move my knight i'm not even sure where
to go i can go this way to defend the
center and go over to e7 of course but
the point is that the queen side hasn't
quite opened up and i can see that the
evil are still you know it's good for
white just like many of the other
variations but you have this at least
security that you're not going to
be blasted open on the queen side i
agree really i like this move very much
in order to um
uh stabilize the uh the pawn structure
first of all on the queen side and
this has even more of this king's indian
you know structures now so but i would
still go for d4 in this position right
you're just gonna rook d1 maybe now that
i don't need my rook on a1 rook t1 and d
and play d4 in the next move and it
looks like the five spring has rook up
to f6 he does indeed and i think the
reason why we you know rook lift makes a
lot of sense you're trying to bring the
rook into the game but there is
something a bit concerning
i would say as well by bringing your
rook up because now there may be a
position where you open up the queen
side and you need your rooks connected
uh just as an example like let's say
this knight goes here and i get to take
and you take back and my queen goes into
b7 now your rook is not defended the
surgeon looks very bad you're losing a
pawn your rook can't move because the
bishop is lost and if you just move back
to f8 c7 drops and this is the big
problem uh we've talked about a
conception the queen side opening up
this is a really good illustration of
why white wants to open up the queen
side because black isn't necessarily
prepared to meet some of the threats so
uh let's go back to our four board view
as fabian did just play rook f6 he's
going to go for an attack but maybe
junction can open up that queen side and
as we look from board to board here i
mean that top left game i know dingley
wren
he wants another win i'm still liking
the look of it and in the bottom left
janupamshi and vajava
amira danya the moves that we've been
talking about knight d1 to e3 have
happened and
how could yon complain
he can i mean
upon c4 is hanging
black probably has to defend it with
rook c8 and we're probably going to see
rook c1
and you know jan's going to sip his tea
and he's going to look at the tournament
standings he's like i'm a point ahead
i'm playing risk-free chess
life could be worse
it certainly could especially with that
t in hand and we see rajaba back at the
board he's going to figure out how to
protect that pawn and i'm here in the
bottom right it's been a slow game thus
far we're used to seeing ali reza and
hikaru play blitz and bullet chess this
is classical they're using their time
and not too many moves have happened
well and danya predicted this very well
so the battle in this game will go over
the g5 square
i think that uh hikaru played knight d5
on his previous move and rook c8 yes
the typical answer here would be uh for
white bishop g5 because i wanted to play
bishop g5 and bishop f6 and this means
that at some point the d5 square would
be mine forever then as swesnick of
player would think uh then i will be
able to play 97 you know in exchange
this night so
um
this position is still very interesting
um
let's see what
what is the other option for white by
the way you could have a repetition
bishop g5 queen a5 check bishop d2 queen
v8 you have this in the special goblins
oh yes as well right yes of course
that's not right there we go my first
day drawing the arrows give me a break
you think this bishop did 28 and this is
uh
i mean there's nothing
square yes for the bishop exactly and
then it cuts off the queen's contact
with the d5 score which renders more
annoying the possibility of black taking
on d5 of the bishop forcing a pawn unto
that square
and that's not ideal and i think we
should just show for maybe our less
experienced viewers at home that after
knight to d5 we often want to take a
knight with our own knight but this will
always fail because the knight takes d5
pawn takes d5 you'll see that your
knight and your bishop are both under
attack and in this particular position
you may not necessarily lose a piece
directly but uh knight a5 you don't want
your knights on the rim i can just move
my bishop back next move almost
pre-movable b4 and your knight does get
trapped so uh just for everybody at home
that this
knight md5 from white if you're going to
capture it as elmira donaire what you're
talking about you have to take with the
bishop which is actually quite
interesting right you could have led
with bishop takes d5 pawn takes d5 and
we see that white gets an extra pawn
here
towards the queen side in many different
positions but black has an extra pawn on
the king side and especially with upon
potentially going to f5 or even a knight
swinging around it's a very mixed bag
actually i like this position after
bishop d5 he takes d5 because you get to
play knight d7 g6 and bishop g7 and then
one important element in this position
is that black
didn't play b5 if black
would have the pawn on b5 then this
position is clearly better for white
but this one leads to a very complex
play
yeah for sure i guess also we should
take an account after bishop takes the
bishop can take back on d5 and maybe
that's what white might want to go for
just to open up some of the queen side
play a little bit and if knight takes
the queen can continue takes you keep
filling that square and that's a very
important central square in the night
arc but it's neither here nor there on
the d5 square because we saw rook to c8
played by ali rizzi he's keeping the
tension both players i think want to
keep the tension and this pawn just one
more quick tactic knight takes e4 some
people think wasn't that knight on c3
defending upon here it was but it's not
a problem because the bishop b6
attacking the queen next move is knight
into c7 check with a fork of the king
and the rook and white wood steel
material yeah but rook c8 actually that
is the point of rook city not only does
it improve the position of the rock but
it
uh it takes the sting out of the move
bishop b6 and it therefore reinforces
the threat of knight takes c4 so a slow
move like bishop c4 to b3
which is otherwise very typical in such
positions black takes on e4 and asks
white
where the compensation is is it under
the bed is it you know between the seats
on the couch but i'm not really seeing
it
and so
that greatly limits the options for
hikara that's why bishop g5 becomes
appealing knight takes f6 also but amira
i know you'll second me on this if you
have to play knight takes f6
that is already a sign
that black uh you know
black is doing quite okay yeah that's
exactly why i wanted to play bishop g5
uh because knight f6 f6 seems like as a
concession in this position and uh
queen a5 of course is a very important
uh
i would say defensive resource after
bishop g5 because i wanted to show after
bishop e7
what you want to obtain is you want to
take with the bishop on f6 bishop f6
bishop f6 and this is the position which
you are obviously looking for
with the structure so white is clearly
better like it's a small edge but a very
long lasting
edge so
that's why uh daniel suggested like
queen a5 uh like in this version of
queen a5 and it's it's a very important
uh
improvement yes you have to escape the
pin and
maybe force that bishop back because the
e4 pawn still is loose and that would be
an anticlimactic draw to what everybody
has looked forward to as an exciting
game i don't think hikaru is in the
business of making those kind of draws
but he is deep in the think tank so we
will go back to our four board view here
so hikar he's trying to figure it out
that d5 square is so important in the
sicilian we know that in rajab of with
the black piece against napalm machine
he's trying to defend that c4 pawn which
is becoming more and more of a target
and fabiano carwana i mean i think that
it's funny because the top games up
there in the top left and top right they
have some similar tendencies where black
is going for an attack and white is
playing more like a fundamental chess a
play in the center develop your pieces
but i mean
top left top right that's where my eyes
keep catching despite the fact that
yonder palm share tournament leader is
in the bottom left and in the bottom
right is the matchup that everybody
wanted to see
yeah i mean again we have a bunch of one
e4s again we have three out of four
games going one e4 i'm not complaining
i'm certainly not complaining i'm
totally down for that but i agree with
you the most complicated games the most
complex positions that are full of life
are on the top left and top right that's
not to say the bottom games can't
explode that's not to say we won't keep
an eye on them but we have got a great
assortment a great menu of different
types of positions so every type of
chess player can find something to watch
and learn from
early in today's round and do you agree
on are those the games of catching your
eye because i think
i get a sense from you that
nakamura faruga game because it's so
early because there's so much tension
going on i feel like that might be the
game that you have your eye on well i
also have my eye on the game between
richard airport and zingler and because
it somehow challenges everything that
i've been taught in my early childhoods
like what happened to first equalize
with black and then you know sees the
moment you know this
this is not going well in well in a way
that's uh well i've been uh
uh thinking about you know so
yeah let's have
let's wait and see well when things go
against our education we're left to our
own devices and
coming up in the just next month or is
it july yet the
starting the end of july players they're
playing their individual games but
they're a team that's not often in chess
but it will be at the 44th chess
olympiad which is coming to chennai
india this is the biggest team event in
chess with more than 100 countries
competing for gold coverage begins at 2
30 a.m pacific time from july 29th
through august 9th right here on
chess.com we'll bring more action here
from the 2022 feed of candidates it is
round 10 we are live from madrid so stay
tuned everybody it's just a quick break
we will be right back
this kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing the chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
no stranger to the candidates fabiano
caruana stands as a pretty popular
choice for winning it all here in madrid
fabi won this prestigious tournament
four years ago in berlin
in his challenger match against magnus
carlson caruana came just one end game
moment away from his first world
championship i wasn't
uh
wasn't playing my best chess today and
buying this so
i think played played very well
soon to be 30 caruana's chess resume is
matched by few in madrid born in miami
with dual citizenship fabi became the
youngest grand master in u.s history at
age 14.
a decade ago he made history at the
sinkfield cup
winning seven straight games on his way
to a 28 44 rating the third highest of
all time
precise calculation and deep knowledge
of opening theory are fabi's calling
cards the italian-american used both to
great effect in the fide grand swiss to
qualify for this event
caruana now aims to become the first
player since vichy anand to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years
but perhaps more importantly fabi looks
towards another shot at the world title
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is the
maybe best one in madrid
foreign
so
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates the
most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40s oh
we were worried that he overthought the
advantage oh my goodness
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
that means that's actually got to be
super intimidating if you're playing a
car when he puts on the coach
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
everyone wants to know what do the
commentators do on their day off
grand master robert hess
[Laughter]
you guys didn't know that was coming but
awesome
when was the last time that you were
the playground it's been a long time
that's why i went down the slide but
then after i went down this other slide
that was there they kept saying come on
robert come on just do it i'm like no i
don't want to you know be on camera
it's definitely their fault and i don't
usually succumb to peer pressure but it
happened that time but just to remind
everybody i'm here with international
master almiras kripchenko grandmaster
daniel laradisky i'm grand master robert
hess this is the 22 feed a candace no
you don't have to see me falling on my
butt any longer i'm sit sitting nicely
in this chair now as we bring up all
four boards it is the tenth round of
action our leader is playing in the
bottom left-hand side of your screen
that is yon napomnishi he has six and a
half out of nine we see him on camera
he's you know diving deep into the
position but as we reset as we look at
these boards here
on mira top right we see that the move
b5 was played by duda and
then knight on a5 for caruana
so let's have a look at this game yes we
shall so we see first fabiano on screen
here he's looking like he's studying
that position so bring it up for
everybody that
fabiano we know how good he is at
calculating donna your face
i'm not
you're not liking it no
i mean
you kind of called it that not an a5
there's no way back
right the c6 square is for bowdoin upon
is defending it
you have no other squares so the big
question right now for yon is where he's
going to put his screen but let's say
for the sake of argument he puts it on
a2 with the idea of maintaining contact
with the e6 pawn yeah the downside is
that now the rook on 80 and the queen
are aligned
but uh
i'm really really concerned about that
knight on a5 because if white can
tamp down black's remaining play on the
king side and
that's not a done deal because rook f6
to g6 might happen but amira's idea of
knight one h2 could come in handy if all
of that happens i feel like in the long
run
white's holding all of the drum cards
the idea of going d3d4 coupled with
uh the exiled knight on a5 and the
general awkwardness of black's pieces i
think objectively we can be talking
about a pretty significant advantage
here for duda if he can handle the next
couple of moves precisely so why don't
we analyze this right so the queen is
under attack let me analyze is that what
we're supposed to do
daniel's first instinct is queen to a2 i
know we kept talking with the rook there
but this looks good to keep the pressure
so when you look at this position where
you see it going first of all i really
well i understand why dany is not
thrilled with this position and i loved
his comment about the exiled knight you
know it's like okay siberia you go you
know and the only way to get this knight
out would be to play b6 might be seven
knights
potentially but that's why you need
first to trade your bishop against one
of the knights and then um but it seems
way too slow anyway so after queen a2 uh
well i
i cannot find the move
yes it's hard to make a move so let's
bring the second rook to f8 of course
and then
knight h2 once again
the knight f1 h2
simply to protect everything this is a
fortress
yes i cannot find a way to to break it
because in order to break it you need
this knight which is on a5 and it's up
but it's out of play
gosh that's not an a5 you would probably
kill to get this knight over here
towards the king side but it is cast
aside on a5 and i mean there is one
little hope for that night is that if
the queen were to get distracted and run
away and this knight could jump into b3
but there's always these problems with
what are you doing at the tension you
probably can't really ever take on b5
because after the pawn takes back this
knight on a5 is stuck in place so that's
another problem well you can you could
do this you could take on b5 uh the move
that you should play after ab5 is bishop
b6 in order to protect your knight but
once again you will lose it if i play c4
let's say and some bring my piece on c3
my queen on c3 then rook a5 is a threat
yeah very direct way to get two pieces
just for that one brook and your knight
h2 knight f3 those two pieces are
keeping everything stabilized for white
and with those knights there it's hard
to see how black goes through unless you
can somehow get these pawns going
but danya it seems very very unlikely
that black's pawns ever really get to
throw up the board throw up the board
get thrown up the board so that they can
land an attack well black sting is gonna
be throwing up when it sees all the
storm clouds that are gathered around
and i've used that phrase like six times
today
well i think the big problem here is
that white is already prepared to play
d4 right and d4 sets off a chain
reaction
that is really really unpleasant for
black the center evaporates black's grip
on the center loosens up
later on white can push that e pun up to
e5 and again everything returns back to
that man on a5 black cannot play
a sustained amount of time essentially
down a piece but i can't really attack
down that piece
and i think this is going to cause a lot
of problems uh shortly down the road for
fabi
uh and i i simply wanted to complete
this because after d4
the standard reaction for black would be
to take on d4
you would take with the c pawn let's say
just to show the uh yeah something like
make a comment
let's say make d4
yeah i'm just gonna i don't put this
right here yes d4 so take on d4 dx on d4
uh black wants to react here normally
with e5 for d5 and here i feel that
neither of these moves are possible
so that's the biggest problem for black
in this position because you need to
take on d4 you cannot allow
white to take d take c5 and g65 so
here like
just every move seems
really very bad you cannot play e5 here
and you cannot play d5 here so you know
in that other game a mirror between
report and digly wren you were saying
your chess education well throw it out
the window here their chest education is
perfect the knight on a5 is bad having
these nice central pawns advance are
good you know that seems to check out
well i seem to understand this position
much better
well i think honestly all of us do i
think every player who walks in the
playing hall they're looking at the
other games like yeah this looks good
for duda i'm worried about fabiano and
at the other game like throw their hands
up like who knows what's happening so
dania
you look at fabiano on screen here the
mcqueen a2 was in fact just played so we
see
him on the clock after the move queen a2
does he look like a player who's
particularly happy with how the opening
is gone
not really i mean fabi
you know from experience he doesn't
really betray a lot of emotions at the
board just generally
but he's everybody has tells
it's just a matter of figuring out what
those tells are
and i think for fabian it's just that
you know when he adopts that very very
intent
thinking pose and he starts i think our
producers pointed that out earlier when
he starts switching poses a lot and i as
i
spoke he just did that once so i don't
like psychological over analysis um you
know i don't want to pretend that this
is all that matters what's on the board
matters a lot more but in so far as that
gives us a clue as to how fab he feels
i think he's definitely feeling at the
very least uneasy about how things have
gone here in the early middle game and
speaking just factually he is down 10
minutes on the clock and we know when
five minute carwan is in his element he
moves really quickly at the opening
stage like he did against janupamashi
right before the rest day in our
previous round he did so against fabiano
against hikar nakamura he is five-minute
carwana out for the first 20-plus moves
of that game so the fact that fabiano is
slowing down that should be a good sign
for yanchista but i'm here let me ask
you
jan schistov he struggled this
tournament
so having a kind of
position that's a bit messy
does that favor the player who you know
is looking for the tournament win has
that stress
or duda you know he hasn't been
performing maybe he's so hungry for a
win that he loses objectivity well first
of all like if we wouldn't have all
these chess boards on screens i feel
like we gave
a very important analysis of a poker
hand you know it feels like that but
then more serious note i really like his
uh well his new uh concept you know
giving up this bishop for the night and
playing with two bishops here because
i feel that uh fabi will struggle to
find any counterplay here so like
doesn't seem messy to me at all it's uh
it seems that it's a very um
healthy uh positional approach
one thing that i could think of to make
this a mess if some point this rook
comes to f8 and maybe we'll get a double
exchange sacrifice down on f3 give up
one rook for the night the second rook
for the other night but the big problem
that i think we continue to highlight is
this knight on a5 that night we're
active somewhere we would see the merits
of black's position but with this knight
stuck over here on the queen side
what do you think of the knight on a5
um i think we should uh go to a four
board view because the 995 is really
hard to look at on the full screen so
let's go elsewhere
and
well fabiano caruana chasing tournament
leader yon napomshi and if i'm not
mistaken that evaluation bar it went up
from a4 to a5 like we're
reading each other's minds i think we
should uh
check out the game of the tournament
leader yonder pancho with the white
pieces against timor java in that cattle
i meant that
eva shot up there like ferrari and so
did yon's eyes he just raised those
eyebrows trying to figure out the
position and i guess as we look here
well not too much has happened so it has
the evaluations with a teeny bit maybe
not as much as it initially looked but
what happened was
that
bishop came to d5 from the corner to
make sure this pawn on c4 was defended
and then jan takes on d5
and what's interesting is i think a lot
of people say you know these commenters
keep talking about a weak pawn on c4 so
why don't we take with the pawn on d5
yeah i mean
from a purely visual perspective this is
a lot more appealing than taking with
the knight but
whenever a pawn does anything upon moves
or upon capture it's important to assess
how the structure is changed in
particular what new weaknesses are
created and how the dynamic of the
position changes overall and if you look
at it carefully first of all the f5
square is quite weak the queen could
jump into f5 with unpleasant
consequences you have a an outpost
potentially on d4 i don't know if i'd
call it an outpost maybe just a post
forgot the in in post
so bishop e3 and knight d4 could give
white great control over the center and
finally
uh the move b2b3
could stubbornly could still cause
problems
uh for black c4 pawn because once b take
c4 happens black has to recapture with a
pawn and yet again you have an isolated
pawn so e takes d5 far from solving all
of black's problems might actually
create more questions and answers and
just to show really quickly that you
can't take on b3 because after this
queen moves you could take on b3 but
it's probably better just to keep your
culture defended and once this queen has
to leave the c file the rook also leaves
a c file because it's taken so uh one
important note is that after knight
takes b5 this b3 move well it doesn't
quite have the same effect because black
can go c3 thanks to the knight's defense
so almira it seems like rajabov he's
defending tenaciously and actively
do you feel like yon still has good
winning chances or are you believing in
rajava
well i'm well first of all i feel that
it's very important to take knight d5 is
already on the board yes so it's
important to keep your pieces active in
this position so you don't want to
defend passively especially uh when you
have your knight on b8 still
so
i want well i want to find out how to
win the c4 pawn but
the advantage of playing knight d5 is
also that you can play knight b6
next and to protect the spawn uh once
once more so
that's an important point because your
95 move which we've been looking at so
many times that 95 goes right for the
pawn but knight b6 is a way to defend
while putting pressure on this 95 as
well so good call on there with knight
to b6 so would be what would be a clever
way to attack uh the pawn
on c4
knight t5 immediately well let's try it
yes you suggested it
well your knight v6 move seemed to be
pretty legitimate here
and yeah now you could support the
knight on e5 you could play a move
along the lines of bishop c3 but then
black plays bishop f6 and starts prying
your fingers
away from the ledge a little bit
yeah and i think we all believe with
more pieces being traded off when that
knight on b8 that hasn't developed gets
out it feels like the task is getting a
bit easier for rajabov can i play queen
a4 there
like not be before playing uh bishop c3
uh-huh maybe queen e4 immediately so you
want to open up your rook down the c
file still all play bishop f6 still
no
you could even consider knight takes c4
and b3 but but i think we we all were
looking towards this variation the rook
and the c file but as we just go to the
final step
you know pause here for a second knight
can't move right the queen's under
attack wait knight takes d2 attacks this
queen so you take my queen i take yours
but after rook takes c5 no you do not
take this queen on e4 because this is
background checkmate instead you take
this rook on c5 and miraculously black
has two minor pieces
uh and a rook for queen of pawn and
white
might be the one who has to watch out
for his king on the first round can we
continue decoration because this is such
a beautiful line but if i play queen b4
with a double attack then rook c1 bishop
f1 you have to give away another piece
so uh i have to take a look f1 and king
g2
and i guess i
i move my knight out somehow
it looks very loose though there
so many nice geometries in this position
so if i will be able to win both of
those knights yeah that's a good point
you you know why you should play knight
a6 here
the point is that you can later defend
the knight with the rook f1 to a1 and
that rook itself is defended so that
eliminates the possibility of forks
that is actually beautiful geometry
defend this the bishop stops checkmate
the bishop pretends protect the rook on
a1 next move you create left for your
king and it says zeros but this is a
position where i think white loses most
of the time yeah because that's why he
finds a way to win one of the other
minor pieces that's right we want to
thank anna kremling for the raid she is
on site live here at the palacio de
santonia in madrid she is half spanish
so her spanish speaking skills maybe
will come in useful for us at a meal in
the nights to come
absolutely
95 played by the way oh well thank you
so much anna once again welcome to
everybody this is the 2022 fide
candidates round 10 and knight e5 was
just played by yon napomshi the last
challenger to the world championship and
as you see on screen neither player
interested in being at the board but i
mean maybe their jackets will do the
playing from here on right the invisible
man this is
i just watched that movie pretty
recently so i think this not maybe um
i think parental guidance is needed for
all the youngsters in the audience to
see the invisible man
so let's agree
even though i haven't seen it
but i just agree with all of your
opinions you know okay well that's um a
little too accommodating
no that's two things you know that's
because danny was disagreeing with all
of our opinions
oh well i think we can all agree that
the knight on e5 move it puts black to
the task of defending c4 white should
always be at least a little bit better
maybe rajabov figures that knight come
into b6 all will be well for him but
neither player is at the board so maybe
let's also remove ourselves from this
board go to the
four board scene here the bird's eye
view we should at least leave our jacket
yeah take our jackets off and read them
on our seats but uh as we look wow
hikaru after a huge thank in the bottom
right hand side of the screen took like
40 minutes i don't know if we've ever
seen hit cart now of course we have he's
so many games and so many great games
and he needs to use his time wisely but
he took on f6 which we were calling a
concession so we'll bring that game up
right now we have knight takes f6 we
have ali reza faruja on screen here and
is he really thinking about g takes f6
because i think as if if this were
bullet he goes queen takes f6 as a
essentially a pre-move but he hasn't
moved yet so elmira do you think that
alireza he's hungry for victory he'll
take with the pawn
well once again for a player who played
sveshnikov for so many years yeah well i
did so like you might be tempted to play
gta x f6 because
uh
then you can
get use of your knight on c6 you know
play
at some point you can play b5 d5 f5 and
use all like all those moves but i feel
that here
it is
positionally um
very dubious it's not supported by the
tactics like it is in the svashnikov
variations so i would definitely take
with
with my queen here like with uh and did
he just take with the pawn yes he did
ali raza farouja came to fight today so
dania as we see him take a drink of
water we know what that means is you're
probably pretty happy about his here
what do you make of the position you are
a very aggressive tactical player
yeah but i
i would have i it's a good thing that he
made his move before i got a chance to
speak because i was about to say
something that was going to age
very very badly i was about to say that
she takes f6 should probably be reserved
for the realm of 30-second games
against the likes of rebecca harris
um but
the more i look at it the more first of
all if polyrhythm plays a move that
automatically means that you should take
it with a tremendous amount of respect
and it means that he's put a lot of
thought into it why was i initially
skeptical about the move
generally i feel like moves
that create static weaknesses by which i
mean permanent weaknesses and we can
talk about the permanent weakness of the
king no matter where black skin goes
maybe the only safe square left on the
board is h8 and it's not getting there
anytime soon
anytime you make a static weakness you
better have something to justify it
right because this is something you're
going to be dealing with the rest of the
game what does alireza think
justifies this static weakness the more
i look at it the more i realize that
this pawn mass can be really dangerous
for white especially if there's a trait
on e6 black can start pushing the deep
on pushing the f bomb the rook from h8
will go to g8 and then white's king
might not be too comfortable on the king
side so ali reza believes that the
compactness of his pawn structure and
his pieces overall coupled with the
g-file and the fact that all of his
quote-unquote weaknesses are actually
pretty well defended and there's a
significant defensive cocoon around his
king
all of that taken together in alireza's
opinion gives him winning chances on
balances the position and
counterbalances the weaknesses that he's
created with this last move it's a very
interesting decision probably one the
computer doesn't fully approve of
but i'm certainly not complaining i
don't know if hikaru nakamura
disapproves of it because he hasn't
moved yet he's that oh i'm not danny i
don't have the expert read on his facial
expressions but that looked to me like
hmm this isn't so clear and as we're
talking about you may get this tetris
piece formation with your pawn structure
but almira i mean what can you say just
about
the general thought process behind the
move and
ale raises courage
well first of all uh
hikaru made a move
made night of six moves after a long
thought because i think he had to
[Music]
come to sort of an agreement with
himself that knight of six doesn't yield
him a big advantage but he didn't want
to play bishop g5 so he calmed down he
played knight f6 and certainly was
thinking about queen f6 and how to
proceed afterwards maybe bishop b6 was
still his plan here and uh
black has to take with
the f bound f takes e6 here so
maybe he was
surprised with gtx f6 because uh this is
a very double edged mode of course the
position is very unbalanced but the king
will stay permanently in the center like
i mean black's king will
will remain in the center i think for
for this game well let me ask the two
i'll start with you donia where's
white's king going because will it
really be safe on no matter which way
you go
well i think between the king's side and
the queen side it's probably going to
the king's side my guess is that it
might travel all the way to h1
so one defensive construction you could
put together is you can castle kingston
you can play g2 g3 and normally you're
advised against pushing
pawns in front of your own king but here
it creates an effective
uh stopper against the rook it also
gives the knight a square on h4 which in
turn could open up a pathway for the
queen to go to h5 that can be a very
nasty idea when the king remains in the
center like this so
my guess is that he car is going to
castle king's side but he might not
hurry with that he might try to keep his
king in the center to give himself
maximum flexibility he's going to try to
see
how alireza positions his pieces before
making a final decision in my opinion
danian what do you think is there any
way or robert issue if you know to keep
this bishop and not to take on e6 is
this uh
right
you could try to trade on your own terms
what do you think of that robert you
definitely could play bishop to b3 and
then knight e5 can i force you
should be there
bishops are coming to trade no bishop d5
only on my terms
that's a
an extremely high level concept of not
taking the bishop initially bring it
back to b3 only when the knight goes to
the rim do you bring it back to d5 and
the point is that if this queen gets on
d5 i mean bishop takes you would like to
take with the queen on d5 the pawn on c2
does look hanging so we're getting kind
of deep into the weeds here but brook
takes c2 is not going to be so good
because when white castles you can see
the black king in the center lacking
development on the king side and you
could take a bunch of pawns but your
king is not going to be so thrilled
about the consequences as white's rooks
connect and start causing problems for
black so i think that it's very
interesting bishop b3 and elmira it's
really just a great thought that why
don't i just say you're going to take me
i'll take with my a pawn but what about
your other plan with knight to e7 you
were saying maybe this knight wraps
around maybe i play f5 maybe i play d5
this looks pretty unclear
yeah this is a typical swesnik of
maneuver especially on like
your pawn is on b7
here and in black's position because
very often it offers uh
a like
another target for white to hit like
they play a4 and black goes even
like sacrifices this two pawn
a4 ab5 takes on six in order to create
some counterplay
uh it's
oh it's very useful the pawns back on b7
and
again i'm not danny but i and danny was
wrong by the way the last time he's
trying to predict how hickar's hand
movements go but i just saw him looking
like he was going to drag the bishop
back to b3 so he very well could make
this bishop retreat that almirah uh
suggested it's
a big moment here i didn't even realize
bishop b2 which i know looks crazy but
um it's probably on on the list of his
candidate moves as well well we have a
great
a great comment from chat lester the
giraffe also a great username there if
takes then takes then takes then it
isn't so clear but i think then takes
then takes i i agree with that that's
just castle yeah that is
grand master level commentary by lester
the giraffe who knew that animals could
play chess so well so
[Laughter]
thank you to lester i mean position is
is unclear you know with that being said
i i do i do think that i do want to
trade on my terms here
well so you you just before we had that
comment you said bishop e2 might also be
something to consider but we'll see what
it card does he's on the clock he's
really deep in the think tank right now
already six minutes but you can tell by
his body language that he is ready to
consider any sort of capture and we do
have a fun little video about a car to
show you all
do you ever look at someone and wonder
what is going on inside their head i can
also trade and take and take and it
takes i take it takes takes takes
queenie two
queen h4 g3 knight g3 check c6 queen b7
knight h1 king there i don't know what's
going on i don't want to think too much
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was actually a quote you know yeah i
didn't know i had the feeling uh because
you all you were talking about this at
the very beginning and he goes uh bishop
detroit's like twitch communities are
playing against each other you know it's
like hikaru against uh alireza yeah
well you know hikara of course is the
biggest content creator chess content
creator on twitch in alireza he has
streamed quite a bit himself not so much
lately as he's focused on his
over-the-board career but right now he's
got the focus on this board because
bishop b3 is played he
kind of hits it back to alireza it's his
burden to decide what's going to happen
with these bishops and there are many
different choices whether it's rook to
g8 we mentioned knight to e7 you could
of course just slide your queen up to d7
so there's so many options here daniel i
want to make two
points one very quickly the reason
bishop b3 knight a5 and then bishop b5
if you had played bishop d5 in this
position instead of bishop
uh b3 i think the subtlety is that black
has bishop takes and if you take back
with the queen there is this incredibly
nasty knight before with a knight on a5
this is impossible the point isn't that
you lose c2 it's how you lose c2 black
takes with the knight fork and the rook
and the quark
that's the logistical point but i i
think that alireza may have someone
underestimated bishop b3 i think in his
mind he may have been slightly naively
hoping that hikaru would take on e6 and
then the landscape of the position
changes completely to me
playing with this structure is a lot
harder than playing with the f7 pawn
having shifted to e6 which greatly
increases the communication between the
center and the
and the king side by opening up the
seventh rank
and it just
makes black center a lot more healthy so
i really like this choice by hikaru i
think the clearest illustration is that
if you take on b3 this f5 square is
about to be filled by a white knight and
so the light squares are a problem you
only have a dark square bishop that is
not good news for black and uh knight a5
i think that's probably already his
first instinct and this bishop b to d5
move no it doesn't exactly end blocks
chances this knight wants to come to c4
so knight a5 isn't a one-trick pony it's
not just trying to take this bishop on
b3 it's also aiming for the c4 square so
i just got that
i'm glad you were
you got it but knight c4 already is
something to consider i know b7 is
hanging that may be a problem for black
but i could also take on e3 which double
isolates your pawn in the center and
it's just the style of the sicilian do i
really care about my queenside pawns or
am i going to be able to attack the
white king
it's a really interesting choice
from a psychological perspective my
bishop b3 is probably the most
unpleasant move you know for larry
zakharov so
he needs um
to be uh
very active here so that's why i like
this move knight
a5 beforehand and bishop d5
knight c4 once again
because b should be six here i
i feel that
well we didn't achieve much by playing
uh
because i can still play knight c4 here
and it's very unpleasant for white so
what you're saying is only one player
achieved something and it was only
raising
you have to be consistent you need to
play bishop t5
and
knight c4 seems very logical here to
me this is really difficult to assess i
mean we've all had positions maybe not
this exact one but similar positions
where we're like all right i see that my
opponent might win some material that
might be a problem for me but i see i
can maybe attack and ruin their pawn
structure and you see all that but
evaluating it correctly is the difficult
part and both these players working so
hard at the board but don't you just get
the feeling that this is alirez's type
of position not that it's not hikaru's
type position but we've seen other games
where it's been like a slow methodical
approach and alareza hasn't seemed to be
very thrilled to be in those positions
on the other hand right here this is
exactly the types of position that he
has
won to rise up to nearly 2 800. well i
agree with you
and i think that this is the first
critical position of this game because
it seems to me i feel that white needs
to make some concessions here you cannot
have it all you cannot have and the two
bishops and the control over d5 squares
so maybe you can castle and i was trying
to analyze um
the position i mean let's go to knight
c4 like the the position that we
analyzed
can you castle here and
to go for this structure it's
93 f takes c3 but then look at those
white squares
it's a very good point that opening up
the f file and this bishop on the dark
square is not going to be very helpful
in dealing with the light score problems
i was trying to analyze this line knight
e3 fdxc3
very often
there is this maneuver
black tries to play rook c5 and to force
it to take on the six once again but i
have the feeling this is way too slow
here
it looks that way here i can play c4
also in response to roxy f5
and i mean just so clear how white
continues the initiative so amir to your
point maybe you can allow this knight to
c4 and i kind of stopped there and it's
the player's responsibility to keep
going with their analysis and important
not just to assume that the position is
okay or not okay but to really calculate
and it's a good point so
i think as alireza he's gonna spend some
time here we can go back to our bird's
eye view we have all four games still in
progress here in the tenth round of the
2022 feeder candidates yonder palmishi
for everybody at home he is in the lead
by one full point he takes on that man
on screen oh team over job just moved
and actually in the bottom left-hand
side of the screen we talked about this
bishop f6 already so interesting play
here and good play by both players and
then we have someone chasing him and
that is fabiano caruana and oh my
goodness did we just see a big move by
fabi so we will get to that game right
now because he needs to win he needs
yondu palmshi to be slowed down and as
we bring up that game we see the last
move played by him was pawn g7 to g5 he
is holding absolutely nothing back
desperate times
yeah i mean he's not mincing his words
that's for sure
and if i remember correctly knight one
h2
is what we were
expecting here knight one h two h five
now there's a very important detail g3
appears to trap the queen
but let's not forget like as queen takes
g3 check
always a critical resource in these
positions
which is why oh so it doesn't work also
when i thought it was just danny i
thought it was his mouse i thought so
too but apparently
maybe i should try come on chess.com fix
this please ridiculous of course there's
there is a pin against the f2 pawn
but that is why on move 18 after or move
19 after h5 white should play d3 d4
and then if you look at this you might
say wait a second doesn't black have g4
and doesn't white's position collapse so
there's a critical subtlety here why can
start with hghg and now the inter mezzo
g3 doesn't trap the queen what it does
do is force it back to h6
right into the fork
uh with knight takes g4 and we play d4
in order to prevent queen's hd3 so
white's pieces work in perfect harmony
and he wins the game here
absolutely but if we go back g5 knight
h2
h5 so we said g3 not possible here for
white that's clear and you were just
saying let's throw in the move d4 it's
not like black has to play this move g4
of course and oh as we saw shouldn't how
about rook g6 why don't we line up this
g4 move and there is quite a lot of
tension in this position
not saying that black is better we see
very clearly that yantrist of duda
should have an advantage here but
could it be a position almeira where
it's getting very tactical and also easy
to go wrong
well i
wanted to suggest rook g6 even on the
move before
uh-huh here
before you play d4 but maybe it's just
um a transposition but it gives me an
opportunity to play rook f8 to bring
another rook
into place after d4
right so you don't have to rush with h5
it's not like knight g4 is or maybe take
first you know i i just said before that
first you take on d4 and then play rook
f8
well there is something to be said that
in this position
we don't have to take back what if we
play h5 now
and it's awfully subtle but you can't
play g3 because your pawn f2 is pinned
and if black gets to move g4 in
it's starting to
look scary for this white king this goes
from zero to 100 really really fast
this is very difficult to calculate
it's scary you you can't hide under the
eval bar if you're
duda i mean you have no idea if this is
winning or lost so that's always the
problem when you're getting attacked
when you're watching with an engine you
automatically know whether the attack is
justified or not so like why is he
taking this seriously he has no idea
he's like this could be winning for all
i know for black this could be losing
for black
that makes it so much more difficult
both emotionally
and practically to to find a response
but i don't know what you're looking for
america the good news for young chits of
duda is he's up half an hour on the
clock he is playing quickly so it is
true that they have no idea what the
exact evaluation is
but he's a strong player he's not having
his best event but he has so much time
to use
this is a very important factor to take
into consideration
but
this position is
not yet very concrete so if it would be
a position where he had to calculate a
very direct line then i would agree with
you completely but here
some mighty waters you know so like he
needs to understand where he
well his second knight belongs maybe he
has to move the knight on f3 first he
has to play knight h2 but then uh
he needs to find the perfect square for
the knight on f3 but he cannot move it
yet so maybe king h1 first and then move
the knight but it's
it looks very awkward to me here as well
so maybe we start with knight h2 here
right
uh
like what did we try h5 we tried h5
transpose he has to see first and
foremost h5 d4 duda has to see
in terms of concrete ideas this idea of
d4 if he doesn't see this
he's not going to play knight h2
and we're pretty sure that knight h2 is
the only way only path toward a clear
advantage and there's no way you want to
allow this g4 pawn push
let's say d4 here you suggested rook g6
i should play g3
okay
a queen goes somewhere and can i play
king g2 here i don't even know okay or
if it loses immediately after g4 and you
will take on d4 so where's some i mean
this looks
quite safe to me yeah and and i i like
what you were just saying though amira
that it looks safe but it's still
not concrete and the position is going
to remain
such that it's not just going to be okay
here i have a way to trade queens to
liquidate to solve my problems the
problems are going to remain and black
also has problems so we're not just
looking at this from fabiano caruana's
perspective but when it comes to king
safety we often get nervous and
jan chistov he hasn't looked himself in
the last few rounds maybe he you know
isn't playing at his absolute best and
we know his best is amongst the world's
best because he won the world cup by
eliminating magnus carlsen he won the
rapid and blitz tournament in poland
ahead of many of the top players in the
world
so
when your king is open
that's when we tend to lose our
objectivity and we know young subdued
but do we think he can remain objective
and
that is without knowing the actual
evaluation yeah i mean one thing
commentators
i think don't talk enough about is fear
they assume that top players are somehow
immune from fear but that fear starts
bubbling up to the top of your throat
anytime your king is in any amount of
danger and it doesn't matter
who you are it doesn't matter if you're
1700 or 2700 when your king is being
attacked there's always the possibility
that you've miscalculated something that
basically means you're gonna get
checkmated so we shouldn't underestimate
the impact but just being scared could
have on one's ability to figure out
objective defensive moves we're not
scared we're not as scared i mean i'm
scared for dude as king but i'd be a
little bit scared if it was my own king
on g2 that was being attacked by fabiana
carwana baby has checked checkmated my
king in the past
um and i was pretty darn scared so
we should consider that factor
as well and we should evaluate how judah
uh how judah fights that natural fear
which always rises up when you get
attacked well actually i asked robert
about
this well in the previous rounds because
i was
[Music]
well
trying to
get away
with this feeling because it overwhelms
me during my games so i think that you
were you were right you know fear is a
very physical reaction you know and even
your your heart rate is different so
maybe you lose your objectivity at some
point so it's
it's very important to talk about this
for sure and
while jan chistov duda he's in the clock
we see some of his reactions here he is
calculating hard he's plenty of time to
spend and another player with plenty of
time to spend is dingley wren as we see
in the top left-hand side of the screen
dangly wren with one hour 20 minutes his
opponent rich report with only 53
and
we said this from the beginning that if
dingley wren was
looking for more wins he got his first
taste of victory right before the rest
day he would play g5 he has done that he
has pushed his pawns forward and
i really like black's position here and
i know that
you know from seven moves back we've
been talking about g5 it looks exciting
the king remains in the center but
doesn't black just have more control
over this board
of course he does but first of all i
wanted to make a joke that he was forced
to bring his knight on c6 you know
because he had both knights on the rim
you know 95 and knight h5 that's true
but they were controlling the posi like
both sides of the board so a3 b4 is a
very typical plan for white here you
show that yes so i just go back so
finally with g5 kick the bishop back and
you said a3 b4 yep if you can't play d4
in this position very often you switch
to a3 and b4 with white
and that isn't exactly what happened we
said rook to b8 king h1 i think perhaps
that report wants to take with the f
pawn
staring down the f-file and why take on
g3 that bishop can't move so rook to b7
what a constant amira you talked about
rook a1 to a2 in the duty game and here
we see that rook coming up to the
seventh rank in this one
that is creative stuff there is creative
stuff but on the other hand uh when i
had a look at this position before
i was asking myself
if we could possibly uh make it work
like sacrifice something 95 because the
knight on h5 for the moment is very
vulnerable
so i was thinking is there any way that
we could uh exploit
this fact
that 95 never seemed
to be working like
that's annoying
[Music]
not a good piece that's a big pawn yeah
this is just a tough position so
one there was one idea that they had
just a second okay it was like before
they uh before he played king h1 could
you play bishop e5 i know that that's a
crazy sacrifice then take on the five
but then you would simply go knight to
four probably because then i wanted to
play f4
ah
but of course it doesn't work but the
idea was if you play knight six then i
would play a four
and maybe
ah no yeah
something down there file but now that
it's not sufficient here of course
we know with the evaluation bar right
there we can easily tell it doesn't work
but what we're just talking about
sometimes it's scary for the person
whose king is under attack and here it
would have been dingley wren's king but
instead he fianchettoed his rook brook
b8 and then moved it again and then he
moved it again the knight was forced
back as amirah indicated came back and
then he moved to c7 he wanted no part of
a potential pin and so we see bishop d5
and g4
by dingley ren so in the game between
duda and caruana we saw a knight get
stuck over on the rim
it could happen in this game as well
i think it's quite likely that it will
happen knight h4
is a very tempting move because the
knight aims for the f5 square
and now i think ding is relying on
knight c6 to e7 that knight has gotten
its money's worth it's gotten to a5
now goes back to e7 hits the bishop the
bishop should probably move bishop b3 or
bishop a2
is natural
but uh at this point i wouldn't rule out
black castle and kingside then trying to
put the king on h7
and continuing to expand on the kings
side with an eventual
f7 f5 maybe maybe 97 to g6
but white's pieces are kind of stuck in
mud i think that's the larger problem
here
report doesn't really have a plan look
at the knight on h4 you're indicating
the bishop under three and the knight on
d2 is almost fully restricted by black's
pawns the g4 pawn controls f3 b5 pawn
control c4 where is that knight going to
go report he doesn't like positions
where he doesn't have dynamic play we
know that
and i think ding knows that as well
he's
acquitting himself excellently i think
you're in the early middle game
i really really like his position and
for dingley ren who scored his first
victory he went to a tie with hikaru
nakamura so if daily wren
can keep that train on going and he can
win this game with the black pieces it's
not inconceivable that
he makes his way towards the top i mean
he's two points behind yonder palm
shield they already played head to head
but we talked about how other players
will try to beat jan and if dingley wren
can win this game and let's say yan
isn't unable to win his then that gap is
shrinking
yeah i mean you could considerably
imagine ding wins
uh let's say hikaru
draws or wins doesn't matter fabiano
with the white with the black pieces
let's say he loses
if john somehow loses and then ding wins
the following game and y'all says again
he's in first place but i know that's
extremely unlikely to happen what i'm
saying
is i agree it's not
you know it it would have been
incansable two rounds ago but all of a
sudden you can see how quickly things
change all it takes is one loss at the
top
and the sharks at the bottom
start smelling blood and you know what
happens then well almira the last
candidates dingler had a very bad first
half but the second half he caught fire
he even beat janna pomschi in the final
round and he ended up with quite a
decent score so dingley wren he's a
player that we all know he's been number
two in the world over 2 800 he's
a force
what do you think does he have what it
takes to recover from a shaky first half
and really play a part down the stretch
here well he's certainly a force
which you have we have to be reckoned
with like i
i cannot formulate anything today
but uh the thing is that um
i was a bit skeptical about his last
move g4 because it gave this h4 square
but
uh
meanwhile uh richard played bishop h4
i was mostly looking at knight h4 yeah
me too
so what what is the difference he
because i wanted to play knight h4 and
f4 then if you castle by the way that
was my suggestion
so is he forcing him to play uh
queen d7 can i play knight e7 here well
as we analyze right two different
options queen d7 or knight t7 which
might just transpose because with the 97
you probably will have to move your
queen just to unpin your knight but
tomato tomato yeah yeah both moves look
pretty good to me queen to d7 and this
knight's under attack i
imagine it's going to one of these two
squads but 97 is a major pest
yeah
because
if you don't take it it's coming to g6
and houston we've got a problem with the
g with the h4 bishop if you do take it
and black's got the two bishops queen
takes c7
knight from h5 coming to f4 bishop
skewering the board the h pawn is going
to move forward
this looks really unpleasant again i
don't want to overstate it it's still a
very unclear position but you know what
i'm you understand what i'm saying i
mean this just looks excellent for black
because
often when you get an attack there's
some weakness like when we're looking at
the game between duda and caruana white
was opening up that queen side causing
fabiano to stall his attack
here it might not be a checkmating
attack but black hasn't committed any
sins on the chessboard and amir we've
you know talked about what our chess
education teaches us earlier it looked
kind of odd now we look at this and say
well black kind of got everything he
could possibly ask for
on the other hand maybe richard thought
i don't know what to do with this bishop
anyway you know so let's play bishop h4
and trade it for this knight
right that makes a lot of sense because
the bishop wasn't doing much of anything
here let's at least get the trade with
the knight but i think that
i mean then i can come to e1 instead of
g1 i'm not actually sure which square is
better uh we can venture around to e3 at
some point yeah but the same exact move
no not the rook the knight coming e7
attacking this going to g6 and if we
show
what happens if the bishop retreats this
looks like a huge problem because i'm
not going to take your bishop anymore i
don't think i might even move my knight
and just try to push my h-bond yeah
knight hf4
white's position
sucks here i mean it's just terrible
and you know yeah yeah no he has to take
on the seven because uh that's the logic
behind the move bishop h4 because he was
so concerned with all the pawn pushes
like h5 f5 is the one possible so he
he decided to
well to go for this positional idea okay
and can we just once again talk about
how ding's rook moved like a knight it
went from a8 to c7 until the perfect
square just that kind of recognition
from ding to move the rook before he's
even castled and we have a great comment
here this tournament has made me a big
report fan let's go we have dingley wren
on screen he's not going to be happy to
read that so get that out of his
eyesight yeah you can tell how angry he
is
ding is just fuming
another interesting tweet here
or a message rather i like watching the
cancer because i can spam blunder
whenever one color gets bigger the other
color in that little bar on the left and
that is the faux pas that so many
people make when they read just the
evaluation bar because uh things can be
much trickier than a seesawing bar would
indicate but you know i had this thought
what made it
interesting to watch the chess
tournaments is that uh before like we
couldn't judge but now everyone has the
possibility to judge even the best
players in the world because they have
you know the evil bar and the computers
you know which could help us analyze the
game and i mean speaking of judging
someone just said i created an account
to say don is an incredible commentator
this person did not just create their
account sure i don't have to look into
their twitch history they're just saying
that because they knew it would be
included
a hater because i've got fans no i'm i'm
appreciative of the comment i'm just
saying it's highly unlikely that person
just i agree with that i agree
in fact you're like i know that account
that's my friend hb of course yeah how
much did you pay that 47.
i talked to him every day thank you
though i really appreciate it yeah i
would love to see those kind comments
coming in and i mean this event it's
still so much left to play for i think
you know a couple of rounds ago we were
talking about how yonder palm shield
five minute carwana it's gonna be
between the two of them but as those two
players perhaps start to slow down
aren't going to necessarily win as many
games and players like dingley wren and
alireza farouja hikara nakamura as they
feel that fire burning beneath them i
mean they are playing chess in a way
that's all out again there's no there's
a point for them to just play it safe
and make draws even team over java who
beat nakamura he continues to fight
against yonder pomachine
oh but it's also it's not so easy just
to sit here you know and everyone is
criticizing your play so he needs to
make some well adjustments and some
changes
in his opening repertoire in in the way
he plays and he finally won his first
game you know more so
and this is true for every player you
know
they have to go all in yeah and they get
criticized but the one way you can't get
criticized if you go to a break so we're
heading on out here for the time being
we'll come back in a few minutes that's
hikaru nakamura the biggest chess twitch
streamer on the planet his eyes are
darting from side to side he's trying to
figure out his best move we'll leave him
to it we are here at the 20 22 feet of
candidates this is chess.com coverage
live from madrid
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
in qualifying for the candidates hikaru
nakamura ratcheted up the level of
interest in what is already considered
the most important tournament in chess
with millions of followers as a popular
content creator hikaru brings along his
sizable community while also attracting
more casual chess fans
although once ranked number two in the
world most believe nakamura's best days
competing in classical chess were behind
him
that changed when this japanese american
grand master leaned on his exceptional
calculating ability to win the fide
grand prix the unexpected victory earned
him a bid into the candidates for the
first time in six years
a five-time u.s champion hikaru has
stayed sharp of late by dominating in
speed chess formats nakamura is
currently ranked by fide in the top two
in both rapid and blitz
a chess giant on twitch and youtube
ikaru brings a special buzz to a
tournament that already holds the keys
to becoming the next world champion
and there are certainly those who have
yet to rule out hikaru from catching
lightning in a bottle here in madrid
[Music]
what's the best thing for you in madrid
you have found here
well everything first of all people but
it was since my childhood that i have
discovered that people are great here
and
in general i love spain okay thank you
very much
[Music]
now
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
[Music]
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i like the lights
foreign
[Music]
well it is indeed true the chairs are
world champion size but as we come back
from break i want to make sure that
everybody remembers who we are
international master almira scrivchenko
grandmaster daniel naradiski i'm grand
master robert hess i'll mirror that
video i
did you already leave by the time it was
made or had you seen it before no i
haven't seen it
i wanted to say uh
chairs are going crescendo you know if
we could say this about
our chairs
[Music]
so
i live is
in a deep thought now he isn't a deep
thought and i mean the chairs may be too
big for the players but the stage has
proven you know quite large for all the
razer fruga as well he did struggle in
the first half of the tournament his
last two games have been improvements he
pushed against team over java ultimately
the game was a draw he did win against
richard report right before the rest day
and now here against hikaru nakamura
he's spent quite a lot of thought
because
hegar slowed down and now alireza he's
doing very much the same
yeah i mean g takes up six it's the kind
of decision where if he wins the game
alireza wins game with brilliant opening
move ali reza innovates crazy opening
idea to bidicaro if you lose this crazy
ella reza perugia makes absurd move in
the opening alireza ferrugia uh blunders
positionally in a basic way in the
opening to lose the game so i wouldn't
criticize alireza too much for gtx f6 i
think it was a very creative option
i think it's admirable that he's playing
for a win but i don't like it from a
purely practical standpoint i don't like
it from an objective standpoint i feel
like he's given hikaru a very clear
roadmap and now hikaru has acquired that
confidence
and you can tell by the time that
alireza is spending on his move
you might be having some second thoughts
but maybe not we'll see
well while that game still is just in
the opening stage the game beyond the
napomshi team over jabba that's our
tournament leader yonda palmachi and for
java who scored his first classical
victory in three years over hikaru
nakamura and that game well some trades
have happened so if you're team over
jabo we have him on camera here we have
a snoring daniel nerdky beside me and
that's because dania clearly believes
that this game is simplifying to the
point where it should be a draw
i think yes if for java takes the right
piece
if knight takes d7 that falls into a
trap
uh-huh so why don't you tell us about
the straps we bring up the analysis
boards you're saying knight takes d7
which looks like such a natural move
that move
is not going to be what you want so nope
because
notice the back rank anytime you don't
have luft you need to be paranoid about
your back ring white doesn't need to be
worried about the same thing because any
background check can be parried with
bishop g2 to f1 how does that help after
bishop takes f6 knight takes f6 looks
like white has to move the queen but no
all of a sudden the rook captures the
pawn on c4
threatening to take on c8 and if rook
takes c4 then the very same queen that's
hanging takes on c4 white is a full pawn
up obviously we're jabba and he's
already not done that he has taken the
correct piece he has taken on d4 this
leads to a forced liquidation an
opposite card bishop end game and a
guaranteed draw which will be i think
our first result of the day because
nothing that 97 can do on mira it has to
take on b6 and trades galore
well i agree with the use
yeah so
knight takes b6
i think is
an absolute necessity and
after knight takes b6 queen takes b6 b2
f2
both hanging and once b2 is captured
looks like c4 will be capturing response
this looks like a complete draw yes we
will play e3 here bishop b2 rook c4 this
is the very first line so rook c4
well
maybe not this works c4 oh wait this is
the same oh
you still have grenades you see it's
like today it's not my day yes we're
just assuming right this is a problem
with assuming chris calculating queen
takes c4 of course would be a draw queen
8 i get to draw an arrow from that queen
to that king because that is back rank
checkmate
so yeah we don't think any of that will
happen but i'll mirror you know as we
maybe
take a step back from the specifics and
think about the broader picture here
yonder pom she came in today we had
questions would he really fight he did
but he didn't get much of anything so
this is going to be another draw for him
which means that nobody can catch up if
rajabov continues to play this perfectly
which we expect he will so nobody can
catch up to him
but can you really get in this mindset
of vote every half point or you know he
gets the black pieces tomorrow against
olympia farouza
to be honest you know i'm thinking about
curacao in 1962. i remember that
tournament yeah you know i was i was
there as well and the thing is that i
just read the book about this tournament
and i don't know why
i was thinking could it be
like a
draw offer
like
wonder job of made a draw like with
white pieces so it was like a drawer for
both games like you mean an implicit
yeah place a draw offer for both games
like i i feel like
uh
vajava in that first game i'm agreeing
with you he just didn't really fight and
maybe it's because he had suffered a
loss in the round before it and today i
mean yonder posture clearly was playing
for a little something and he's just not
getting much
of anything and i think if you said
before the tournament who would be happy
with two draws between these players it
would be rajabo because yon napomishi is
the more practice player he's in good
great shape but at this point when you
look at jan on screen here he's going to
keep the lead he should be happy overall
but he doesn't look particularly pleased
right he's kind of
he's looking at the board but he
probably isn't analyzing very much
because all the pieces are coming off
and do you think he might feel like it's
a wasted opportunity
i don't know why he went for this line
then if we come back you know to the
position after um
knight b6 95 96. okay
yes here here
95.95 95 96 we analyzed this position
i think quite accurately so if you
don't go for you don't go for 95 q4 if
you if you don't see an advantage here
so
i have a feeling it's something strange
about this game
there is something i cannot justify
it rationally but
[Music]
yeah i mean it doesn't feel like a real
fight i agree with you mira
what's weird to me
is a little something a little bit
different this line that timur played
everybody's playing in that nowadays
literally everybody's playing b5
and if you're consciously going for
a line like this
you generally have something prepared
i'd compare this to fabi going for that
petrov line against nepo in the previous
round he didn't just go for it to go for
it he had something prepared it seems
like nepo didn't really challenge timur
i don't even know what the novelty was
but
it didn't seem like timor struggled at
any point in this game
to figure out the equalizing path we
thought that nebo had a pleasant
position
maybe we'll be able to nitpick and find
better options but
i'm on the same page as omira
i feel like he didn't really challenge
rajabov and this was a game which
i think nepo
could have probably tried a little bit
harder to win at the same time let's not
lose sight of the big picture he's a
point ahead it's much more important for
him
uh not to lose than it is to win as long
as he keeps that lead draws are totally
fine for him so i get it he survived
five in caruana before that he didn't
really try against dingley wren because
he has the chairman lead he's tried hard
enough in the first half of the
tournament when he started five and a
half of the second out of seven excuse
me a record at the canvas no one has
ever had four wins compared to no losses
so he's made history so maybe he doesn't
need to continue pressing for victories
as we're saying he entered a full point
ahead that means with that half point
nobody can catch up to him and if
somebody does get closer five-minute
carwana and we'll zoom out and look at
fabiano's position if fabiano wins today
then perhaps jan will feel differently
about his opening choices but he will
exit today with this draw as the sole
leader so let's go back to our bird's
eye view let's look at the
all four games at once we see that
fabiano caruana he's locked in this
tactical melee and the last move by dudo
is bringing the rook to d1 so
i think we should head over there i'm
also of course still fast in the top
left what is happening there dame lee
ren's rook is just on c3 it looks like
it grabbed a pawn but
fabiano being in second place let's go
on over to his board against jan chistop
duda who's had the white pieces who has
had the advantage and the last couple
moves almira we saw after knight h2 the
move you've been talking about forever
rook g6 d4 played
and nothing
surprising in the last couple turns
well here we're considering
king g2 or rogue d1
both moves are
very logical here so
another possibility after rook d1 that
white has is to take on e5 and also play
rook d7 to invite the seventh rank
you know i wanted to say actually when
we were analyzing this but this position
now i remember that i wanted to play
king g7 take on d4 and to play e5 in
order you know to open my bishop if only
i could make two moves at one time so
maybe still came g7 here
but i guess your problem right oh yes i
just i just said it you know
you were talking about this book coming
up to the seventh rank so king g7 i
completely can stand behind the idea but
after it takes takes that rook that you
were just
maybe that's why rook d1 is more
accurate than kim ji2
you know so it's sort of anticipates
king g7 and uh take on d4
but i would argue that
can you repeat omira what the idea of
king g7 is
i wanted to play king g7 take on d4 and
to play e5 today aha that's
[Music]
understood
although you could start with king g2
and you still have time after king g7 to
put the rook on d1
like the important thing is just that
you have a rook on d1
when black is ready to go for almira's
idea and taken gotti fine right so you
should just have a rook on the one
anyway that's a very important piece
i'm deeply concerned about fabi's
position now the question for big
question for duda is going to be what if
fabby doesn't do anything what if he
puts his rook on f8
whatever plays rook g7
how is yantristov going to resolve the
tension he's obviously better he's
dominating on all sides of the board
maybe save the king side
but what is the actual plan of
improvement
i wish i had an easy answer that because
the rook on g7 now covers the seventh
rank so d takes e5 on one hand is very
tempting because you hand block the
double isolated pawns but we also know
the bishop one a7 has been closed off
and as soon as you take on e5 you open
this bishop down to f2 and that could
pose very big problems for white as g4
is certainly on the menu
it's really not an easy choice for yon
chisto i think he wants to keep the
tension in the center
talking about the menus you know once in
china by the way you know i found it
like in shanghai a russian restaurant
which was such a big surprise to me
and the menu was very interesting
because the
the last
page had broken chair broken glass
broken windows and broken doors and well
you could order those
was that food no of course not it's just
that well sometimes we'll well you you
want to break something
[Laughter]
that was on the menu how about broken
mice that's something i would order i
thought of the type of food i just
didn't know and yes you have a
brief history of breaking a mouse or two
but also we've had a long history of
players standing right in front of the
camera so we thanks to our producers
changing the angle there but uh yanches
of duda he looks more relaxed now i
think this is the most relaxed we've
seen him in like five days yeah i mean
he knows he's better he knows he's
playing relatively risk-free this is the
best position he's had in the last three
games so it makes sense that he's more
satisfied with himself i think
frustration generally comes out of
dissatisfaction with your own play
you're angry at yourself and you're
continually going down those lips why
did i play this move why did i get
myself into this position
right now he's pretty satisfied with his
own play
and
he's
you know he's going to try everything he
can to cash in fabi's also pretty low on
time they've only made 21 moves
both of them are under an hour so
once again i think we're gonna see some
time scrambles today
and even right here this moment for yon
chistop because this king it probably
wants to move and i think king g2 is
extremely natural so i would be very
tempted to bring the king up to g2
something of being on the same diagonal
as this bishop even though the line is
closed for now that makes me want to
bring my king up to g2 but i also see
black's next move rook cafe
and diane you were making this point
like it's not really apparent how white
does something significant you can
like your position you give black these
double isolated pawns but from there
like that knockout blow seems very far
in the future
i'm thinking and thinking and i
i mean it is i think a good practice to
go flank by flank queen side center king
said and ask yourself can i do anything
on either flank queen side
okay he's made the move king h1 and let
me jump straight to the point i think he
might be preparing the move h3h4 trying
to establish a stronghold for his knight
on g5 it's quite paradoxical that
white's plan is actually on the king
side and yet i think that's exactly what
he's trying to do
wow that's a good point because we take
the knight can simply take back thanks
for the queen's defense of the f2 pawn
yeah and as
is desired h4g for the knight can sink
its teeth into the g5 square
exactly yes if you play h4 g4 you we
want to play knight g5 oh yeah then
group g5
sacrifices yeah but then e6 is going to
hang so there's going to be logistical
difficulties it's pretty clear it's
going to show exactly what we're talking
about if g4
knight to g5 can we in fact take on g5
it probably should just be good for
white but some of these positions with
h4 coming if you could quickly get your
rook into the game but no
because i'm going to play f3 very
quickly here i think i'm gonna rip open
the king side yeah and you're like
basically playing down a rook yes you're
playing down a rope because you're black
is coming down exchanging the knight on
a5 i was
i've been picking on this piece but just
because there's no squares to go to so
fabiano's in big trouble here yeah
basically in this position you have only
one piece which is a tekken and that's
the queen
that's right
that's a little yeah sag
that's that's not enough so what can
black dude black can play g4 so that you
can't play h4 that takes away that
option but after h
after g4 hg
hg this knight cannot come to h4 so we
wanted to get an outpost for a knight
then that h4
it is an outpost it's a bit of an odd
one but i head into f5 and if black
takes on d4 you want
an exchange shotgun d4 or
some sort of if oh
oh my god oh i know there's some
beautiful ideas e5
d e cd and you wear a second exchange
and play knight f5 then huh
i mean you know me better than i know
myself i don't even need to say anything
i think i can go go rest look at this i
mean this is just gorgeous absolutely
amazing situational awareness the knight
comes in because if it's captured you
move the rook with discover check if you
allow me i'm going to play knight h6
check forking if you play rook h7 which
seems to take away the h6 square i mean
there must be a number of moves that are
good but the main point is the black
king is wide open and it's not clear to
me this is plus
six and a half or plus seven or whatever
it's getting to
but it's obvious that black's king is in
some serious trouble right
i mean yeah there's going to be a
knockout well even queen a2 to d5
gathering the forces together and
it all comes back to one thing it's like
a refrain and you got to keep mentioning
that refrain black is playing without a
piece you can't
sustain your counter play forever
without without the knight on a5
right wow
wow wow wow
all right fabiano even individual moves
at this point are super difficult amira
he can play g4 to not allow the knight
into g5 you can start with rookie eight
noting that the knight will land on g5
you might just have to live with it but
we were just talking about at least i
was saying that i don't see
how duda concludes this game and now
after a simple move king h1 i'm like
well this is looking really scary and i
think we have to give him credit because
king g2 is generally
the more natural square but if we just
show this you can't play h4 after the
king is on a g2 because if i make this
rook e8 move after h4 i take it and your
king is
exactly where it doesn't want to be
and
i can't find a way to bring this knight
into play you know i i've tried
everything in my head so it's
it seems impossible
yeah i honestly don't want to look at
that 9 85 anymore i mean it's really
just
unpleasant and fabiano he's probably
worried and if we think what's happened
in the back half of the tournament in
round seven
stream run eight pardon me he um
played against hikaru nakamura he lost
that game in round nine he drew against
yonder palm street from a better
position with great preparation on the
white side and here in round 10 he's in
serious trouble so
the storyline heading into the event
where he's lost his mojo can yon do it
for 14 rounds in a row and right now it
seems like fabiano he really got stopped
he ran to a brick wall in the car
nakamura and since then
things haven't been going right yeah
that game really took the air out of the
building for for friday it just hasn't
been the same
in these last three games
and
yeah i mean it's it's just so clear that
it's it's been two different people
playing the first half in the second
half of the tournament
and
for better for worse that happens right
the candidates is not only an exercise
in opening preparation and good play but
in stamina in endurance well the
endurance of young palm shield has been
admirable i'm going to pull that game up
fascinating position well no they are
finishing their game they're making uh
last games just to
conclude this one
and they're moving their bishops back
and forth same pawn structure opposite
colored bishops nothing to see here
except for a handshake after the final
move of the repetition
almira yondapan machine you know he's
getting it done
well and this was his strategy also in
the second half of the last candidates
you know he you were talking about this
you know he was
taking no risks as i as far as i
remember and even when he played his
game against maxim vashilagraf which was
of the crucial importance he
he
tried to well
to have a very solid position
and
went for a draw like maxim tried to
complicate the matters but he just
couldn't do it
and team over java definitely had no
opportunity to do so but they're talking
uh janupomshi looking pretty happy all
things considered so
[Music]
they're just chatting about the game
i don't know really what there is chat
about because that game seemed pretty
balanced i think they might be
discussing this end game in the final
position
that is definitely not what they're
discussing maybe uh they're asking hey
any good restaurants you've been to
maybe you have a recommendation for me
mm-hmm but yana pomgy i can't recommend
anything for his play because he leads
this tournament seven points out of ten
games amira
who's gonna stop this guy
well let's have a look at uh
the pairings uh if we have them
at some point but that game has
concluded we definitely will look at
yonder palm she's upcoming schedule
my eyes went back to the top left board
there it gets more and more complicated
with every move
does either player know what's happening
in that game
it doesn't appear
that way but i'm also looking at reports
clock he's got 32 minutes for a position
this complex
okay
you know just a quick note in the bottom
right hand side that already brought
knight t7 played d5 but let's
go on over to the game between dingley
ren and report because that game is just
absolutely crazy so we'll bring that one
up we'll analyze it right now
and
i think richard has somehow made
lemonade out of lemons here well i
mentioned this idea that he wanted to
play a fourth of
um
knight d5 here seems very risky
hmm
i you know
because you take the queen i mean
i i haven't looked at this or analyzes
nearly as seriously as the players and i
don't want to be the guy who just sort
of
you know kind of waves his his hands
around with the decision by ding to take
that pawn on c3 robert
i think he may have
over salted it a little bit because that
rook was a hero
but i don't know if opening up the
position and facilitating the move f2 f4
was particularly wise i personally
really liked the old idea move your
queen from d8 prepare knight g6 keep the
position relatively closed and most
importantly prevent f2l4 which is
white's essentially only source of major
counterplay
am i wrong uh looks like a good choice
to show some restraint here i guess
white can stop on f3 instead of going up
to f4 but i do concur the pawn f4 looks
a little bit more challenging for black
to deal with because greed sometimes
very rarely can be good thing loren goes
for it and then after 92 brings his rook
back and maybe he just doesn't believe
report right he feels like he's bluffing
a little bit he's going for some kind of
attack
but he is
this beating the red with the black
piece up a pawn almira
what do you think is this uh a bluff or
does richard report really have an
attack brewing no that's what i wanted
to like i made the joke so now that you
cannot play knight g5 you need to do
something about this pin
and he did it
he's almost forced to play f6
yeah otherwise he's so tied down yes
so um
i really like richard's position now and
it suits him so well
wow f6 i mean what a move here
dingley ren is king is in the center
his uh
this position is opening up and yet he
simply
goes f6 done he's not afraid about his
king because he really wants to be able
to take this bishop here on d5
i like it f6 no i think f6 is the
principled move you have to
douse the flames of white's king side
attack
i'm not entirely convinced that he wants
to play knight 65 97 to g6 might also be
on the docket that's actually
sort of a semi threat because that would
pile up on the f4 pawn
but how do you even make a decision here
with white i'm looking at this position
i'm feeling totally overwhelmed effie
it's like
when i took my ap calculus exam
where do i start do i take the integral
the derivative f5 fe queen e1 queen b3
9g3 and you've got 30 minutes
this is an incredibly daunting task draw
all those arrows that you were just
mentioning it's like so many different
moves and that
is a very legitimate point that this
position
it's so complicated that you don't even
know what your first move is and you're
trying to look through the branches of
variations here and all of them look
enterprising but which one is actually
best in richer report i thought he was
about to move for a moment there but i
just want to show that after pawn takes
e5 d takes e5 the pawn f6 is not hanging
because if their bishop takes on f6
knight takes f6
uh rook takes and after knight takes d5
this one is
just gonna win a piece for black so
yeah this is gonna be a
problem for
richard
he can't equalize the material and so he
has quite a lot to figure out
well we are
quite happy here to be joined in the
studio by none other than tournament
leader yonder palm shield how are you
feeling
uh
no idea
basically okay i
had in mind this line can occur today
and i thought that this
bishop e3 is a very tricky move mm-hmm
and in fact after green i think we need
five board up here so everything yeah i
think queen e5 is an accuracy
okay uh but
i mean okay because you know i studied
this line is black a little bit here
because okay it was one of my
obviously why one of the lines uh i was
working before the mage uh but uh yeah
somehow it turned out that
well what kids was quite reasonable and
unfortunately maybe i'm winning the pawn
on c4 but
i could never i could never find a way
so well maybe maybe that's just not good
enough for white well was that part of
your strategy because when you're the
white piece against dingley wren you
just kind of killed the game and here
against rajab did you just want a safe
position that you could play for two
results well obviously like
considering tournament situation i don't
think i'm you know in a position to take
some major risk
uh but uh anyway i was trying to
you know pull out something pull
something out of the opening and uh
you know it seemed to me that i did but
you know once again but uh yeah it's
it has to be analyzed maybe i just
uh
misread uh something
jan were you more proud of some of your
wins or the way that you defended
against fabiano in that difficult
position
you had much less time what are you
most satisfied with so far in this
tournament
uh
most satisfied that is it's only like
four hours to go
that's uh that's only thing which you
know which like really warms my heart
uh but yeah
four extremely difficult games but uh i
mean still yeah
uh but in a serious not speaking on the
games
i think
well uh
i can't say like uh
it's only about lucky okay that i
managed to win some games also i mean of
course it was very important to
uh to have a good start like beating
dink with black pieces was like uh
quite uh quite something but in general
i'd say that
you know it's
maybe it's not the time you know to
choose
not yet the time to choose the game or
something yeah it's it's how someone
games to play well as you said the first
gaming sting went perfectly for you and
now it seems like ding is finding his
form a little bit more so
but i'm not playing him yeah exactly i
was about to say you know
when you look down the stretch of course
there's no specific opponent that you
have in mind but uh how much do you and
your tournament standing in first place
look at these other players and see this
player is on fire i'm glad i already
finished with him or do you not care who
your opponent is i think everybody can
uh suddenly you know you know come up
with some great game and uh be on fire
because you know all players here are
extremely talented extremely strong
and uh
you know i believe
somehow i thought like before my game
with young sister i felt like he was
showing
very you know very nice chess
and uh yeah
to me it came as a surprise that he
suffered so
you know
you know few bad games in a row but i
guess now maybe he's doing maybe now
he's doing fine yeah maybe now he's
doing fine but in general
uh well you know once again yeah it's
not like uh someone is
clearly out of form so despite the score
it's still
still you know very much is left behind
the curtains
jan um maybe there's no answer to this
question and the answer is both do you
think it's
more important to be extremely well
prepared or fresh and not fatigued when
you come to the game how do you manage
your time after the round to make sure
that you're both prepared and you come
to the board fresh it doesn't matter how
do i manage i i can't come fresh here
this doesn't work i mean yeah i mean i
mean seriously but
of course um you know when you
uh i would say
repeat one line you know for for example
okay let it be i don't know for example
petrov yeah like every day before every
game with black pieces uh so maybe after
you know three or four games you already
more or less show that you okay won't
won't forget everything so you can maybe
skip a little bit of preparation yeah so
long you know longer the tournaments
last of course you know the fresh mind
it comes to the you know
to the front to the front row i would
say well you're talking about being
fresh what'd you do on your rest day
basically i'm spending my rest days uh
in my bed
so that's i'm okay surely you know go
going to you know for for some long walk
but also just on a res day i try to rest
and
uh i'll say no no touristic facilities
so far
one more question about experience level
uh you're obviously very experienced you
have a world championship match under
your belt several candidates do you
think experience plays a big role in the
candidates and on that note do you think
somebody like alireza
is experiencing a lot of problems with
nerves or is that not as important as
your play this is just you know another
tournament but what do you mean several
candidates it's like several for example
this is a you know
you know you can better say this about
like fabiano for example he has several
i mean one two then several yeah well
not many people have a world
championship match uh yeah is quite a
thing also but for example fabian also
has it
no but
i'd say uh
this you know also helped me a lot in
the last edition
in the previous edition that i spent you
know i think uh two previous candidates
uh in uh
as a commentator so i just
i mean i was like watching it really
closely and i understood like which are
which is you know the most common
problem
uh
like
looking at some specific players i would
say yes so it's like they're playing
brilliantly but still they can't maybe
i don't know
stick to the plan yeah at some point
yeah so i mean in general
as i said it like maybe two years ago or
something it's very important try not to
lose
so if you know if you don't lose okay
this this is surely going all right but
yeah wait so you said doing commentary
helps your chest is that what you're
saying
uh i haven't uh i haven't done
commentary for quite some time yeah so
and still i consider like i have some
progress yeah but uh
i would say that back then uh
like during the commentary i really i
really spent quite a lot of time like
working on chassis or like working some
specific lines okay just checking this
line uh
live within giant and uh analyzing
checking some games which i probably
wouldn't do
so
if i would be just like uh
some guy from the audience uh so it was
like some kind of a trick to to
to get to to get over my laziness yeah
i need to learn from you yeah
yeah i have one one more question for
yon and
you know i gotta ask this
do you
care at all about magnus's comments or
have you sort of put that out of your
mind and
you know you'll cross that bridge
if you get there kind of thing well it's
uh
actually danny already asked me asked me
to say okay first danny then daniel
who going to be next year so what while
uh while the tournament is
is going on yeah i think like there is i
mean anything can happen and the result
can be uh
so when i see the final you know
standings yeah the cross table then okay
i would already think about
some some other aspects but for now it's
i think it's the last thing i should do
and i saw you look in the monitor
looking probably a 500 karwans game uh
any quick thoughts on his game before we
let you go and get your rest
so far it's so good for right but it's
still very complex i think
but the problem with with this knight on
e5 v8 it will never get into play but i
think
i think maybe white can just go for
something okay english one i didn't
understand the move at first but maybe
he just wants h4 and knight g5 yeah yeah
yeah maybe defend f so maybe yeah just
some some rookie two more for now i
would say like to defend on f2 and uh
play on comedy but
yeah i believe maybe
fabiano played this line you know quite
ambitiously do you think he played it
because dude has been struggling and
against somebody else he would have
chosen different styles okay probably
the tournament situation says this yeah
like okay dude has not so much points
and
uh he wasn't doing great especially last
few games but
once again uh
so far
it's uh it's hard to say who is playing
you know which color yeah so like white
is playing for you in a very solid way
yeah well young we uh thank you for
coming to studio great appreciation
performance thus far keep it up and
hopefully see you in the studio again
thank you good luck again thank you
enjoy your rest
well that was ian napoli here joining us
that is your tournament leader here at
the 2022 feeder candidates
yon napomchi he maintains his lead over
that man in the blue shirt on camera
that's foggy under carwana he's trying
to chase down yonda palmashi but as he
glances to the side glances back towards
the board and we heard yon napomshi's
thoughts
he doesn't think that fabian's position
is good at all and
i think that we
almira and fabiano we all agree with
that statement
well we do and now that i think about
this game um i can explain jan's
decision you know maybe he went for this
uh
line and exchanged all the pieces
because it was motivated and dictated by
the tournament position but also by
like
by the position in the game between uh
young sister of duda and fabiana caruana
and he expressed a little bit of
disappointment based on how
it felt like the opening maybe he could
have gone a little bit more about that
but we didn't want to press him on his
preparation we don't have to admit
everything to the world but i mean jan
he's been stable he's been playing
really nicely and the other games are
hectic right like we had one game that
was a pretty peaceful draw and as we
look throughout this bird's eye view
all of these games are just heating up
i don't even my eyes are just running
around okay the one on the lower left
not as much but the rest of the rest of
the games are all incredibly complex we
talked a little bit about the report
ding game where richard's clock
is dwindling and fading and he seems to
be not even close to making a move yet
i'm going to give you the choice i'm i'm
experiencing menu it's like a restaurant
which is 15 items that are all my
favorite foods i don't know which game
we should turn to i i i think we
probably have to go back to the car want
to do game but before we do ali raza
faruja who we just bring up on camera
here he's down to 28 minutes and change
and it's very early in that game and
he's worse almira we've talked about
this numerous times at this event his
time management the clock is his
his mortal enemy
well
this position is very complex and maybe
he doesn't feel it very well so he needs
to spend some more time i know this is
not the
sharp neither flying
it's
it's a very quiet line where sometimes
the game is decided over one square
so maybe we should have a look at this
position quickly
yeah i i think we can uh first glance at
the car want to do the game uh i think
just to
latch on to some of yon's points about
how do this position looking good even
players who are struggling can beat the
players who seem to be in the best form
and it is duda on the clock
he can either now or in the near future
play this h4 move and
danielle mira this is uh looking like
dude is getting closer and closer to his
first win in the candidates
yeah
there's a very interesting detail on
i'll i'll let you go but just one
quick thing after h4 g takes h4 at first
i ruled this out because i thought well
if white takes with the knight then that
gives up the f2 pawn
i think that's still good for roy but
what i would say is that g takes h4 here
is not only not out of the question but
could be simply devastating for black
the rook from u1 it gets to g1 and
all of these weaknesses the e61 the g5
square the fact that black has a very
hard time sustaining control of the
g-file
i'll mirror your knights on show and f3
you were calling for them from the very
beginning understanding what white
needed but it's amazing how just these
two pieces defend the king
well i find more and more amazing the
move king h1
like
so now everything is crystal clear to us
but it
young sister dude i needed to find this
move because
there's a series of king h1 h4 then
that's what i wanted to talk about then
gtx h4 you you you have two
possibilities just to take with the
knight and to take with the bomb
um
i'm very concerned uh with fabi's
position and i think fabiano
is also concerned about his question uh
he's been changing those poses we've
mentioned how that seems to be perhaps a
bit of a tell but he's going to try to
calculate and i guess from his
perspective if jan schuster doesn't play
h4 right now let's say he makes this
rookie 2 move which seems very logical
to defend the second rank then black
finally
you know we're highlighting g4 positives
earlier gets this move in and if we
start swapping pawns at the very least
this white doesn't this white knight
doesn't get the g5 square if it goes to
h4 it's on the rim and maybe not causing
the most problems for black so i think
fabiano
if duda slows down now he finally has
some chances yeah duda needs to sense
the urgency of the moment because in
such situations
it's very important it's very tempting
to get into let me improve my position
mode
and that often drives you to
procrastinate on an idea you think well
let me defend the up coupon first but
when you do that you often don't factor
in
the immediacy of the situation you
underestimate your opponent's ideas
and just procrastinating by one move as
you just indicated allows black to
change the nature of the position to
prevent h4 and to develop serious
counterplay black is still worse after
rookie two but i think you can't even
compare it to the position after h4 i
think h4 wouldn't go so far as to say it
wins but it comes pretty darn close
what a move gtx h4
in most positions you don't capture with
the pawn that's helping to shield your
king
and i guess maybe we should
take a moment here because this plus
three approximately for white
it doesn't necessarily look like a plus
three position looks very good for white
but the players don't think in engine
terms although the next move rook g1
looks pretty obvious so i guess that's
the biggest problem for fabiano is young
chisholm's moves are pretty natural
of course and uh we were talking about
this knight on a5 but the bishop on an
a7 is out of play as well so
young sister is playing with two
powerful knights
and
they are going to launch an attack very
soon you can play knight g5 queen it
took in h5
rook g1 everything is possible yeah all
of white's pieces come into the party
and well the party doesn't stop just
because one game has ended or if this
game ends as well because we have so
many great games look at these right we
have three games still in progress and
all of them are fascinating amir you
mentioned that we should probably look
at the game between hikaru and farouza
it's looking really bad for alerissa and
ah look at hikaru here he's looking at
that board like he smells some blood
he absolutely smells blood i mean
alireza has had the castle king side
alareza has not set any of his king side
pawns in motion he's given up control
complete control of the default hikaru
is totally dominating here
and
really elirez's worst nightmare has come
true when he was taking with the with
the g pawn he understood that this could
happen but he thought that the mobility
of his
central pawn mass is going to prevent
this scenario he did end up pushing d5
but it was completely in effect it was a
shot into thin air ikaro said no problem
i'm just going to take it and i'm not
going to trade queens and thank you very
much for the d file yeah don't trade
queens when you have the safer king so
the car sidesteps the queen trade and
knight to f5
and it's not like
already made any noticeably like
terrible moves or anything it's just
that once he took on f6 it's exactly
amira and donna your reactions these are
static weaknesses and hikaru just
playing nice moves very very logical
play from him so
okay we see that white is better that
much is clearer
but how to
improve your position from this point
it's a very interesting question i i
wanted to come back to the position
first of all when he played d5 to
explain that very often in this position
you want to play f5
but maybe he couldn't make this work
yeah 5 is very interesting i and can i
you're saying if i take the knight takes
on f5 and
this does look at you i guess you still
don't want to take on e3 just like the
position we're analyzing a while ago
because opening up the f file for this
rook sitting on f1 could be a bit of an
issue yes but i want to keep all my
pawns in the center and i want to play
d5
so probably this doesn't work
yeah because even if you play d5
exactly i wouldn't say anything
a square is worth a thousand words
and it's kinky
black lacks development and it just
feels like it's a little bit too slow
compared to some of the ideas in the
sveshnikov so
yeah i guess alariza never really felt
like his feet were on the floor and he
was kind of hanging
in thin air after d5 which is a very
natural move it's a not a bad move but
as we see
no queen trade for you knight f5 is
a very natural square for the knight but
every single move for white improving c4
saves the pawn allows the rook to go to
d5 where you can double so what a
nightmare for alireza
yeah i mean i guess the one consolation
for him to piggyback off of your point
is that it isn't easy it's not like
icaru has a three-move win
but this is i think what makes ikaro so
incredibly terrifying when he gets a
position like this
he has ironclad patience he never rushes
and he loves moves like h2h3 or queen c2
he's not going to do anything drastic he
is going to squeeze the life out of you
and that is why i think he's taking
as much time as he has four minutes and
counting there are many ways for white
to improve his position the car was
trying to choose that most accurate
option the option that's going to limit
black's counter play
and it's going to be part of a larger
strategy
to act like a boa constrictor and
completely squeeze the life out of all
ereza this is trouble
hard to make a move for black it's hard
to say anything
it's like black tradition's just bad
yeah and the one thing that's keeping
alireza with some hopes is like not like
he's a pawn that can be attacked a bunch
of times or there's no way for white to
go crushing an h3 played good call donya
you
are the car whisperer right now
just it's almost like i played him a
couple times make sure the king never
gets background checkmated it's just a
useful move
uh altogether and now he passes the
baton back to all the razor said find a
move find a response and a mirror this
isn't looking very pleasant now we have
delphi's oracle here
no but i i wanted to explain that like i
have the feeling that
h3 is such as strong moves
but i wanted to show for example if you
play knight g2 maybe it allows already a
small counter play with b5 so that's why
you don't need to rush things in this
position
because this rook loses its connection
with the other group no b5
is one of those moves that black needs
to play to feel like he has a chance
wow
such a strong move i don't envy alariza
at all and you never ever ever want to
play this move knight takes e3 and i'll
just show that very quickly here because
knight takes e3
and hikaru's on fire well in this game i
guess but he did lose the previous game
so
go knock and go lots of hikaru fans
coming out in the chat no surprises to
see that he is
focused
he's pretty focused well he's gone
up to the focusing but
knockout for the win
but why don't you want to play this move
because after queen is three if i play
f5 you play a knight h4 rook g6 and then
knight h4 what do how do you continue
yeah even if you don't win a pawn
getting the knight to f5 is just
devastating for the king on g8 so
ministry of repair that's a pretty good
username
um
nice jacket mr chair
not such a unique comment but
i like the username
so queen e4 here
i can even take and go knight h4
the depressing thing for black is that
even in an end game positionally i'm so
dominant that i don't even really need
the queens
what what a bad position for and the
clock and the clock then just compounds
all of the problems they've only made 20
moves yeah it's no increment this is bad
they're not playing blitz and thank you
for that shout out um
that we just showed on screen there so
whoo
this position not fun for ali raza the
other position that we have are looking
very fun some for more one player rather
than both
from caruana he's having a miserable
time yeah look at the top right of your
screen guess what jkd just played he is
determined not to let this game slip no
he found his form at the worst possible
moment for fabiano but for yon chistop
duda he's the world cup champion number
one player from poland wow and as yonder
palms said
every player in this field can be
anybody else no matter their form
it's just nuts how quickly everything
changes
you're like fabi's on top of the field
he's winning games john kristoff due to
losing to everybody boom goes the
dynamite 15 moves you feel like dude is
on top of the world he's playing amazing
that's what makes the candidate so
fascinating i keep coming back to this
anybody in the field can beat anybody
else you never know what's going to
happen on the basis of the previous
round
i have no idea what's going to happen
this
richard report dingley run game i mean
report is approaching time trouble but
that position is just
mesmerizing scary
it's like a horror movie and like
really beautiful piece of art at the
same time so i i don't even know what to
say about it but
we
will get back to that game for sure
we'll get back and break we'll go to
that game unless something major happens
but for now we do need to take a break
uh this has been a really fun round to
this point and what else is fun is a
certain event called the i am not a gm
speed chess championship we see the
finalists are eric rosen and james canty
the third that's gm canty to you out
there oh no my move will eric rosen a
fan favorite take down the razor sharp
james canty
who knows all i know is you will want to
tune in thursday july 7th at 10 30 a.m
pacific right here on chess.com we're
going to take a quick break we'll return
it is round 10 of the phoenix candidates
2022. this is chess.com coverage live
from madrid
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less actor than them in every stage
yeah and that that stings a little bit
okay do the more game review okay yeah
thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks i
gotta stop playing cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
you'll probably need to work on these
ones yep every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's crap
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pets
rook there for rookie too
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
the feed a candidate is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger yon napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss
ali reza faruja won the grand swiss
turned the heads of everyone in doing so
and has become the youngest player in
history to cross the 2800 evo rating
barrier he would become the youngest
world chess champion of all time should
he win the candidates and ultimately the
world chess championship match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlson
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikara nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard rapport the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fidei awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master tamor
rajaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one
punched his ticket by ousting none other
than world champion magnus carlson in
the semi-finals of that event
judah would ultimately defeat karjakin
in the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grandmaster dingley
rent
dingley ren takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 feed a rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
want to play us online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess like
continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 spain's capital
place host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
and he definitely knows
we were worried that he overthought the
advantage
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in world chess
championship
the candidates is grueling prince
and unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
that's actually got to be super
intimidating if you're playing a car
when he puts on the code
and others from the next wave of stars
yielding to those before them
[Music]
miss amigos
the next challenger for the world
champion you know
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
and what a legacy this man already has
and he wants to add to that that is
fabiano caruana he faced off against
magnus carlson in the 2018 world chess
championship but his hopes and reaching
another world championship
they're in the balance right now amira
it's not looking good for fabiano well i
think that young sister dude has him on
the ropes in his game
chances are chattered probably right now
so he played bishop c5 that's the way to
bring his bishop into play and into
defense but also he has the possibility
of playing eight xb5 xb5 b6 and then
maybe knight b7 knight d6 but
once again uh you don't have time for it
in this position
yeah what we're talking about is
bringing this knight on a5 please let it
get to somewhere like d6 that would be
the dream come true but it takes so much
time and
five minutes he's
darting away from the board but dania
this rook is darting to g1 and that's
going to spell trouble for caruana
yeah i mean quite simply again we've got
that 995. fabiano has so many weaknesses
scattered across the board that he
simply does not have the firepower
literally does not have the horsepower
because the horse is
away in siberia as we've been discussing
after rochi won
an illustration of the extent of his
problems let's say he goes rook f
to f7 in order to try to
maintain control over the g7 square that
knight from f3 jumps into g5 you say no
problem i'm gonna go rookie seven defend
the e6 pawn rook d8 and that's basically
track mate that's how quickly things are
going to go down the drain for black so
the situation is dire as lumira said
white is winning
and with precise technique
i think jkd should be able to
drive home the full point within five
ten moves
yeah it's just an awful position for
fabiano without any hope of complicating
matters normally if you're getting
attacked you hope to throw
well danny's not here but you could
throw a wrench in somebody's plans and
it's just an unfortunate situation for
fabiano who after
the first half of the tournament
he just he hasn't been himself right he
lost to hikaru he drew the game against
yan which was maybe his biggest chance
and then in this game against a
determined yan chistop
he may be giving the polish player his
first victory of the tournament
well i think that fabiano is also
getting very tired because his plane
style also has this drawback you know he
is calculating a lot you know so
it's
at some point it will backfire
yeah
and i'd add one more thing which is that
this game is doubly disappointing for
him because you pointed out he's an
italian expert for both colors
this is his opening
this is an area where he feels
tremendously comfortable and has for
many many years
and for him to get outplayed in a
fashion this one-sided
is going to hurt tremendously
obviously not as much as
his place in the standings is going to
hurt but
this is a sign that fabi is
in your own words not himself
and some problems for fabiano is you
know you asked jan
the storyline has been will magnus play
the winner of the candidates if not
alireza frusia it doesn't look like
alireza is going to be the winner so
first place is extremely important for
obvious reasons
second place has had an increased
importance which hasn't been the case in
previous canon cycles
so if fabi loses and ikara wins and ding
wins
all of a sudden we have a three-way tie
for second place and that's going to be
the first time that fabiano has had
anyone
tied within the standings for i don't
even know how many rounds
oh so this it means that the tournament
is still very open
and all of the players have a chance at
the match
in the first the first half
yeah a special kind of match which uh
i don't think you know anybody really
wants everyone wants to see magnus
carlsen play but if we take him at his
word as we've discussed in previous days
then second place will play first place
here in the candidates for a world
championship match well i remember like
if there are a few historical examples
but still like uh the candidate who won
the tournament they didn't have a chance
to play the match it was for some
reasons like world war ii you know
these were very difficult uh situations
so
could be for the first time i think that
the
king abdicates
yeah it's uh
i always creates
chaos in the event and no player creates
more chaos and richard report i would
say and while he may not be looking at
second place and you know he he's if he
wins he will be still in the running for
that second place and i mean report
this guy is such an electric player
it doesn't always have to go his way but
it's always fun to look at his game so
we can bring up this game quickly we'll
keep an eye on the caruana dude game as
well as the game between nakamura and
ferrugia but this one i mean how could
we not
dive in because there's a king still on
e8 it looks like white has all these
pieces going after the king is black's
turn
what a mess
i'm tongue-tied i mean
i would point out you know in such
positions
i think
the the main contribution to a human can
just be to make some observations and
and perhaps those observations will help
people make make sense of how the game
continues so what do i see
first of all the king on h1 it isn't as
safe as it appears because that bishop
on a7 is blocking its escape square so
you could conceive of a future where a
queen for example appears on h56 to h5
it's still not made there's a bishop on
f6 which would block but
it's something that you should always
keep in mind any mating ideas the bishop
on d5 can be captured i think a lot of
people might look at it and say wait a
minute i don't get it knight takes d5 ed
queen takes d5 i've won upon but that
doesn't tell the whole story anytime you
have a pawn capture which files open up
the e file opens up and the e4 square
frees up for white's knight knight e4
here very dangerous possibility of a
knight appearing on f6 it's anybody's
game so i think it's in ding's best
interest to actually keep the bishop
alive on d5 as annoying as it is and to
try his best to somehow coordinate his
species maybe trade that bishop off but
not with knight takes d5 but rather with
bishop c8 to e6
and then maybe knight g6 and rook f7 so
black is close to consolidating can
report keep
the flames of his fire burning and time
on his clock
well if i wouldn't have an account i
would create it today you know just to
hear danny so i agree
but
i did create my twitch account yeah your
hb yes
mirror the hb
you solved the mystery so
almira this position donnie was just
saying how knight takes d5 so many
people look for material but it's
probably more important than to leave
the e4
pawn there so the knight can't get to e4
so
it's very important to keep this knight
out of play
so i i
wasn't looking at knight d5 so i i like
your move
bishop e6 or
maybe knight g6
[Music]
two possible moves here yeah knight g6
is pretty interesting keeps e5 defended
bishop e6 can happen next and if you're
not careful also rook f7 to follow once
we get rid of this
really annoying and strong bishop on d5
but while
dingley wren he sits oh
okay don't move yet don't move dingly
red because i want to send dania to the
telestrator because richard report we
know how exciting his chess is there's a
game from a bundesliga many years back
at this point but what a game that was
well amir and i were discussing this
before the show started richard report
has made a lot of fans at this
tournament and for very good reason
and he didn't acquire the playing style
that he has yesterday he's had it for
many years
this game is from 2014 elmira was hoping
for a king's gambit and not without
grounds because in 2014 against the
german grand master i just want to show
you the first couple of moves of this
ridiculous game that can only be played
by richard report with the white pieces
he plays the king's gambit
but that's not enough because after
black accepts it the standard move is
knight f3 standard is not in richard
reports dictionary and he plays the old
move knight c3 that's the vienna defense
it's almost never been played in a
hundred years his opponent responds with
a check on h4 how crazy do you have to
be to have a king on e2 by move four
of the
opening well it gets crazier his
opponent blasts open the diagonal with
d5
report takes it allowing a check on g4
but white's knight comes out to f3 now
his opponent not to be outdone
sacrifices his rook with knight c6 this
is only move six richard report is upper
rook he's got a king on e2
and just a couple more moves here to
fully indicate how ridiculous this is if
black had given a check on d4 the king
would have been out on d3 and white is
actually winning so black correctly
plays knight e5
um
or after knight takes c7 check
yeah king d8 knight takes the eight this
is all correct 95 queen e1 by richard
report offering a queen trade and
finally after knight takes f3
white trades queens
richard report somehow stays alive with
king e1 and you get this ridiculous
position black eventually won the knight
on a8 but richard used his central pawns
he played d4 he took the pawn and f4 and
he actually won the game so this is but
a small illustration of who richard
report is as a chess player and who he
has been as a chess player for many many
years
wow what a game that was an opening and
i'm somewhat glad that that didn't
happen today because
every new player every student of the
game watching that would say whoa coach
i want to do that that looks fun and the
coach is like no your king is going to
be castled it's going to be safe but
amir you picked out the game
wow wow wow well and actually we
discussed it with dinah and oh he told
me that he made an extensive analysis of
this position by the way so i'm looking
forward to this course you know on the
king's canvas yeah i made a youtube
video uh on the king's gambit for black
and you know i was trying to cover
everything and when i was covering
knight c3 i actually had this very same
position in my analysis
where report's opponent went wrong but
it wasn't a coincidence that you went
wrong richard report constantly gets
these positions where you basically have
to play insane computer moves in order
to stay alive and this position isn't
too far removed from the kinds of
positions richard has been getting for
decades now and there's a reason why
ding has spent 26 minutes pondering his
choice exactly he does not look calm he
can't become nobody can when your
opponent is richard report and we talked
about some ideas like bishop to e6 or
knight to g6 we do not want to vacate
the e4 square by taking on d5 allowing
the knight to hop forward there's a king
on e8 but as donya pointed out this
queen at some point would like to get to
a square like h5 that king on h1 could
fall victim to a mating attack as well
so
ding looked up at report i wasn't quite
expecting that but let's uh take a
moment to gather ourselves after
such shocking tactics and see what's
happening oh my gosh the eval bars on
the right side of the screen are getting
sky high for both duda and nakamura
which game shall we jump into first well
we kind of know what's going on in the
duda game
but hikaru is actually sacrificed in
exchange
and it appears
that this sacrifice is going to lead
to black swift death what's happening
here well hikaru was thinking how to
follow it up but if we just go back h3
was played almirah was clamoring for
this idea b5
c5 was hikara's choice but that leaves
this rook
a little bit vulnerable because if these
rooks get disconnected from one another
then the rook on d5 will fall which is
what eventually happened in the game now
the move played was bishop f8 the engine
didn't love that to show the kind of
understanding and restraint by a5 that i
mean
wow wanna move the point is that c5
becomes a quick target when you can play
bishop f8 and finally knight takes e3 so
a5 was an opportunity for alireza even
though the position remained bad but as
we speed up here look at this move
knight d4 and hikaru literally doesn't
care about the rook on d5 he literally
does not and he plays knight takes d4
and that knight from d4 very likely
to go to f5
elmira is that a reasonable assumption
that he's going to put that on an f5
well i would start with queen g4 first
because after knight f5 you
still have the possibility of playing
queen e4
maybe doesn't lose on the spot
i would start with queen g4 knight f5
and then um
there he goes
trying to get this knight into f5 as
amir said you don't allow the queen to
e4 in this variation the queen can go to
c4 i think black would desperately try
to get a queen trade but the attack rage
is on we're not going to trade queens as
white that's for sure i think he played
knight f5
straight away
okay
so he doesn't care about queen e4
literally
i guess he wants queen h5 aha in
response to that
gosh this looks terrible for black
yeah because the attack just rages on
queen h5
yeah you want to make this work and the
one thing that white needs to do is not
trade pieces when you're down material
you often don't want to trade and also
that could give black access to the
first rank and start a counter attack
against the white king because the
bishop on f8 does take care of the
checkmating square so i think this rook
you can trade and probably still have an
advantage but you may also be able just
to slide to an open file and go after
another
target god
rookie three another idea that's on the
docket and eventual rook clips i think
the key thing for people to understand
here robert the elmira is that
black or white is not in a big hurry
right when you're down material a lot of
people assume i got to do something now
black cannot dislodge that knight from
f5 he can't dislodge the queen from h5
everything is stuck in mud and hikaru
actually has three or four tempe to get
stuff going on the king's side
very good point no rush here because
black has no actual threats no real
ideas and alireza we know how good he is
but elmira it's looking like a position
where it's almost hopeless
well you're absolutely right and that's
why
we have to
have a look at the position which
happened
right before the
exchange sacrifice and you were
pointing out this move a5
i think which is
right here a5 which is probably black's
best chance in this position
yep isolating that c5 on preventing b4
but you can understand why alireza went
for the material like at least now he
can suffer for something
but
or as yasser's friend like to say at
least he's going to die with a full
stomach right
yes he got some material for it but a5
wow what a clever idea that would have
been it does allow black to stay in the
game because you prevent white from
getting
connected pawns and
a pawn's best friend is another pawn
this pawn on c5 is
going off to college so his high school
best friend is left behind and this
gives some chances here for black to go
after it it's a really difficult move to
play especially without much time on the
clock and we see that
alariza down to 16 minutes
and counting down so yeah this is a
problem for him and the game is
obviously no easier
well i understand why he played knight
d4 because when you're so low on time
you want to go for
a concrete line you know
you can make a few moves you know and to
transpose to a different position but
here
simply doesn't work
very straightforward for hikaru
his position looks amazing he's got a
great knight in f5
as we venture back towards our bird's
eye view we see that
yonshits of duda i don't know whose
knight is better hikarus or young
chistos because the knight on g5
looks every bit as good as a car is not
an f5
i mean it looks like
only a few more accurate moves are
required
for jkd to put the finishing touches he
looks like he's about to make a move
is he going to grab on e6 or is he going
to improve his position
i know both those games have you know
huge advantages if not winning positions
for white but i i can't take my eyes off
the left side of the screen
now dingley rents king is on d7 oh my
gosh i mean that game is so fun but five
minute carwana will bring his game up he
is i think knight takes c6 no no no he's
not having any fun here but i mean
his knockout still isn't quite here yet
ah you need to bring the other rook to
the g file rug d3 and right dg3
oh
you're being a bully over here can you
start with the rook g3 i believe you can
it's like you can get the salad before
the main course you can get it with the
main course and either way
the attack is totally overwhelming i
know you're a dessert guy first you're
eating those gummy bears before the show
i'm not do you eat gummy bears before
lunch is not dessert
that's gummy bears just a snack yeah but
gummy bears isn't really a candy
amira
i i don't want to be the judge
[Laughter]
all right well either and chat are
probably going crazy right now rook g3
is
a very good move just double the brooks
and this h5 pawn will remain at target
so this queen will need to stay tethered
to that pawn otherwise the king on h8
will get mated
just know how it works then you will
throw in a peel you know so i have to
have a ruler
i'm just asking i mean what you thought
gummy bears would you let your kids have
that before eating a meal
no i wouldn't
i wouldn't i might get some
meal but
you know as a commentator i am allowed
certain certain privileges
well there's nothing sweet in this
position for fabiano
he's looking at yanchez up and young
and
he's played a great game and
something i was thinking about was if
duda
had won the opening game of the
tournament when he had a
huge
advantage against richard report it
would have been a very different event
for him most likely he had a great
position after seven or ten moves in the
opening because report didn't handle it
very well so
if he had
just nursed that advantage or actually
maximized his chance in that game we
probably wouldn't be looking at duda in
last place with a win after nine rounds
i think we would have seen a very
different jan schistov
yeah
i completely agree with that and i'll
i'll pass it to you but
to that point i just also want to tack
on the fact
that i think chess fans tend to think of
things very deterministically
um they think okay
if this is how duda did that mean he's
in bad form that means in any other
alternate reality he also would have
done badly i think you're
pushing back on that assumption and i
completely agree a lot of times
things don't always come down to chance
yes form plays a role but a big part of
it really is that first round maybe even
one moment in that first round and had
that one moment gone differently had
ding capitalized on a slightly better
position against nepo in round one we
might be talking about a completely
different tournament there
so
elmira you do you agree with that way of
thinking as well
i do agree with that and i also think
that it's a very different game like
when you ask yourself questions should
have could have you know like as a chess
player when you analyze uh your games
later on the like why did they do this
why did they do that you know but
you were
taking these decisions under enormous
pressure so
and for players often one win sets them
in motion and
none of the magnus carlsen there have
been events where he's drawn the first
four games in in tata steel in vikanze
and then he gets that first win and then
he goes like six out of seven in the
next bunch of games magnus on the
decline he's not winning any more
tournaments all he does is draw games
but you know for players who have a very
fighting style someone like young chiso
often all it takes is one win
and then he feels like all right i got
that victory now i am a little freer i
don't have to sit here thinking when am
i ever going to win to this point in the
tournament that's probably been weighing
on him but he's the only player now who
hasn't won a game and he picked a
terrible time for fabiano but a great
time for himself
it was also true for there is a fusion
you know he needed this win he needed
desperately to win a game
but
it came too late you know
absolutely excuse me and he is taking
his time in this position very patient
he's got 25 minutes plenty of time he
realizes of course how close he is to
winning this game
i think the fact that this is his first
win or potentially his first win
adds to his anxiety level maybe making
him take a little bit more time than he
normally would but i am fully expecting
rook g3
or rook d3 in the next
minute or two he brings the other rook
to g1
and the problem is that if black screen
moves away from g6 then there's going to
be all sorts of tactics starting with a
sack on e6
and ending with
a deflection check
on f7 and all this time
black's knight has remained on a5 a
passive spectator and now the bishop is
a passive spectator
as well
that night on a5 wow i mean what can be
said about it that hasn't already been
said
it just never has been in the game ever
since he got there
it never had a chance
that's how difficult it took well to
come back from siberia
no flights i've been to hunting says
twice and i made it back but yeah that
was quite a trek
[Laughter]
well yan chistop here
he's at the board
focusing it's his turn he knows
that the end is near if he plays as
accurately he also has plenty of time so
let's
maybe take a step back we've talked
about his tournament to this stage and
it hasn't been going well for him it has
been going well for hikar nakamura in
this game but i mean there's a king on
d7 right there's a that king on d7 in
dingley ren's position
my eyes are just it's like a magnet you
know it's like i can't help you you
can't take your eyes off that game
what a game between these two and that's
the great part of having richard report
and dingley running the tournament is
you know that they're always going to
fight dingley ran a couple rounds so he
kind of had to make a quick draw because
he had the black pieces against yonda
pamashi but if given the choice he will
always play on
yeah absolutely i mean i think you could
sense
his disappointment when jan was going
for that charge line i think i could
just
sense the chagrin that thing felt
because there was nothing he could do
and he wanted to fight white pieces
black pieces
he's an incredibly objective player he
is a fighter
and he doesn't let a string of bad
results get to him notice that he lost
the first game he had all those
disappointing games where he missed wins
it has not impacted his play in the
lease and i think we should give him a
lot of credit for not letting these
disappointing results get to him and
affect the objectivity of his play
robert daniel what do you think
is he aiming for
kingston six king b6 king a7
something dead dangerous
if given the time and look at his little
chair i always like that he's the only
one who has decided that he doesn't want
those really tall chairs but almirah
just mentioned king c6
king b6 and even king to a7 to find some
safety and
that could be a future for that king
maybe the king is safe on d7 but
it feels
well
a bit vulnerable there as well so
i can play queenie two king g4
immediately because the bishop is
hanging on on f6 so
should i start with
ah bishop move
like bishop bishop h4
[Music]
that's interesting that also clears the
path for the queen to potentially go to
episode but then you can go kingston
yeah where do we are
as soon as you made your move i was i
had it ready i didn't care what movie
you said that you didn't you know
wouldn't have blundered anything with
king c6 i'm going here it's a good move
it is
when i suggested it i saw that it was
completely crazy
it only takes two moves though that's
the thing
uh robert yes
i would like to draw your attention to
the monitor you think i ever listened to
the chat polls that say eight like gummy
bears eighty percent of people said it's
a snack i knew everybody would have said
it's a health food it is
what i mean you do need sugar to survive
i don't know what kind of gummy bears
the chat has been eating but it's the
type that makes them think like that
that's what it seems like oh i wonder
what kind of gummy bears those are
goodness well i disagree with that and
gosh of course they saw with dania
always the case thank you chad i knew
you'd have my back
oh i'll mirror i guess you know we'll
have to be the adults in the room
well don't count on me
ramirez abstaining from this discussion
she's uh wisely he's trying to corrupt
me oh i know i can i know what kind of
devious tricks this guy's up to but what
kind of devious tricks is
knight c4 sacrificing a knight the pawn
can just simply capture it but the point
is that once this d-pawn captures in
response there is an open d-file the
king id7 is not happy
oh my only report can play such a move
what a move okay we need to analyze this
a bit because right there's a knight
that's hanging here so b takes d takes
and next move for white is c5 because i
want to move your queen away so i can
play bishop takes e5 exploding the fact
that this bishop will be pinned oh my
goodness
i would also add that bishop a4 check is
now a very serious possibility as a
consequence of the b5 pun moving away
report without hesitation
taking the knight
yeah ding takes it and we are into we're
back barn burner here oh my gosh what a
position this is like
what does black even do here
let me be king cc now gang c65 right
that palm push is gonna be devastating
you might have to give up some material
here
to stave off
the i mean c5 is a massive threat oh but
i see what you think so rook c6 okay
prevents c5 because his bishop is under
attack
and bishop a4 will win this rook but
considering the fact that black took a
piece for merely one pawn if you do in
fact take that rook when my king was out
the way after bishop takes c6 maybe
knight takes um c6 and if we look at the
material count it's two minor pieces for
rook and pawn and neither king is safe
and after white plays p5 the king will
be even more unsafe oh my gosh
and then c5
what an idea this is awesome chess yeah
try can you show this line b5 knight a5
black should take i think a b because if
knight a5 there's c5
that pawn is poisonous
this way and that way because of the pin
on the c file and the d file
and it is anybody's game here
i think both players
deserve a ton of credit but only one
player can win if there's a decisive
result almira i mean
this is a spectacle
well
i'm out of words because i'm trying to
calculate the lines and
this is total chaos
well report
is the agent of chaos he's a much kinder
soul than the joker but the type of
chess he plays just throws people into
a situation where they will never quite
feel comfortable so
rook c6 might be the
production team wow they had that ready
yeah that
came out the second you said joker
it's not the first time i've
made that
connection but wow that is also it the
the joke where's this kind of yeah i
could see right you could wear that
outfit uh anton squared me thank you to
anton square me who always produces
great content and this tweet that lives
up to the reputation so oh my gosh i'm
just mesmerized by that
oh gosh not even the batman can save you
from
the report joker so
more i look at this position i get the
feeling that
rook says six is not an easy move to
find
what are what are the options here
are there any other appealing
alternatives i guess is the question
um
so c5 is the threat then you want to
take on e7 and play bishop d5 is that
the concrete line where is your king
going
because the bishop takes e5 will also
fight between i mean if you go to e8
then c5 bishop e5 and queen f7 is mate
i'll show that yes let's c5 if you move
your queen to say c6
after bishop takes e5 you can't afford
to take back because queen of seven is
check and mate
ouch
so you can't go there you can't go to c6
you can't make a king move
and you can't make a queen move because
that only exacerbates
bishop takes c5
great
feature tweet here uh featured chat i
should say fortunate nate says some
people just want to watch the board burn
that's awesome
great joker reference and report i mean
knights can we just go back and just do
an instant replay
knight c4 are you kidding me rook c6
played by the way ding remaining on top
but no it move is incredible
this game is just
super exciting and actually if i i don't
want to leave this game especially with
reports such time travel it just moved
34 report down to eight minutes and it's
wildly complex but if we take a step
back we zoom out for a moment here
fabiano caruana still fighting alireza
furus are also fighting and
you know both of those players could
lose couldn't have their
game end at any moment but
they're trying their best wait a minute
oh no no no i thought there was a
cool tactic in the fabia game but it
doesn't quite work
in the hikaru game over on the bottom
right he's played as bishop from e3 to
h6 trying to eliminate the only defender
of black's king
look at that body language
he's put his suit on or has he no no
he's not he's not inside sure
it is his blazer whatever it's called
but look at him he's like slumped over
i'll bring that game up here
on the
screen and this king on jit amira
the rook did come to a1
this brings more firepower to the attack
oh you're absolutely right you know
honestly this game wasn't i mean after g
takes f6 it wasn't even close
it was
totally one-sided
and i think maybe
um uh already wanted to win too badly
could you make that argument that he
came in today wanting to beat hikaru he
was at that moment he could have played
queen takes f6 and probably
solved the opening without too many
problems but instead he
chose a path that simply got into
trouble
yeah i i remember discussion a couple
years ago with my good friend vladimir
putin both of us have been playing carl
a lot on online blitz we're trying to
strategize you know which openings tend
to be more successful which less
and he said a very profound phrase he
said
the caro is extremely good at punishing
uh bad pawn structures if you actually
look at hikaru structures they're always
healthy look at his pawn structure b4 c5
pawn chain
one pawn island on the king side look at
black's pawn structure
so g takes f6 i completely agree with
you robert i think he tried to force it
i think he he sensed an opportunity to
unbalance the position
he knew that hikara wasn't feeling too
comfortable because he'd just taken 45
minutes
and instead of playing the position
he
overcooked it he overdid it and he car
still has to win but i think rook a3
basically finishes the game and i'll
risk it down to four minutes and 16
seconds for now 12 moves remaining
yeah for him and as we look at the time
patrol you get an extra hour after the
40th move it's only
white's 28th move right now so a
really big
difficulties ahead for rizza on the
board on the clock and as don just
saying he's calling it it's over with
this rook coming to g3 and that means
this king is
it's gonna be checkmated right this is
just taking advantage of the fact that
there are no defenders over here there
isn't a single i mean there is a check
on b1 or e1 but king h2 and that's it
alireza might simply resign here
geez look at the car he he's like this
game he's waiting for all there is to
resign he's saying we both know it's
over
that's why i was thinking that maybe
like the pandemics created a very
different species you know the chess
players were playing so many online
scheme and they were mostly rapid and
blitz so you're
the way they are taking decisions now
are profoundly altered you know so this
seems like a move which would make in a
blitz game gta x6
but in a classical game
white have more than enough time in
order to find well
what is the best positional approach
and
all of the
you know illustrious players from the
zurich 1953 tournament i don't think a
single one would play g takes f6 it's a
very different brand of chess as you're
saying and for alireza fruga he's going
to regret that move because he could
have played queen takes and it would
have been fine he would have been up on
time and it's not like after queen takes
f6 the game ended in a draw yeah it was
an equal position but it was still full
of life
maybe there was something there he
didn't like but
this is going to be discussed
and rediscussed for a long time after
this game because that really was the
decision
after which everything started going
downhill
yeah went downhill very fast
and
it's in some ways a bit similar to the
game between
duda and carwana where
i mean for five minute carwana he barely
got at the opening it felt like and for
already frugia his opening was fine
right like the
the general principles were followed and
then he stopped following them for one
move and now his king on h8 is
just devastated
two minutes for 12 moves
those rooks are completely useless
totally impotent
you cannot play rook d3 because the
bishop on the f8 is hanging so you
cannot exchange like
a pair of rooks to
to survive a few more moves i'll show
one quick variation i know alireza is
still trying to figure this out but
there's a reason why he's using all of
his time and he might just resign in a
couple turns because if he tries to
bring his rook back to c7 right this f7
pawn's under attack after rook g3 and
interpret queen c6 let me just defend
all possible weak squares
there is a very forcing checkmate i can
play rook g8 check actually which is
super awesome
g7 wow i can also just play queen g4
right away which threatens queen g8 mate
and if you trade i have queen g7 and
queen g8 is checkmate threats and you
just can't stop it
goodbye and alireza as we're speaking is
down to one minute even if he wasn't
lost he literally wouldn't have been
able to make all of the moves in this
time control
so he might resign simply in this
position
yeah he knows it's over and he can look
across at hikaru who's just
thinking about his next stream perhaps
or where to go for dinner and what to
order paella gazpacho
lots of great spanish food here alireza
has taken the bishop no one before
okay rogue g3 this rook just comes right
over here to g3 this pawn's hanging
there isn't
too much
that needs to be talked about at this
point it's uh hikara letting his move to
the talking mm-hmm and he's not gonna
wait he's not gonna torture early reza
for very long he's gonna play pretty
quickly here i think
apparently it's made in nine we're being
told i would have thought it was sooner
i guess to delay the mate at some point
black will throw in like a rook d one
check and a rook h1 check or whatever
but
yeah at this point it's just
over and it kara nakamura what a game by
him he played title tuesday yesterday
that he streamed that's how he
used his rest day and it's a great
effect the work never stops
and after a painful painful loss against
timur with the black piece is a game
that he really was hoping not to lose to
bounce back like this is the sign of
someone who is supremely confident in
himself
and really is the sign of a fighter
and i just want to know that speaking of
fighting you know
not on screen right now but fabinho
caruana is still fighting alaris is down
in his final second so we will let this
game come to its conclusion i mean carl
may spend a bit of time but he's gonna
bring that rook over swing it to g3 but
fabiano he's still in this game
wow
that's honestly hard to believe but
we're looking at
some of the boards here we're looking at
our bird's eye view caruana game is up
in the top right
but the four minutes robert amira
coupled with the three pieces on the
g-file it still looks really really bad
yeah that night trying to get back into
the game but okay hikaru nakamura bottom
right here trades bishops queen h6 g3
yeah he's
queen h6 rook g3 to follow and the
problem for black
is that you just don't have pieces to
defend your king so we can show just
really quickly here after queen h6 and
there it is actually we're not going to
show it we'll let it
do it he doesn't need us
he
doesn't mean to look at the board
yeah ali reza
i mean he can give a totally meaningless
check on e1
and then one more if he wants it but
there's the finishing touch with rook g3
and black actually takes on c5 with
check but even that doesn't help white
simply plays king h2
wow
25 seconds
will ferruja even make another move
that's
the question that we have to ask now but
he is about to lose on time he's at the
lose on the board his king is getting
checked made just like has happened
against yonder palmache
yeah he is not going to make another
move
no he is i apologize
okay well he made it with just a couple
seconds on the clock and he immediately
resigns hikaru nakamura
in just his second classical game ever
against alareza frugia he says the old
guard is not to be denied this the
future is bright for alireza but today
is not his day
not even close
it really wasn't even close
what a performance by hikaru a good
opening choice great time management
positional play the exchange sacrifice
this had all the ingredients
of a lovely game
all the ingredients of the in the
phoenix school i would say you know
and
whoa let's get back to yes to those
games i mean first of all the the
dingley red report game just zeroes on
the evo bar that oh the c5 thing happens
report only is two minutes and caruana's
two minutes 46 seconds for caruana he
has made 34 moves and for report he has
made
39 so that one's about to reach time
control so they will get into a think
but we have to stay on this game between
the player in second place and look at
the eval bar oh my god yeah you know
it's lifting some weights how would
unfortunately get all of his pieces to
the kingdom and he played elmira's move
b6 so he's finally ready
he finally found a flight out of siberia
to new york gosh
well i wouldn't call it new york yet but
at least b7 is the start of civilization
amira
i mean for duda how nervous do you think
he is right now
well he
should be rather nervous because he has
to find a way to um
[Music]
to conclude you know so
but it's i'm looking for
a move like rook f3 because i need to
exchange something here
and to bring the knight from h to maybe
a rook f3 and knight
hf3
just to bring this knight yes bring this
knight into play but on the other hand
and also like
to protect my rook on g1 and to attack
the e6 pawn at the same time sort of a
combination of ideas
the problem is that i can sort of call
your block
and i could go to ip7 here i could say
alright you know what
take my pawn play queen takes e6
i'll trade queens and
if you showed caruana this end game
compared to what he had about seven
moves ago he would have embraced this
with openers give me this please
yeah to get here
to survive the game long enough to be in
a pawn down end game and by the way
let's look at what that pawn is it's on
f2 which seems very hard to push with
the bishop and pawn lined up and these
queen side pawns may become vulnerable
later so jan chester duda he has made
the move rook one to g2
a very mysterious move
what's the point of it
rook one g2
maybe it's to get to time control
but dude is the one with 10 minutes and
fatherhood brings his knight i think
back to b7
wait a minute does he have something
crazy here
because i was thinking can he take on
the e6 and then because of rook g3 rogue
g wonder well or check all checks so
but um well this is certainly not the
line but
well
97
oh my god oh my god that was the idea
after rook takes g3 he takes on f6
and that's why he brought the rook to g2
that is holy
this because now the queen's inject and
as you said the rooks on g2 can't be
captured on g1 it's a rook h3 it's rook
g8
check mate so it would be even material
but mate that ends the game and oh my
gosh knight
and if you take with a queen then
obviously there's rook takes g7
so you have to go rook f
g6
oh goodness and that actually keeps
black in the game very much so this is
kind of what white wants is that we
could keep trading rooks but i can just
bring my knight back e6 at target queen
f3 in the near future which also
threatens knight f7 i might add so it's
not going to be that simple for fabiano
but we can see that
the evo bar
i mean it was higher in the past oh it
was much higher fabiano is in as good of
shape as he's been in the last 15 moves
really if he can hold this down get to
mu 40 he's going to have realistic
drawing chances all that he achieved a
young sister is an exchange of rooks
which i wanted to do with the book of
three right the knight h7 was such a
spectacular move
especially in the time travel you know
here he was trying to stun fabiano well
knight h7 you don't get to see that move
very often when it can be captured by
three different black pieces but it
wasn't actually
on pre because there's too much pressure
down the g file so
that was a cool move by duda but it's
funny you make this tactic you think i'm
going to win your opponent responds and
now you're thinking and you're like uh
what did that really accomplish so i
wonder if duda is a bit upset that he
played such a cool move and hasn't paid
dividends there was he looked away
he needs to be careful because if he
tries too hard to win and let's say he
moves his knight back to g5 and in comes
the black knight to c5 we're not just
talking about five or saving the game
there's so much going on the position
that if duda doesn't get his head on
right he could even lose this game
and again the body language right i
don't usually love talking about but
we'll do it specifically he's shaking
his head he's doing that thing again and
he
has to make sure not to fall into here
we go again mode here we go again
another another position that i screwed
up and when you start negatively self
talking like that you know what happens
next robert you make more mistakes he's
still much better he has to keep his
composure these next four moves until
time control are critical oh he looks so
upset a mirror like as we look at his
face here it's kind of red and he's just
shaking his head
what do you think can he still get it
done well he just realized that he has
nothing more than
well trained in the rooks in this
position so he has to play rook g6 i
think rook g6 and then knight g5 back
right just bring the knight back here
is it hard to admit that of course it's
it's one of the hardest thing in chess
then you made a mistake or like you have
to go back uh one uh thing that comes to
mind that you have the f3 square for
your queen so after trading your rooks
playing knight g5 you will have the
possibility to play queen f3
and to attack the h5 pawn
yeah that would be really nice so just
to show that the rook on g3 is actually
blocking in that white queen on h3 so
bring the knight back because now it's
going to be captured and next move queen
f3 becomes available so for black you
need to figure out how to deal with that
you probably are gonna have to bring
your queen to something like e8 so that
when the queen in fact does come to f3
you can go rook to g7 covering f7
covering h5 and it's just amazing how
fabiano has coordinated his pieces to
miraculously cover every
it's crazy although there is this idea
of knight f1 knight g3 which at least
visually looks really really nasty
and
i guess after knight f1 black can
attempt bishop
e7 maybe
it really is crazy that black is
holding everything down it looks like
there has to be some sort of a tactic
there has to be a capture of some sort
but
he's making it happen there's just so
many threats in this position and fabi
has uh
well less than two minutes on his clock
so
i'm afraid that duda might go knight g5
i think so too and one of the reasons
you played knight g5 is we see that this
move
37 is on the clock for white it's only
36 moves played is knight g5 it doesn't
trade pieces because fabinho doesn't
have much time and so you may think i'll
play knight g5 that way you don't have
the easy response to get closer to move
40. but knight g5 then this knight comes
into c5 and
as we were saying just a moment ago like
this could be a position where 59 not
just stabilizes but could think about
playing for more
this could be a turning point the game
he did
trade rooks
now the big question is is he gonna go
knight g5 now
i think he is
and knight f6 here
is that
i just move my queen to f7 i guess i
take g6 i take e6 and i have no threats
there
i think i guess that's the point and
just to show that queen of seven but
that is tempting though he's doing it
no i think he went knight g5
did he yeah okay but i was just showing
or did he wait queen takes e6 he did he
did apparently this is completely level
i mean what a situation this would but
you're right he went knight to g5
instead and the knight now is nicely
protected rather than a weird swelling
f6 and five minute goes rook f6
okay he wants his rook coming down to f4
okay
that's a reasonable move and knight c5 i
think is next
and there is no immediate discovery
right that's critical if the e4 pawn
wasn't there there would be 94
but as it stands tonight has absolutely
no prospect other than to remain on g5
and everyone should remain glued to
their computers their phones you should
be watching this because it's about to
be move 40 but the players in time
treble and we'll also have hikaru after
the time patrol so you will certainly
not want to miss that but right now
will fabiano even make it to move
forward he owns one minute 14 seconds
left amira judas still looks really
upset here
he looks very upset but he needs to find
two very difficult moves in this
position first of all he is getting very
long time himself
and i don't want to allow rook up 4.
yeah eventually this is going to be a
big pain
is there any way
i want to play queen f3 so maybe
yeah someday you want to get that queen
there i mean knight f1 is still you know
is still in play then knight f1 knight
two three the problem is if you
guarantee g3 while the queen sits on h3
that's really awkward
what move did he just play f4
and the best move and it's almost three
for white now we saw that that was
recommended
but oh my goodness is the idea he takes
f4 e5 and then knight gf3
oh my god
oh this queen is in the wrong place
that's the problem for fabinho rook
takes f4 allows knight takes e6 which
hits the rook and the queen at the same
time c5 he went knight c5 and did so
quickly but he couldn't take on f4 with
the pawn either even it looks like a
free pawn after e5 with a fork the
bishop takes an e5
and then this knight on g5 it can go
back to f3 and go to e4 but i think even
stronger somehow is almira's queen f3
because queen hits b7 loose pieces drop
off the fact that jan shistov just could
see that
shows that he's a tactical wizard that
he's nuts
and now after knight c5 can't he just
take on e5 and again go knight gf3
so in the game position you're asking
after knight c5 can you just take on e5
and then move the knight from g5 to f3
the queen cannot move away and defend
the bishop at the same time if there was
no c7 pawn you would have to move queen
b8 ironically enough
i think this ends the game
it wins a piece
oh my god judah's gonna see it and he
did and he took
and fabi might simply resign after
knight jf3
unbelievable and do not earn this one
i think we can safely say that duda
earned it
f4
he looks so upset and then he uncorks f4
jkd
not not joking around today
and bobby with nothing else to do but to
take
and knight gf3
it ends it it wins the bishop
unbelievable
what a move f4 what a roller coaster but
at the end of the day and he saw that
while shaking his head
i guess he's still disappointed in his
technique
but it's better to be disappointed when
you've just beaten fabiano
yeah
that was unbelievable knight seven f4
and now they made time patrol as has the
other game we are going to head out for
a quick break don't you go anywhere just
because we're going to break doesn't
mean that you should do the same well
you can't for like two minutes but one
return we will have hikara nakamura you
certainly want we want to hear his
thoughts after a great victory over
alireza frugia we'll be right back here
from 2020 defeated candidates round 10
live from madrid
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights our new tool that lets you dive
deep into all of the fun and instructive
data behind your chest try it today
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are joined in studio by the one
the only grand master hikaru nakamura
hikaru congratulations that was a great
win no thank you
yeah seemed like a pretty smooth game
overall um despite some
some big time usage by both of us in the
opening i guess you could say so would
you say that title tuesday was great
preparation for today
i don't know if title tuesday was great
preparation but kind of just playing
blitz i just took on d4 and went knight
f5 without even really thinking and if i
hadn't played blitz yesterday maybe i
would have used more time to to do it so
i thought i mean i thought it was just
very well played i think the main thing
is ali reza um when he thought forever
to take on f6 with the pawn i think he
thought he was better i think thought
he's better he's trying to press for the
win and then he kind of had to realize
he's worse and i think mentally it was
very hard for him to recover from that
and he just kind of went down without a
fight
two related questions there
another surprise in the opening which
was knight c6 could you walk us through
your immediate reactions to first of all
knight c6 and then sort of blow by blow
what were you thinking after g takes f6
yeah so i mean the thing is when he
played knight six um there are a couple
of things i don't know actually go back
instead of knight c6 if black plays
bishop e7 bishop c4
um bishop e6 bishop b3 knight c6 i think
i had this against alder reza in the
world rapid and um same i think or sorry
it's moscow in 2019 i think i had this
exact position so like during the game
when he played knight c6 uh i try i mean
i looked at something very briefly um
yesterday on this move and then kind of
i just chose over the board to do
something different um and so i played
bishop c4 bishop e6 and i thought okay
because he played he took 10 minutes to
play knight c6 then he plays bishop e6
immediately i realized that he was
trying to transpose into into sort of
our game or some line that i wasn't
really uh expecting and so therefore i
just decided to play an id5 mainly i did
it because i didn't see anything wrong
with it um i suspect it's probably a
pretty silly move objectively i think
black should be fine but i didn't see a
reason that i'm like worse or anything
so i thought okay whatever i get out of
prep and just just play chess um
and then he used time yeah i played rook
c8 and i used like 20 minutes i really
didn't want to take on f6 i basically
want to be like i wanted to play bishop
b6 maybe um
you're like i want to go something like
bishop b6 was one idea or even knight g5
actually instead i should go back yeah
sorry uh knight g5 yeah but then he
plays bishop d5 bishop d5 knight d5
and i mean i spent forever trying to
make pawn takes work because queen takes
d5 queen a5 is just a draw i mean black
maybe is marginally better even but i
mean shouldn't be anything special but i
spent forever trying to make pawn takes
queen a5
um i think queen a5 and like c3 knight
e7 that's something like 94
knight takes d5 and like queen g4
something like this like i really wanted
to play this and and after after like
rook d8 or just castles and and and who
cares throw all caution to the wind but
i mean i kind of realized that
objectively this has to be bad i mean
this is that's probably what you would
play against
yeah you would like the position i mean
this is that i mean it's probably
unpleasant if you don't have like a lot
of time here with black i mean you can't
go bishop e7 i mean it feels
i mean it feels tricky but with correct
play it should should obviously just be
be winning for black so i took forever
and then i'm like okay you know what
i'll just be i'll just be simple and
just play play just standard moves with
knight f6 and then when ali reza didn't
take right away i realized that he was
going to take with the pawn and try to
be ambitious um
and i think i think it's just it just
ends up being a mistake i think for
whatever reason after pawn takes um
i think he just assumed that i was gonna
have to trade on e6 or something of that
nature um
and i just don't end up having to do
that and just he just ends up a little
bit worse i think although it's funny
computer says i'm supposed to take on e6
huh
and play like c3 wow okay
yeah i mean i
i don't know i mean black gets this this
big center here um
maybe f5 maybe d5 i mean yeah what else
the engine i guess doesn't have
depth that we thought bishop e3 was very
strong practically also yeah
i mean i saw i actually i saw some
structures like this and i thought it's
probably okay but it's like why do i
want to do this this better be
principled so bishop b3
and i thought after bishop b3 this i
thought was the moment where ali reza i
mean i don't know if maybe knight a5 is
just bad but i thought knight a5 was
really the only try here i thought after
knight a5 bishop d5 knight c4
white's probably better somehow after
castle's knight b2 um queen b1
but i wasn't 100 sure like trade on d5
knight c4 queen b7 um like queen d7
maybe
uh queen a6 and f5 i mean
f5 rkb1 i mean this is kind of what i
saw something like this i thought it
should be good but
i wasn't sure but once he went 97 i mean
the reason that i think 97 was bad is
because at this point he was still ahead
on the clock but after 97 i play like
five moves without having to think i
mean i just castle um in the next yeah
castles and he has to go like this and
d5 and it just
i mean it's just it's bad because if you
compare this to say the shavashnakov
there's a line where you play 97 early
to force knight f6 but i think black
always has the possibility to castle
queenside and i kind of realized during
the game that when i compare this one to
the chevashenkov with the rook on c8 and
no castles no no castle and queen side
it should just be better for white
objectively
in a way comparing that to costly temple
rooks it's such a natural move but
that's right you lose that right so as
the game continued here at caro it
looked like you know after queen e2 very
principled yeah where was the moment
where you felt like it was better for
you and then you were taken to the next
level i mean i basically thought here
already it's better and the main reason
is because the time had already evened
out i knew ali reza when he took with
the pawn thought he was better than he
wasn't and then i have this very obvious
idea just stack the rooks on the d file
and i mean i basically played all these
moves almost instantly and the problem
is i just don't know what black is
supposed to do here really um
i mean it's it just looks bad i i really
i wasn't sure what he's supposed to do
just to
i mean maybe develop the way he did but
i i i think it's already just very very
hard to play and um i mean he played
bishop g7 which is a human move of
course um i actually thought he probably
should play brook g8 rook g8 and then i
know like g3 bishop e7 or something
but again also for a human like you also
feel kind of stupid because the king is
just sitting on e8 here so eventually
you assume something bad is going to
happen in center like rook d5 or d1
maybe queen c2
i mean again computer probably says
there are no problems because you can go
rook d5 or d8 of course but
i mean i i just i i i don't think it was
practical because again from the get-go
when he took up the pawn he thought he
was better i could definitely feel that
he thought he was better he felt very
aggressive and then to kind of have to
come to the realization you're not
better and then suddenly defend a
position where not only are you like
you're not just a little worse you're
much worse and they're no clearer no
clear ideas i think it was just too much
for him um
and what he did in the game i mean i
just didn't really
i i what he did made sense to me it's
what i expected but
again i mean i i don't know if you're
supposed to just like yeah 97 maybe rook
d7 and then what
rook sees i mean yeah
yeah okay this is insane yeah and it's
also the evaluation is still sky high
yeah
yeah
no i mean i i just don't know what black
is really supposed to do there's no
counter play and
it's just it's just a batch of vegetable
basically that's what it's kind of
turned into here and
i mean i don't know if h3 was best but i
thought okay creates a square for the
king um and also i said it supports g4
because i really wanted to play g4
instead of h3
but if i go g4 right away then he has
like 97 um or d6 queen e4 and maybe the
queen can go to g6 maybe there's f5 h5
somewhere it's i mean it's still
probably again you
oh
jesus oh man
wow okay
how did you miss that
that's beautiful that is really good
just to show everybody so they
understand what's happening here is f3
and this queen on e4 is trapped in the
center of the board
that's very nice yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think you can forgive yourself for
nothing enough like eight moves away
yeah so i mean that's why i played h3
was because i thought i'd just support
g4 just play like a logical move create
space for the king go for g4 move later
um and yeah after c5 this this was the
last moment i guess he could have tried
a5 um
i think if he played a5 here i was
actually going to just go g4 um
and i wasn't really sure i mean
what's he supposed to play in knight uh
knight d4 is okay here huh
ah because i've played g4 so now i no
longer have uh
my queens yeah there's no
no path to h5 or g4 or anything uh maybe
then this is actually quite reasonable
for black to play a5
but yeah still queen c2 queen c2 queen
e6 and
yeah i'm not sure
i mean it should still be better for
white but yeah there's no clear-cut path
so this this was the last moment but i
expected what he did because again at
this point he's getting low on time
there's no increment position is bad and
basically what he does either i'm gonna
win or i'm not gonna win um but it's
like very it's gonna to be very
clear-cut one way or the other um so i
kind of understood this idea
and yeah i just played i didn't i didn't
see the wind in all the lines right away
but i just assumed that i also i thought
that it's very worse i'll always be able
to draw with some bishop h6 takes night
takes and with a knight in the queen
there's no risk of losing so i thought
why not just play it and i mean i think
queen e4 is maybe the last mistake maybe
it can go queen c4
um i think after queen h5 is still
winning but i thought maybe here he can
somehow try to go some e4 rookie five or
something
i mean like rook d8 first yeah rook cd8
first you know okay one and then maybe
maybe you can try to get some e4 rookie
five i think it's still too slow
but with the queen on e4 there's no no
plan to to dislodge the knight from f5
so i think after queen e4 it was just uh
it was just lost basically i didn't
didn't see anything after this um
k1 is really nice and then rick a3
yeah i mean i think they're probably i
can probably even be slower with like
some king h2
but i once once once i saw i mean
basically it took me a while to spot
that after bishop h6 knight h6 king g7
um rook a3
that on f5 there's queen g5 because
actually for for a while i was looking
at knight f5 but after knight five king
h8 there's actually not a win um or
maybe it's still winning somehow but i
mean for for probably like three or four
minutes i i was like how's there no
winner in this position then i realized
just queen g5 instead of knight five and
it's
it's uh quite quite six out of five yeah
yikes
yeah so i mean there just there was
nothing really um that he that he could
have done differently at this point i
think it's just
he tried to be creative and uh i mean
it's just a force it's a beautiful force
made here with just like queen c5 king
h2 and just uh
i mean just queen g7 next next move i
mean the knight on f5 just uh it wins
wins the game basically so it's very
it's very nice to win win the game like
that um and also to win a game where it
seemed like it was pretty smooth because
the other games that i played were not
what i would call smoothie game against
fabiano probably i should have won that
around 40 instead i made a real mess out
of that so it was it was quite nice to
convert what seemed like a pretty smooth
game today i have a question sort of
what you were mentioning about your
preparation you felt like he was trying
to transposition back to familiar
territory and against jan napomchi early
in the event it seemed like he had a
line prepared and then when john
deviated he went to think tank and got
in trouble so do you think that's his
youth showing or what's happening when
players like you and john are playing a
movement comes unexpectedly to him
i mean i it's hard for me to know
because i don't know what his
preparation was before the event but i i
would kind of think that since he had so
much time off something like nine months
to prepare
probably he's been looking at so many
lines up to like move 30 in different
openings and then when you get surprised
at the board i suspect that he's just he
was not really expecting or he's not
used to it and his his reactions haven't
haven't been the best um
so it's just it's it's tough and and
also i mean to be fair though i think
after winning if he hadn't won the last
round i'm not so sure he would have done
what he did today but after winning he
wanted to try to be aggressive um and
again as we've seen now i think like in
my game against timor
alirez against me today and fabiano
against duda you tried to be creative
with black and
bad things seem to happen i have two
rapid fire questions on the subject of
perugia one i asked you before the
tournament
let me clarify do you have sort of a
particular chip on your shoulder when
you're playing perugia because you know
youngest participant in the field and
you know a lot of talk about it and you
want to say whoa i'm not i'm not ready
to pass on the torch to the younger
generation just yet do you feel that
that motivates you or is it
you play the same kind of you motivate
yourself in the same way against
everybody i mean i don't think that
matters but there's a pretty famous clip
out there let's be saying that i'll play
all the resume and the candidates and
i'm gonna beat him so i guess i kind of
had to uh live up to live up to what i
said on my stream i'm sure people will
find that clip somewhere but
uh no i mean i think the thing uh with
ali reza though is
the fact that i played the candidates in
2016 uh when i was quite a bit younger
and i didn't didn't really do so well i
sort of i understand that for ali reza's
tournament is very different and with it
being his first time playing in it there
i think for him there's a lot of
pressure uh for me i don't really feel
like i have to um like defend the older
generation i mean it's uh i'm just going
into it game by game but i do think that
for ali reza there's a lot of pressure
and i also think the fact that he chose
not to play for nine ones was a big
mistake because the problem is when you
don't play for nine months if you don't
have a good result everyone's going to
be very very critical of that approach
and i have to say i think most the
players have tried to do something
similar maybe it's not nine months but
like even four or five months where they
don't play before the cats they
generally don't do very well so i think
it was a big mistake um and he sort of
lost that rhythm and sort of the
momentum he had he was doing really
really well i think he did well in the
european team championship then he did
well in uh the grand swiss i mean he was
on fire and then sort of just stopped
for nine months and not even play online
i think that was a just just a big big
mistake preparation wise for this event
yeah that was sort of my second cool
question he made this crazy decision not
to play any online blitz as far as i
know for something like two years so he
went complete cold turkey
um do you think that
you know what do you think of that
decision that impact impacted his
uh growth in any way uh is that a
reasonable decision in your in your mind
um i just i don't think it's it's it's
smart i think as i said he was he was on
a roll he was 2800 playing very well and
when you have that momentum i mean i
think of i'll actually use magnus an
example there was this period in like 20
i think it was 2011 or 2012 somewhere
around there maybe it was even 2010 but
he got really hot he did well he did
very well in this tournament in china he
just kept playing and dominating every
event and i think for ali raza he he
should have um
and i i also think you know you can say
it's alireza as his his family whatever
management whoever it might be but
i think they just didn't understand how
different this event is from any other
tournament i mean i've said it many
times before but this is the only
tournament where you can finish second
and you feel like you've you've just
had a bad event um you know it's like
fabiano if he loses this game i mean i
guess i guess we're tied for second but
if if fabian let's just say he finishes
on plus two or something wins another
game somewhere it's gonna feel like a
huge huge disappointment for him um and
so i think just for ali raza nadan ali
reza and his team not understanding the
the difference um it was it was just
yeah just probably a lack of experience
um but but i think he'll have more
chances and i'm sure he'll he'll learn
and grow from what's happened here well
quick question about second place
feeling like a disappointment because we
all have heard what magnus said i know
what you said that you you all think
magnus will play but if we hold him to
his word
and fabiano loses this game you're tied
for second place so
you know
of course going to the event everyone's
looking for first but
what does that mean to you and you know
how are you feeling about that
i mean to use the classic line i i mean
i literally don't care i'm just i'm just
i'm just playing one game at a time i
mean as i said i think you know i think
the thing is
you just you can't really rely on the
unknowns so obviously um i i do have
that in the very back of my mind but it
doesn't really play a role in terms of
the the tournament and i just approach a
game by game because i i mean if it
happens it happens but it's a
hypothetical over which i have zero
control it's it's all up to magnus
whether whether he plays or doesn't play
so i'm just not it doesn't really matter
that much to me
i've got one more question for you
you've been working hard even during the
candidates you stream title tuesday
you've been doing videos
uh going over your game and obviously
that's a huge opportunity that people
have never had to just immediately get
an inside viewpoint
uh how much additional confidence would
you say it gives you to know that you've
got a massive community following every
every move and does that ever make you
nervous or would you say that that's
always and that positive um i mean i
think that's a huge nut positive um i
you know i think the the main way that i
look at it is i just simply try not to
embarrass myself in these tournaments
that i play that's i mean from the first
grand prix i played in berlin that's the
only thing that i've seen about i was
trying to just have a good result
nothing else really um
you know i think knowing they're the
fans out there it really um knowing the
fans out there who will cheer for me
even if i don't do well that that does
make a difference it takes a lot of the
pressure off for sure um and also i
think when you see the positivity for
example let's let's just rewind assume
that i was playing the candidates and
let's just say 20 what's it 20 19 or
2018 or one of those years after 2016
but before the whole streaming boom um
and i lost this game to teamwork
yesterday it would have been the end of
the world i would have been very
devastated um to put it mildly
and uh the fact that sort of they're the
fans who are out there
saying you still can play well you can
still do well i mean that that really
does help at the end of the day and um
it's just it's all been been it's been a
while so i'm having a good time but you
are a fierce competitor right yeah i
mean i think the way that i i would i
would look at it as for example with the
the grand prix in berlin when i got the
wild card if i didn't think that i could
be competitive i would not have played
if i was just going to show up you know
if i was going to play blitz against
daniel till 3 a.m to catch a plane
flight and then go play go play in
berlin i i would not have uh chosen to
play so
basically if i don't think that i can be
competitive or i can't put put in the
work then i'm not going to play the
tournament and that would have been the
same for here if i was going to say
stream every day up until up until say a
week before the event i i just simply
would have not played i would have given
my spot away um
so i i try to do is do as much as i can
um and it seems to be working i mean
it's it's sort of been up and down i
mean i it's funny because actually after
i lost this first round game um i i for
whatever reason i felt like i was going
to get my chances with white i feel like
in some ways uh doing the throwback to
2016 i feel like i'm i'm sort of doing
the vichy where in 2016 vishu basically
would win a game with white lose the
game with black then win a game with
white um and then lose with black and i
think he he had something like six
decisive games in a row uh in the middle
of that tournament somewhere so just
just trying you know i just feel like
using using that as the example i'm just
trying to win with white every every
chance i got and you lost round one in
the grand prix and then you bounce back
and beat lavon the second time you got
to play them so do you think that
there's something there because you do
the same thing with fabiano and just
losing to somebody like give you extra
motivation um
i don't know i mean i i think it's just
what happens in the opening really um
but certainly the game against levon
obviously was much different than the
game against fabiano because this game
against fabiano sure i can win draw lose
whatever it doesn't change anything but
against levon i had to win that game or
i wouldn't have qualified um so i think
uh as far as that game goes i just you
know you just you just try to
get something where it's a little bit
tricky but also i think psychology
matters a lot um like in that game
against levon i knew that if i could put
him under some pressure he traditionally
struggles when it comes specifically to
the candidates tournament so
um yeah just try to put them under
pressure and see what happens but i
don't think there's any special
motivation i think i mean a lot of
people especially on reddit are probably
mad at me because i i kind of ruined
fabiano's tournament um by beating him i
thought it was funny to see some
comments like they're like okay so so
you you ruined the tournament yesterday
so that's why you lost against teamwork
which i thought was uh it was that was
some good stuff um i really enjoyed
seeing those comments but i'm just
having fun not really worrying too much
and i think in the candidates um as i've
also said generally players tend to not
play their best chats i think we've seen
a lot of mistakes
many players have missed wins team wars
game against richard just being probably
the most glaring example
and so i'm just trying to play good
chess and not really think about the
bigger picture and um and so i think
that's that's probably the single
biggest reason i've done well in this
this event okay well we are going to let
you go you've been here for a while we
really appreciate your time but we have
a fun video for you so
we're going to show you that and
sure
can we say you're partially retired from
us no i'm not retired from trust
i'll give you that impression i'm
playing the world rap and blitz i'm
gonna play defeated grand prix i'm gonna
win it i'm gonna i'm gonna go beat ollie
rez in the candidates
you guys found it yeah yeah maybe you're
the prophet i know you're sitting next
to god yeah but
i i knew you had to find it yeah i knew
you guys would find it but yeah that's a
great clip yeah
last quick thing what's your starbucks
order what's in that cup uh i actually
don't know because chris goes and gets
it for me every day so i think it's just
regular coffee i think but i'm actually
i don't know i don't know i don't know
well i'll try not to crash your dinner
like the other night so
have a great rest of your evening and we
look forward to seeing you tomorrow
thank you guys tomorrow thank you
that is hikaru nakamura the most watched
chess streamer on twitch he has so many
fans out there and i guess as he said on
reddit he's got some people who are mad
at him because
the man on screen here five minute
karwana he was right behind yon napomshi
as the second half of the candidates
began but it's beginning to look like
fabiano he's not going to be in the
seoul second place anymore he's still
fighting on but as we're rejoined here
by almira
he's down a piece
yeah
it looks like uh an assessment by um
international master natsukanyan who
says like whitehead like is an extra
pound
i think i've shared that story before in
the opinion of i am the second young
yeah white is up at night
[Laughter]
and oh wow we haven't you know we
haven't seen what i'm saying i am seeing
we had a fantastic interview with hikaru
who was saying he's taking it one game
at a time and somebody who is happy to
play these games in the second half is
dingley wren and
that evaluation bar is heavily in his
favor which shouldn't come as a surprise
just as we look at the top left of our
screen there it's two minor pieces for
rook and
the report moved and i guess still red
hasn't arrived back in his chair big
chair little chair
chair little chair but a very happy
dingle run for sure yeah dingle around
us he sits over there at his chair
thinking about the position
is
he's all smiles
but
i'm trying to wrap my head around
how exactly he saves all of his minor
pieces
so if we swing over to that game
and we have ding back on screen we have
the board up there we go analyze to see
how we got here just go go through the
last bunch of moves donna your idea
after the well you go back you further
rook c6 has played bishop a4 to pin the
rook here came b5
then c5 and after the com queen e6
report 39 from bishop h4 looks fine but
black steals a pawn and after rook c1
queen d6 i mean black is everything
under control not too many pawns remain
but black's king is feeling safer by the
turn
yeah it looks like rook d1 here might
have forced a repetition
my guess is that
richard might have been worried about
the bishop sliding down at e4
intercepting the d file but
there's a check on f7 here
the position is totally wild the engine
gives all zeros which is not a surprise
that's always what happens in these
situations
it's the last thing people think right
but i had an idea because then you
mentioned like in the position that we
have on board how ding is going to keep
like
his minor pieces protected but they saw
that maybe he can sacrifice something
and use the pos like the the position of
the bishop on h4 which is very opportu i
cannot see how you can bring him into
play and this b pawn is becoming very
dangerous at the same time is it
possible and you just play like bishop
d4 to make sure that this rook isn't
going anywhere then you're going to push
this b-pawn with the bishop
oh my god the king is totally boxed in
on h1 look at that king yeah the king
can't come out because the bishop covers
almira this is brilliant stuff and i
think
my first reaction let me sacrifice my
rook for this bishop so i'm playing
bishop f6 and then go rook takes d4 but
the problem is if you do something like
this you're just gonna lose because
black will always have this g pawn and
then white's king is too far away and
maybe we can also go pawn hunting at
some moment
on the light squares in particular this
one
this is
minus eight it's a winning end game for
flat i think ding sees it you can just
kind of tell by the body language he's
ready to make a move
and there
and and the thing is i don't think he
would have gone for this line having
already made mu 40
i don't think he would have been going
knight d3
if he thought that he was just losing a
minor piece for nothing
so he definitely sees something is that
something
a takes b5
and we should just show the knight f2
check seems to save the peace but after
king to h2 the problem is your bishop
now is under attack and pinned your
knight is not able to help and he does
play eight against ramirez move is on
the board and just to quickly show like
after a move like king b6 defending the
bishop here this bishop on
h4 comes to life with bishop d a check
your
pieces are falling first the bishop then
the knight and then white would win the
game but almira we have to talk about it
a takes b5 played by dingley wren we
know when he's at his best he is
a menace on the chessboard even though
he's a nice guy what a move
well when i initially thought about this
position i was thinking about bishop e6
first not a things b5 i think that i now
that i see it on the board
it's more precise but you had the idea
in mind after a takes b5 that this rook
is going to have to deal with this pawn
but i guess the problem is the bishop f6
bishop d4 in this situation
maybe there's this
well now i can take on d4 i think
already because
you can't squeeze through to b6 and a5
well that's very important you have to
take the longer route and that gives my
king a chance to make my way to the
queen side and stop your pawn
wow that's a a long journey but just
goes to show how one slight inaccuracy
with your king not getting to v6 and out
in to help the
v-pawn the ushered up the board that
would be a fatal error but
it's not fatal but it would just turn a
win into a draw a takes b5 and rapport
is shocked
yeah he definitely even in the way that
he was writing the move down you could
tell he kept looking over at the board
and
it's important to establish that queen
takes d3 is not forced there is a
serious alternative in queen takes v5
and i'd mentioned something crazy
i wouldn't rule out stalemate ideas for
white if you can imagine a black queen
on d1 with a white king on h2
all of white's pawn moves are
immobilized so
white has defensive chances here
but report just as i say that never mind
i think he took on d3 he did take on d3
knight f2 check comes the knight takes
e4 even and it just feels like yeah
terrible i i get it yeah king is is
a problem but this might just be forcing
and it might already be in territory of
a potential just a win
yeah
it's minus
1.7
but what does white do bishop d4 the
rook is i guess gonna have to slide back
we just proved that you can't sacrifice
on
d4 and once again how important is it to
start with the right move even if you
have the right idea you know like
you should execute it precisely
wow seeingly wren it could be fine and
by the look on richard reports face he
might be thinking that he's lost now we
can see with the help of the evaluation
bar there still are some chances here
and i'm sure he understands that but you
also trust the 2800 rated dingly wren
when he does something like this you're
like uh-oh you gulp and you're now
looking how in the world do i survive
yeah and richard is obviously
not in the best frame of mind after the
last couple of games
and as i've said before when you get
into another bad position you tell
yourself well here we go again that's
going to be another loss you start the
negative self-talk
and it seems to me that in order to save
this position white has to find a very
very precise sequence of bishop and rook
moves and that can be among the hardest
things to do in chess to find these
computerish moves in the end game like
rook d1 here and bishop b7 there and
it's incredibly difficult
to defend a position like this and we're
getting some feature chats here ding is
goaded a z chess from come from arizona
is that danny i don't know ding blitz
mode
yes ding is just
i i don't know what the blitz mode but
he's responsible i think he played
really fast in the last couple of months
i mean just
fantastic play by ding
and
one other important point is that this
pawn
this feels like a sitting duck bishop is
going to come to b7 and once you win
this pawn you have a second passer the
king on h1
it's stuck in a box
yeah
in the long run i don't see a single
defense for light what if you start with
bishop e7
trying to
prevent progress of the pun then maybe
your idea
and then i think i can just play bishop
yeah and just take this phone and
so if i go
there no
what's up there there there so everybody
at home can also know what you're
thinking i actually didn't
[Laughter]
i was trying to to see if there are
still stalemate ideas
but no like the king will always have
the h1 square or the h2 square
if there was no pawn on g2 i would play
king h2
and then i would try to
give away both of my pieces but even
that's not serious you're turning into
eric rosen before my very eyes just
trying to find a stalemate
you know for the sake of the family
hoping that the opponent falls i was
doing it before it was even cool
for the record
almera this position i mean the eval bar
is not suggesting that it's completely
winning for black maybe it needs a
little bit more depth and you know some
more moves but it just looks like a
position that's kind of hopeless for
white well unless hikari said for humans
you know it's very important to
to
to start with this you know it is very
difficult to defend this position i
think it's completely lost
let me read this one because i mentioned
you know for once a year mentioned
johan furter gauss
um
apt's name since he mentions meth hass
reminds me of my math teacher it would
make complex problems seem easy but then
i would end up failing
all the tests anyway
that's a compliment
well is that a hopefully that's a good
teacher but doesn't seem like it if the
student's failing right so that's where
i'm a little lost
yeah i can see the inconsistency i seem
fun but if my student's failing the test
and that doesn't sound like a job well
done
no well maybe we should have a look at
the position on the board and to
we have to
find the best defense
the best defensive approach for white
here
hmm
he seems really different look at me
no no clue
because it's it's this additional idea
that you pointed out of bishop c8 to v7
the fact that e4 is also falling
your hands are
completely tied up
and if you try to defend that palm it's
going to rook d1 and efficient to b7 you
play rook e1 you're not paying attention
to this b-pawn we're just happy to start
going you could play b4 but you can also
start with king to b6 or even bishop c3
and just this pawn pushing this pawn
hanging
it's over in this case
yeah
yeah minus 1.8 evaluation in such
situations is quite meaningless
i feel like
the game might be decided in five six
moves because one little inaccuracy
and that's it
amira are you going to give a report
any chances here
well he's completely shocked i had a
look at his well the pose he um
[Music]
it dawned on him that this position is
very difficult to defend especially with
the king on h1
so he's going for rd4 and he will try to
defend this endgame
and it's kind of what i said right if
this were a blitz game bishop f6 would
be my automatic move because
i'm looking at the position i i trust my
opponent maybe too much but you trust
dingley wren's idea and you're saying
opposite colored bishops we're told how
many times that all opposite color
bishops are drawn even if you're down
one pawn maybe two maybe even three but
here at the start black's actually not
going to be up any pawns but the point
is the quality of the pawns white's e4
pawn coupled with these double pawns
that are isolated on the g file aren't
helpful this king is darting out to a5
to help escort the pawn the other side
it seems like black's play is very easy
i wanted to have a look at the position
which might occur after bishop b7 we
know that king b6 is much faster but if
i play bishop b7 is this a win
for black i think this is a draw because
this isn't true i get my king to the
queens and i play bishop f6 bishop h4
and you can't make any progress
right and just to show what we're
talking about here that's that's an
important question answer this pawn gets
far you give up this pawn on g2 and you
have to think i'm up two pawns i'm
winning here with the black pieces but
the issue is that this bishop will go as
daniel was just saying to h4 so that
even if this king we can make all these
moves you protect your pawn the king
sits on b2 as soon as you play h5 i'm
gonna bring my bishop to f6 and then
play bishop h4 and i can make this move
back and forth forever or make king b1
king b2 or king c3 king b2 whatever and
of course i'm just going to keep this
status quo no possible progress can be
made and it's because of the obstacle of
bishop to your best move just putting
your bishop on the dark squares you
can't do that
i want to point out one more trap okay
you go to the initial position why is
king b6 necessary i think some people
might be tempted to go b4 the problem
with playing b4 is that it falls for
rook b3
and all of a sudden black cannot defend
everything at the same time bishop c3
looks like a water tight defensive move
but
rook takes c3
bc and then you vacuum up both of
black's critical pawns securing an
immediate draw
wow that's actually
a really nice variation there because
once white scoops with that pawn then
it's just a simple draw so
that's really important don't rush you
have a past pawn you're taught to push
it but push it wisely push it real good
as
psalm peppa would say so here comes the
king the b6 first and then we're gonna
push the pawn so let's remove that arrow
king b6 that is the way to go accuracy
is dingley runs the whole name he just
looked up at reporting like i don't
think he has a middle name but
king b6 is the type of move that dingley
wren for sure will play so can we
calculate this line once again king b6
rook d4
you'll take
bishop d4 is king a5 so king ju1
the issue is that i'm just going to
bring my king here and my pawn to b3 and
when i eventually win this pawn
i can throw away a pawn but you can also
bring your king to c2 you have time for
that okay well that's too easy then
i i was this makes perfect sense oh well
first
i made it yeah the wrong movement
you have to bring the king to 82. that
plan is actually necessary ah so don
wanted to bring the king to c2 but not
in time and after the king comes back
for now white has things under control
but after e5
i can put my bishop here you can try to
say you're not moving anywhere but
eventually what's about to happen is i'm
going to take this bond and as soon as i
take this pawn i'm going to win with my
pawns being faster so you can continue
going back and forth many people think
there's nothing that black can do but
once i bring my bishop back
the bishop comes back because if i ever
move my king the pawn pushes and here
h4 takes g3
g2 the bishop is caught
between two different pawns so which one
should we push first
you're giving giving us all the hard
decisions
why i say b2 right it doesn't matter but
takes and then siri also on the bishop
bishop overloaded in two different
directions and that's the winning plan
that's
might be how we see this game conclude
yep i mean this might even be what ding
is currently calculating
because
all he really needs to establish is that
rook takes d4 is winning that's the only
concrete line that he has to calculate
everything else is conceptual everything
else is a matter of figuring out okay i
want to play bishop b6 b4
and this is how i want to make progress
the only actual line is to calculate is
rook takes d4
and while ding is doing just that he has
plenty of time on his clocks yon
napomshi he remains the leader ding
trying to get in striking distance but
the player who held yonder palm shooter
draw that was teamwork job up tina
valencia caught up with timor after his
game
yeah i mean it's a very important line
in general in the catalan that was used
by anne in the match
and
against carlson so
well it's very tricky positions that you
have there
they at first seemingly um you see this
you know all the pawns are equal and
it's uh seemingly nothing but the there
are a lot of ideas in this uh in this
line that he played and also the one
that uh carlson played against me in
norwich's just uh
i don't know a few weeks ago
and
actually i lost that game as black and
made some inaccuracy in the opening and
then
[Music]
i think he showed a great technique
well today's lines with knight c3 is the
different one and
white is always pressing on the c4 pawn
and once you make just the one wrong
move at some point
you just lose the pawn and then you get
very bad in game so
the idea is not to lose the pawn which
is not so easy to do actually and um
yeah he was seemingly upset about the
fact that
um according to analysis i think he said
that queen c7 is the move in general
there i also remember that there are
some ways but um yeah i didn't remember
what was exactly the difference between
the queen a5 and which seven in this
position
so uh
generally trying to play a bit faster in
in my recent games so i just saw that
okay i mean i should just move because
sometimes i mean in the first half of
the tournament i would spend maybe one
and a half hours here on deciding which
move is the best and why
but um
i think i played queen a5 and after that
uh
i don't know if if the the play was
correct but i didn't see anything
anything great for white but i'm not
sure why he was uh disappointed exactly
that was sort of summary that jan
napomishi said where he felt like that
queen to a5 move was inaccurate but what
java was saying it wasn't a big deal
what is the big deal ding lee wren just
played king to b6
he's the calculator right he knows what
to do and he i think you're right donna
has seen the end of this game there's a
moment in most games
at this top level when you can just feel
that the players already know what's
going to happen they already know what
the result is going to be
that's what you just said and i feel
like in ding's body language in the
speed of which he's playing because ding
is not shy about taking his time like
you said he's the calculator once he
starts playing fast and once he starts
making these accurate moves you know
he's got everything forecasted until the
end of the game this one is essentially
over
and almira yon napomashi when he was in
studio he said
or at least he hinted that he's happy
that he has already played his two games
against dingley wren now the first game
ding seemed a little out of his element
maybe it was the recent
trip to madrid some jet lag or just poor
play in round one
but dingley run in this form
problem well and also lee had the few
missed opportunities in this tournament
i feel that he's back in the race
already after this game but um
what well if he would have won one of
those games once again what what could
have happened now
so well we don't want i have to wonder
what could have happened in this game
because while dingley ran he spoiled a
huge advantage against richard report in
their first matchup
we called it this is exactly what we're
anticipating and you call it the
variation we were just showing that that
might be how this game concludes i think
it is i think it is
i think once he puts his king on a2 and
his pawn on b3
or maybe once he wins the pawn on g2 uh
report will resign now the funny thing
is
you can even allow white's epon to get
to e7
all you need to do is win the g2 pawn
nothing else matters as long as you
contain the e pawn
wow so this one is
essentially over and while dangling the
red no longer has yonder palm she on a
slate of opponents he's still off four
games after this we are waiting to see
the conclusion this one likely a win
against richard report but he is black
against five-minute car one and next and
if ding wins and as we have been
uh thinking for a long time that five
new carolina would lose they'd be tied
in the standings so almirah
i mean ding he can try to keep going
of course and he has uh well two blacks
and two whites at the end of the
tournament so
um looking at his round 12
with white pieces against him or rajabov
and
he might actually target this
game
you have to
play for win somewhere and hikaru said
that you can't just force a win out of
thin air with black that's how you get
in trouble ding hasn't seemed to be that
type of player so don't you agree to
round 12 right against for java that's
what ding's looking forward to yeah i
mean he's basically been in trouble the
least of anybody in this tournament i
mean he lost that one game against nepal
that was it
and again look at the speed with which
he is executing the winning plan as he
decides to start with b4 but he's going
to follow up with king a14 b3 and king
a2
but
he's got several games of the white
pieces that he is going to try very very
hard to win the game against
think black against icaru
is a game that he's also eyeing while he
razzle lost today he's going to go all
in the rest of the tournament alireza is
not forcing a berlin draw so ding i
think he's rearing to go he's won two in
a row
and
he's still entertaining
visions
of crazy things happening and he wants
to put himself into a position to
benefit if crazy things happen and amira
hikaru said he's not thinking about
second place because it's the what ifs
what do you think about ding it was a
what if for him to even
qualify for the candidates he was unable
to play games outside of china
beforehand now if he can get into second
place
withstand some pressure from five under
carwana
you think he's thinking about a world
championship match against jonathan
machine well he certainly does first of
all he said that he was already so lucky
to qualify for this tournament so one
step at a time
i think that
he
[Music]
his form is back
he was struggling at the beginning of
the tournament so i think he is taking
it's also like hikaru one game at a time
and
well
the decision is not his at the end of
the tournament we will have to see you
[Music]
what will happen
yeah and we have both dingley rand and
fabiana carona facing us really just
calculating at the moment on the board
but
two players with very different results
in this game and fabiano he's been in
trouble since the beginning
dingley run i wonder if he even knew
what was going on at the beginning of
the game because it was hectic but right
now
the eve out bars in totally different
directions robert can we get just get
back to the position where um dink
played king b6 okay so we'll bring up
the analysis board there so when ding
click into b6 yes was there any way to
defend this position with bishop d8
i guess the king just comes up through i
just see it
okay so one avenue or the other doesn't
have to be park avenue it's okay to go
down
madison avenue right there's on the west
side oh really yeah nice try though
intimately familiar with the geography
of manhattan you you did get an avenue
that exists though so i'm proud of you
thank you yeah i couldn't name an
average charlotte but also i'm not
interested no no i'm sorry okay
so the king is just going forward he's
trying to help this pawn go and as we
see
this one would still be completely
winning for black so
live position we're going to catch up to
it the bishop took on d4 the white king
is trying but it is going to be
too slow as king b3 king a2 upon b3 we
showed this variation just before and
this pawn on g2 being on a light square
if you could just push the pawn to h2
we're making a draw here yeah the pawn
on g2 is an issue as the bishop will
start scooping up
this one here and the black pawn will
sacrifice itself leading to victory yeah
this uh
you know the way the rest of the game is
going to play out illustrates an
important concept for obstacle bishop
end games which is that
you want passers on opposite sides of
the board you don't normally want
connected passers
bishop can deal with connected passers
it can blockade them along a certain the
color of the bishop but when you've got
disjointed pastors especially ones that
are on either side of the board the
bishop has absolutely no chance because
it can really only stop
once it can control one side of the
board at one time
and this is a great illustration of that
theme here and
richard might resign here he might make
a couple of moves but
the the result is no longer in question
and almer we've been discussing this
uh earlier than dingley wren he's like a
second half player last time in the
candidates he struggled mightily in the
first half he lost his first two games
and in the second half he was great he
only lost to an each geary but won a
bunch so he'll be at six wins and only
that one lost in each geary with of
course many draws in the second half and
this is his third candidate so
what do you make of him as a player in
in the long tournament
well that's a tough question you know i
think that um
what affects him a lot is first of all
that he
his team is in china he could not be
joined by his seconds or by his family
he didn't have enough time to adapt
himself at the first half of the
tournament so maybe he should always
consider
like in russia he came like before
i think three weeks before the
tournament starts it's also
went wrong so he needs to to find a
balance between his preparation his
shape and
give
give his body the time to adjust to the
tournament
for sure and i know donya has a golden
state warriors reference ready for us so
dingley wren third quarter player oh
yeah just like the warriors exactly good
one but i mean in all seriousness uh
something
has gone wrong for him in the first half
of the last candidates and this one and
you were mentioning the what ifs the
hypotheticals like what if dingley wren
could show the form that he is showing
right now in round one
second candidates in row he lost the
first round and we actually
run wow we have a great
first of all great username joker and a
fool but jan a first half player being a
second half player if they fused they'd
be unstoppable and maybe there's
something to that where yon
he gets out the gates running he's
really strong in the first half of the
canons the second candidates he
dominated the first half in this one and
the last one he also was doing really
well before losing round seven to maxine
bush lagrave and dingley wren
struggles in the first half and then
kind of dominates the second half so
maybe they need to find a way to trade
off some talents well
richard said that he doesn't see anyone
beating magnus in the near future even
even if you combine two players so maybe
this is the perfect combination you know
we should combine yan
and jing
and here it is
okay well that would be a very
interesting mix of players
richard report perhaps the most
interesting player in the entire world
he always is ready to light up the
chessboard but he's on the clock we'll
let him think about what seems to be his
inevitable demise over the board so
we're going to head to break we'll be
back in a few minutes for the end of
round 10 here at the phoenix candidates
2022 this is chess.com coverage live
from madrid
you can watch top chess events right on
your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
i figure it's time for me to really
blend in you know dress like a local
i don't
i obviously wear jackets all the time
okay
so
we're ready for the candidates every
local madridian visits the chessboard
on a daily basis i hear they visit and
kind of
pay tribute
to queen isabella herself this is a
i hear that uh
this is
this is a statue of queen isabella
herself
yeah we are here at the 2022 candidates
tournament in madrid spain and we have
our man on the inside danny wrench who's
been with the players a lot going to the
players meetings and he's here to tell
us about some special requests that a
few of the players made danny what have
they been talking about yeah well
obviously we want to and always ask the
players and get them in the spirit of
the city right the uh the place that
they're playing from so a couple of
actually kind of unique ones that have
been that have been thrown out there and
i'm going to try to represent these as
well as i can to fit a okay but the
first one was
a lot of bonus requests if you play and
win with the spanish on either side
makes sense right makes sense um
there was a uh
a suggestion you know that anytime you
move the queen you you drop a dab for
queen isabella yeah yeah she's the one
that made the queen power makes sense
okay um but then the players were
unanimous on one in particular which was
that every two hours into every round
they'll have now a required siesta well
we'll see if any of these rules are
implemented for the tournament uh
especially if somebody plays the spanish
they got some money coming their way
yeah it doesn't seem likely but uh i
don't even want to know which players
made these requests but i've got a
couple ideas in my mind yeah well you
know and uh if and anything that gets
the players to play something more than
the berlin right the most exciting draw
in the world now that we have some money
on the line perhaps we see some exciting
some exciting spanish games so i'm i'm
actually excited about that one there
you go you need some alex honnold on us
yesterday
the alex honold of chess folks climbing
without a rope oh wait i can do it
i don't know why i'm doing this but i
feel like a little kid when i get around
big things slowly checking our insurance
like chess parkour
oh did you catch that on camera can you
tell he's a dad of a teenager
always move like a night guys i think
i'm gonna go hit a siesta over there
with the uh seems like the thing to do
with the locals you do you baby girl
yeah yeah okay i'll see you guys in a
couple hours
yeah
it's been a long day dan you deserve it
buddy
you deserve it
go ahead and throw that down and
just
buckle up buddy
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed
you can also organize kids into clubs
and send them messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
blitz chant is coming this july watch
your favorite nfl stars compete for
their share of the 100 000 charity prize
fund legendary wide receiver and future
hall of famer larry fisher will be
joined by some of the biggest names in
the league catch cleveland browns
receiver amari cooper dallas cowboys
linebacker micah parsons top five draft
pick and new new yorker k von thibodeaux
and others it all goes down on july 9th
and 10th starting at 1pm pacific time
right here on chess.com well right here
on chess.com we have the coverage of the
10th round of 2022 fedex candidates i'm
joined by international master elmira
skripchenko this is grand master daniel
naradiski i am grandmaster robert hess
and we have two games remaining here in
the 10th round we know that yon napomshi
maintains his lead ahead of the field
but we have rich report trying to save
what it seemed like an increasingly
hopeless position richard
yeah it's you know he knows it's over
right elmira as we look at him on camera
here
his head's in his hand he's just trying
to figure out is it definitively so or
is there even some chance and with so
few peace in the board
well we know that this is over we have
analyzed every line every possible line
in this position so it's actually a very
instructive chest anyway yeah no it's a
fantastic end game it's one that should
go in the books but one player who
refuses to lose without always fighting
to the very end is fabiano caruana he
is slugging it out despite the fact that
he's been down a piece for a while and
this position actually isn't that clear
like
we
thought that he was done we thought that
young stuff dude for sure was gonna get
his first victory and now as we bring
the board up with our 30 000 viewers on
twitch still here you know i got to give
you a shout out i appreciate you so
night
f2 was the last move and what a move
that is
it's a very fancy trade and fabi has
defended resiliently creatively
tenaciously all tournament long
remember his game against c car i mean
that was incredible he lost that game
but he's
he didn't get discouraged and he's
trying to do it again today the problem
robert i think is that the narrative is
similar to the game against icaru where
he's trying he's finding ideas but it's
not going to be enough i think jan is
going to take that knight he just did
he's going to shift the queen from h3 to
g3 and there are simply going to be too
many threats against black's king and if
black tries to trade queens with queen
v6 which maybe is the most
prudent defensive option
jan schuster is going to say i'm happy
to trade queens
two pawns it's two puns too many he's
fabi's never getting to that b5 pawn all
right the b6 will be a target i want to
show why knight f2 was such a cool move
and why white didn't just have a hanging
knight so in this position it looks like
this knight on d3 can just be captured
but yan shistop has had fantastic
tactics all game queen takes d3 allows
this one to go to a8 with chad oh my god
queen
king h7 runs into knight g5 check to
your king and hello to your queen you
have to take my knight and you lose the
queen on d3 so if you go to g7 instead
the only legal move with the king
there's queen g2 check and after rook g6
you think your king is safe but i'm
sacrificing my queen for your rook and
playing knight e5 check almira all game
it's felt like there were a couple
moments maybe where young chaser went
wrong but all game it's really he's
seeing tactics everywhere and this is
absolutely brilliant
especially at this stage of the game we
know that
after the time control
you're more tired of course so
players have been calculating uh
complicated lines
throughout the game so uh
this is a just a perfect solution
that beautiful tactical sequence and
it's not going to happen the queen did
just slide over to g3 trying to go into
e5 the c7 pawn is hanging so fabiano he
might have to play queen d6 but as we
indicated queen d6 once the pieces come
off it's going to be a win for white you
can simply protect your rook over here
on f2
hopes to get this pawn this knight can
come into d4 and this pawn is hanging as
long as white has one pawn remaining it
will be a win but fabiano he doesn't
have any better options he's going for
this so queen to d6
he's
i'm surprised the game is still going
honestly and
well maybe he feels like he has some
slim chances
yeah i suppose that
there's a decision jkd has to make here
which is that he can also go king g2 and
try to trade on his own terms
i'm not sure that there's such a big
difference i think ultimately
every line all roads lead to rome here
or warsaw maybe in this case
but here's the thing
what's going to happen i think is that
jan kristoff is probably going to give
away the b5 pawn
now he's going to give it away for the e
and d puns and he's going to win black's
h pawn and knight rook and h pawn versus
rook is completely winning right right
we're not talking here about wrong
colored bishop this is a an easy
theoretical win
that's that seems to be that and duda
he's looking much more composed than
we've seen him in previous rounds and
even earlier in this game when he
overlooked after that knight h7 move
that fabiano could slide his rook over
so for young chistop
we said that every player will play a
part in who wins this event and he may
be playing a part in who doesn't win
this event because fabiano he was a half
point behind yana palmashi after seven
rounds now he is about to suffer his
second loss in three games
young sister is a troublemaker what do
you want to say yes
i don't know if he's a troublemaker you
know he's uh
he's got a lot of fans he's a good guy
he just uh happens to be winning a chess
game
i mean i i streamed yesterday for a bit
during the rest day
and it was crazy to me how many people
were just you know
shoveling dirt on on young trista and
saying you know why is he in the
candidates he deserves to be there first
of all somebody's got to be in last
place somebody always has a bad
tournament
and i made the point that he's going to
win one game and then everybody's going
to be singing his praises so the best
thing to do is just to realize that
everybody who's in the candidates
deserves to be there you never get into
this tournament if you're not worthy of
it
and
to get back to
a point i've made several times already
if the first round results had been
different you've made this point as well
then we'd be having completely different
conversations so nothing is
deterministic right anything could have
happened
the reason that things did happen the
way that they did
a lot of it is due to the skill of the
players but some of it really is due to
moments individual moments that could
have gone either way that's what makes
it so fascinating to watch also
you know what i'm saying
rant over
all right safe to talk now
professor proton
oh well fabiano you know he
just looks like he's had enough
and
the candace is a brutal tournament where
there's only one winner and everybody
else
they pack their bags play the next chess
sermon but they won't be playing a match
at the end of it all against magnus
carlsen
so
by the way dingley rents king is on d3
while richard reports king is on d6
reports game with the other way because
he recognized that the ending was
completely losing if he brought it to c1
he calculated that to the end just like
dingley ren did so instead rapport
brought his king up
towards black's side of the board but
ding ridge did something very smart so
we'll bring up an analysis board just to
show you his
last couple moves here
as we likely are about to see
this game come to inclusion
after king 2 d6 he could have pushed his
pawn to b2 and it does happen that it's
winning but you start thinking as this
pawn goes up the board starts walking
its way maybe you can have some chances
of the king of pawn in game so what ding
does instead it just brings his king
back because he realizes that with the
white king so far away he could just
grab the pawn go right back there to c2
game plan
and white has nothing
yeah he's about to play king d3 and then
king c2 and i think report will resign
right here
it won't be a moment too late if he
resigned after king to d3 because the
plan is simple same exact plan king c2
bishop comes to b7 takes this pawn h
pawn walks up the board to sacrifice
itself and the g pawn or the b pawn will
queen
very impressive mic drop
i mean to survive such a complicated
position to survive let's not forget
the crazy move report made was it knight
c4 yeah knight c4 ding took it in stride
he took that knight quickly he survived
time pressure he found the best line
the dude is a beast it's like he's
totally unaffected by the course of the
game and he manages to stay objective to
stay calm all of those skills
are skills that we should appreciate and
value
amir he did take this night very quickly
like
i would be stunned i'd be looking like
can i actually take that richard such a
creative genius but as daniel said that
he just
let the knight there he took it and that
was that do you remember their first
game like the the game they played in
the first leg of these candidates uh
well that's game all the yeah i do
remember the first time richard
sacrificed the knight on d4 and ding
didn't win that's right but this time
dingley run does in fact win the score
sheets are signed the arbiter stops the
clock he does the traditional thing
putting the king on the dark squares in
the center and digging the red he smiled
after his previous win against john
schuster duda he seems like he's been in
it for a long day the rest day didn't
just happen because he had to give every
ounce of energy to a victory over
richard reports a bad day for report
great day for dingley wren and wow five
minute carwana i i really thought his
game could be the second game done
but now he's still fighting he's the
last game of the round
yeah i mean
i essentially think the game is decided
and the reason i'm so confident is
because there are no more tactics in the
position
at this point the path to victory
is incredibly straightforward you take
the pawn on e6
and then using the offer of a rook trade
you drop back down to e5 you win the
pawn on h5 and at some point fabi is
going to resign he's going to realize
he's already realized that the game is
over but he's obviously still making
moves
still trying every last little resource
and i can't imagine how painful this
moment is for him right because he came
into today
he had his interview after his drug and
tian he said it's the lead is not
insurmountable
and he went for it today and jan chistop
just played an excellent game of chess
right there were very few if any
question marks from his side
and for fabiano it's again what if what
if i had beaten janna the first time we
played what if when we played right
before the rest day i had made use of my
preparation and scored a full point and
now not only did he not beat jana pomshi
he's about to lose to yanchistov duda
he's going to be one and a half points
behind our leader on the other hand well
kudos to fabiana he
he tried everything is well he he's
literally dying on the board in every
game
so
this is uh this is so admirable
it really is and he gives it his all
but jan chistoff also does the same
right despite the fact that he's had
three losses he could have just shipped
this tournament like all right i'll try
to make some draws who cares at this
point but he came to fight still and
that's the type of person and player he
is where he loves chess he said in
interview ever since a kid he wanted to
become world champion and he thought
that it was possible and it's not going
to happen this time around but maybe in
the future he can fight for that world
championship
you know what impressed me maybe the
most the fact that he managed to find f4
on move 39 yeah because he was going
through that here we go again phase he
was shaking his head
he screwed it up a little bit
and rather than letting that get to him
maybe he was letting it get to him
emotionally but he hunkered down he
found a brilliant tactical resource to
turn the game around once more and
secure the victory that is the sign of
someone who is mentally strong
emotionally strong and somebody who's
just unwilling
to give the game up when you hit
adversity for the first time in the game
chess.com gives that a brilliant move or
they will in the game review that
deserves like four brilliances it's
honestly an amazing tactic
so instructive
but remember i said like i don't want
you to play rook f4 and f4 is such a
brilliant move in this position
it's crazy
yeah the f4 is just
a phenomenal move i don't honestly care
what anybody says right that's a
brilliancy and also the way the game was
going and we saw that after knight h7
rookie six that just a few moves before
i can show that moment here where when
the knight came to h7 it looks like it's
a game over winning tactic and after
fabiano slid his rook over yan chistop
was not very happy and he looked like he
was getting down on himself so to
make sure that he remained composed and
then just a couple moves later to play
this f4 move
he is such a fantastic player and that
was a bright moment in an otherwise
gloomy tournament of course and we were
having a feeling that he is losing the
threat of the game after knight h7 and
rook g6 but
he
gained his composure
very quickly and he found
the only moves in this position
you can see him putting the finishing
touches here as he maneuvers his knight
to the center
getting ready to cut the king off with
rook d6 track the key here is to get the
white king up toward g5 to use the
knight as both a shield against
flexworks checks and as a defender of
the h4 prong once the king leaves h4 you
want to make sure the knight is ready to
defend that pawn should the black rook
slide over to h1
and now king f4 and king e5 is very
strong because the pawn will be
untouchable
yeah rook g4 checked thank you for the
pawn but as daniel's indicating the
knight comes to f5 with a fork
protecting h4 tactically
and
yeah this is just you know almost enough
at this point if this king gets to f6
and the knight to f5 we're already gonna
see black and check bobby might resign
right now
i haven't been particularly accurate of
predicting when people are resigned but
he did just look at the clock
glance over there there's no time
trouble so it's not about that it's just
yeah i think you're right that he's
thinking about when to resign
and
when he resigns the round is over at
least by the moves in the chess board
but it's not over here in the studio
five minute car want to has resigned two
for two you got it and dingly wren will
join us in the studio for an interview
so even though the chess has been played
out for the day you will not want to
miss that interview fabiano carwana well
he probably wishes today didn't happen
but jan schistov duda on the other side
of this what a victory by him
an incredible game and
as commentators we're unbiased we're
rooting for everyone we're rooting for
good games to be played that's what we
want
but when somebody has a rough tournament
and recovers and plays a game like this
you can't but be happy for him even if
you're a fabby fan
you've got to be happy with the way that
duda played you got to be happy for him
the tournament is not over he's going to
try to ride his momentum tomorrow but
what an incredible performance we were
treated to by
the pull with three
names the poll with three names and well
the results from this round
some
i mean another day full of decisive
action we saw
report just
resign and lose the dingly ren we also
saw karwan do the same and lose to
yanches of duda yanda palms he made that
draw and hikaru we can't forget that
game he came in the studio gave a great
interview but he played a magnificent
game himself
yeah today was a day of clean games
well maybe the ding report game i don't
know if clean is the adjective but i
would use to describe perhaps we will
ask ding what adjective he will use to
describe that game but the end game
technique certainly was clean and super
instructive kudos to duda that almost
rhymes and of course yukar nakamura he
said that you know the matchup of the
generations that wasn't really on his
mind but hey oldest competitor against
the youngest participant hikaru proved
that he had still has a lot a gas left
in that tank and now mirror as we you
know head on over to the standings where
we know yon napomshi that's been the
prevailing storyline he's in first place
but we look down after him three players
now tied for second place what do you
make of that mosh pit
well we're we are going to have
well 300 rounds you know ahead of us
because every player who
who's tied for the second place you know
they're
they will push
in in every game so today i'm struggling
with my headaches so
i don't know what the players
do yeah the moves were definitely
dizzying so we understand the dingley
red versus which report it gave us all
we could handle but dingley wren he's
right there tie for second so danya as
we look forward to tomorrow's matchups
and we know that there's a three-way tie
for second which could be important
unlike previous candidates uh let's
take a peek which matchup catches your
fancy
well we've got hicarro against rehearsed
report that is definitely a game that he
car will be looking to win richard is
really scuffling right now he's lost
quite a few games to start the second
half of the tournament
i mean really all of these are
fascinating and i'm particularly excited
for that last match of caruana against
dingley run ding has just won two games
in a row fabi has lost two out of his
last three in the game he drew was still
disappointing will he be able to
re-emerge from his tail spin or will
dingly ren and will ding liran take
serious risk with the black pieces to
try to extend this winning streak to
three i can't wait
sir almira we have farouza against
napomerci alareza bad day today but
tomorrow he probably will fight on well
i realized certainly all in at this
point in the tournament so he's going to
throw himself at yan
and
even during his interview he said that
he's
been waiting for this game because jan
is in the top
his
form so he wants to
he wants his revenge first of all and
this might affect also the standings oh
it certainly will if farouza can beat
yon upon she and then we have karwana
and ding and of course hikar with that
great record against rich report if
farouza can do everybody else a favor
this tournament is blown wide open
it's it's blown completely wide open
that's what i love the fact that
somebody who's not necessarily
contending for first place can still
make their impact leave their imprint on
the final standings of the tournament
some people say that's a bad thing
i think that's a good thing i think
that's what makes this tournament so
fascinating and for alireza ferrugia i
think the important thing for him today
is to take
and extract the lesson from his loss
against carl he forced it robert he
forced it with g takes f6 he's got to
let the game come to him and he's got to
play objectively tomorrow against dion
but everybody is holding their
collective breaths as they watch that
match up for sure well it's going to be
some fantastic games of chess tomorrow
but for now we are going to take a quick
break and the reason why is we bring
dingley wren into the studio he'll be
here right after this short break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is our privilege to be joined by the
number one chinese player in the world
the number two rated player in the world
ding li ren ding how are you feeling
after your second win in a row yeah i
feel very good uh
even better than last time than the last
round because today i think i played
very well throughout the game
i
i
i
prepared in the opening and
i prefer this line
and long not for this game but some time
ago but
in the game it just
occurs on the board
so i know this idea rook v8 through v7
at some point
and the idea is just to delay castling
if
if
there is some
and not castle immediately so
and the game just went and was what i
i wished
saying knight c4
really surprised us two questions did
you see that move because you reacted
really quickly
and super super accurately so what went
through your mind when richard played
knight c4 on move 30 33. and of course i
missed i didn't see it
i thought he might go back with bishop
f7 try to put the knight on b3
or something like um
bishop h4 try to
push the queen to f7 or f8 but of course
i didn't seem nice anymore
so so take us through that he plays
knight c4 you responded pretty quickly
so
you didn't expect it but did you just
calculate it that quickly that you could
safely no i thought it's the only move
after i take on g5 i i know maybe i can
also play queen b4 but during the game i
thought at least i saw knight bc b take
c for bishop a4
and still i had to
i have to play rook c86 i think
96 or maybe knight c6 also fine queen
five queen six
queen age seven kings
yeah
i want a crazy position so during the
game ding
when you were getting this game it was
very unclear did you feel like you were
doing well throughout or you weren't
sure yeah i think the most important
position is when i play bishop d4
move
no no before
yes the queen of war here i spent a lot
of time
on knight's first knight c6
since i didn't want to exchange the
bishop because after he sacrificed the
pawn he had e4 for knight and e1 for
rook
just showing that very quickly right
there we were talking during the game so
you were thinking about knight c6 yeah
c6 clever if you take i just take a look
but he has
look c1
and if knight b4
bishop f7 check oh
wow and i'm going to play king of fade
you're calculating this during the year
yes
i think he can
he
he only knows bishop c4
to force a draw
can you hear it
and bishop is seven i don't know the
evolution box says why is it better but
i don't know how i think this is his
only chance to
that's absolutely incredible yeah and
it's such a such a privilege to see our
calculations during the game
questioning uh yesterday you beat yan
shistaff it looked like an equal
position
how much confidence did yesterday's win
give you and what were your thoughts
about the game in general
well yesterday at first i have some
small advantage out of the opening but i
want to
i want um
i want more with a4 not b3 b3 is more
solid more perception but i play a4
uh
i want to play and take takundi and
i think he defends very well until
until the last point because he moved
rook d2
in the last game
at around 30th move
it look d2 knight a5
g6 is good good move to play the king on
g7 it was missing by me and also next
check and rook c2 is very important here
my first intention played bishop d3
i think it's just winning for white rook
c1 knight v6 and he found the square on
a1 uk1 only move and king g2 knight h5
although i have the overwhelming
advantage on the queen side but
just one thread knight for 1995 it might
be prepared to check
and you know you tend to be thought of
as a solid player but you're showing us
all these tactics so
how do you train yourself for these kind
of moments like in today's game you're
just showing us bishop f7 check is very
wild how do you prepare for those
moments
well now the the game is not
not
uh it's different from before
since everybody wants to play some
concrete line they like to
calculate until the end
so maybe there not so much position
where you can
press press and with
small advantage just the position get
very
complicated um very soon
so
last question from meeting fabiano
caruana tomorrow
you've won two in a row fabiano is
struggling he lost today
but you have the black pieces what is
your mindset going into tomorrow's game
and
how much risk are you thinking about
taking or is that something you're going
to decide
i think it depends on possession he must
became very well prepared
like before
it's almost important prioritizing the
opening i need to
handle the pressure it gave me then
if i have some chance of course i will
pray for a win
okay well i have two quick questions and
i promise we'll let you go i know it's
late so magnus carlson of course said
that you know he wanted to play all the
razor furuja alareza not the top of the
standings do you feel like you know
second place i know you came to termite
wanting first but do you feel like
you're now right and time for second
place is that something you've been
thinking about
yes yes now i'm already tied for second
place with ikaru and
fabi
so
yeah i think we are fighting full of
second place
okay and uh i already forgot my last
question
i had so many but uh ding it's really an
honor to have you in the studio we've
had two great wins so we like to see you
doing well so congratulations and good
luck tomorrow thank you good luck thank
you
and as we see
the people of spain walking around
enjoying themselves we are probably
gonna do the same
we're gonna say good night to everybody
who's tuned in we really appreciate your
continued viewership and we want to
thank all the players and especially
dingley red here at the end it's been a
late night he's had two
long games he won and well we'll see you
tomorrow same time same place live from
madrid spain see you tomorrow for round
11 undefeated candidates
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you